I just find it extraordinary that you would think the Holocaust
could ever be something that we could joke about. Why? Too soon.
Dude, Pierce Piers got so caught off guard by that. Holy sh
Holy,
dude. What?
Okay, without further ado, guys, we're going to get to >> one
of the people the primary piece of content for the stream. Okay,
the primary piece of content. Here it is. The Piers Morgan Nick
Fentes interview. Whatever. All right, I'm psyched. Here it is.
Piers got I do believe Piers kind of got wrecked a little bit.
Okay, Piers Piers sort of kind of got wrecked a little bit and
it does suck. It is unfortunate,
but he did kind of get owned. I thought I thought All right.
by Nick. Yes.
So, here's the problem with Piers. I watched a good chunk of
it. Okay. So, we're watching it again. We're just having a good
time here watching it. All right. But my biggest issue with Piers
is that there are real criticisms of Nick, even from like the
clips he's doing, but Piers doesn't really hit on them. Pi sort
of plays the clip and it's like
little spoiler, slight spoiler, okay, but we all knew this clip
was going to come up. Oh, you said was cool. Why'd you say was
cool? That's crazy. And it's like, okay, but that hints at an
underlying thing going on where you care where you like he's
got some beliefs, but Piers barely if ever goes after the underlying
beliefs. He almost always just goes at the surface level of the
clip and goes, "Uh, excuse me. Excuse me. You can't say cool.
That's
crazy." Right? That's like how PICE handles a ton of the interview.
He just he just like tries to virtue signal which is crazy
because
he literally wrote a book called woke is dead. Yes. Exactly.
Exactly. Ken the Jelly man. He uses he basically just uses the
woke tactics in this interview a ton of the time. Yes. Yeah.
Okay. Everybody everybody knows this is my main complaint when
I was watching it. I was chatting with some people. This is my
main complaint was basically he's just the whole time he's basically
being the woke person. instead of actually diving in and asking
and you could get Nick to disavow Nick basically if you go deeper
he's got to disavow his beliefs or he's got to
yeah he's got to disavow his beliefs or he's got to like try
to make a joke and you can actually do something but instead
Nick just gets to like signal like oh yeah I can't be contained
like I I'm actually too cool for you to woke scold and that's
that's the broad content of the or that's the broad character
of the interview anyway let's check it out it is really good
it's
Um, Nick still didn't come off good, though. Uh, he came off
exactly how he wanted to come off, which is probably offensive
to a large portion of people. But realistically, how much more
does he have to grow? Like, this video had 100,000 concurrent
viewers. How much more does it have to grow? Does he have to
grow more or does he just have to be who he is and not care?
Right? Like, usually the reason you'd say, "Oh, don't go don't
extend yourself further. Don't like go crazy." is because you
don't want to cut off like future growth. But Nick's not cutting
off like what what more does he have to grow? Making like $100,000
a month. Do you have to grow >> You're a New York Times
reader, an NPR fan, a Daily Wire subscriber, or an avid consumer
of all things Tucker Carlson. For several months now, there's
been no avoiding the subject of Nick Fuentes. And let's be clear,
the main reason you're hearing about him is because he's popular.
A large number of people, especially young men, are interested
in what he has to say. What that says about our society and our
culture is the subject of ferocious debate. For many people,
it's a grave indictment of an insidious immorality. For others,
he's a product of a culture which has turned on its own and left
many young people feeling listless and bitter. He's either a
litmus test for right-wing hypocrisy on free speech or a walking
talking manifestation of where the line should be drawn. And
a frankly preposterous amount of air time has been spent on debating
everything from his ideology to his and whether Okay.
Okay. That could be an argument for other people. Frankly, a
crazy amount of air time has been dedicated to this guy. Yeah.
By who? By you? By Piers Morgan himself. Constantly talking about
Nick Fuentes. Piers Morgan totally like taking all of the views
for talking about this but not wanting any of the responsibility.
Hey, Piers. Who's the one doing it? Every single time, Piers.
He had multiple debates about this. Like, tons
a frankly preposterous amount of
Okay. All right. Other people can make that criticism. Probably
not Piers. >> Anyone should actually talk to him at
>> If I were writing a glossery entry on the Strerisand
effect, I wouldn't put a picture of her next to it. I would put
a picture of Nick Fuentes. >> They have opted to not do
so when it comes to like Nick Fuentes. Fuentes takes this guy
apart brick by brick. It's a full takedown. >> My concern
is that people who are a bit more moderate are >> It's
funny because Steve Bannon and Nick Fuentes are probably two
people they agree on like they're the two people who have that
actual like in-group versus outgroup signaling. Okay. They're
the two people who have that.
Um and like sorry it's it's like they're they're like within
the same in-group to 99% of people but they have like slight
differences. They're like the exact same. It's got to be hard
for them to compliment each other because they think like the
almost the exact same. It's weird because they're such like so
generally Yeah. generationally divided, but it's it's strange
that they hate each other so much to me. They think the exact
same way from everything I've watched of both of them. They think
the exact same way. >> Deeply alarmed by Nick Fuentes.
I >> I was very happy to see that like Nick Fuentes really
passed that test with flying colors.
That fragmentation is being caused purposefully by a splinter
faction of people led by a young man named Nick Fuentes. >> That's
the war. Can you get the beef prices down? Not crazy things that
Nick Fuentes or these other loons say on social media.
>> Bro, is that Bill O'Reilly? Bro, he looking skinny.
>> Well, it looks like all the screaming about Nick Fuentes
on the internet is finally dying down a little bit. So now we
had on this guy, this Fuentes guy, and never challenged him.
>> Um, you should have Nick Fuentes on your show and you
could ask him questions about that.
>> The truth is it doesn't make a lot of sense to spend
all this time talking about Nick Fuentes, but not actually to
Nick Fuentes. People who say you shouldn't give him a platform
overlook the very obvious fact that he already has a platform
of his own which is often bigger than most of the people complaining
and he uses it to speak unchallenged to his many followers. It's
on that basis that I've invited him to appear live and uncensored
on my platform and Nick Fuentes joins me now. Nick Fuentes, welcome
to Uncensored.
>> Hi, great to be with you. >> I don't dude there's
some uh there's some crazy stills. We'll see where I pause. There's
some very crazy stills
in this stream. Okay, just Nick. Hold on. I'm going to pull one
cuz Nick looked a little chubby. Okay, give me give me a second.
Let me pull Let me pull this. Uh, how from me? There's some wild
stills. Hold on. Give me a second. This one This one I thought
was fantastic. Okay, this is my favorite one.
Nick Flat Nick Fat Fat. God, I can't get it. Fluent. I can't
get it with fat in there. God damn it. Damn. >> No, you
>> It just looks goofy. Okay. It just looks goofy. That's
all. Crazy if you had to attack Nick's appearance instead of
his arguments. We'll talk about his arguments and how terrible
job Piers does in taking them down. >> I don't think we've
ever met. You can correct me if that's wrong. Um I know she I
like it. >> I know that increasingly
people are talking about you in a more mainstream environment
uh than you may be used to. So for those who know nothing about
Nick
I want this to be an opportunity to get to the real person. I
don't know who that person is, but I do want to use this opportunity
to get there. I've seen you talk as we prepared for this in exchanges
with people and on your show saying if you fear it's going to
be very hostile, it's going to be an ambush, all those kind of
things. I don't intend it to be overtly hostile. I don't intend
to ambush you. I intend it to be an examination of what you said
on the record, an examination of what you believe or what you
say you believe. Uh, and an examination of what your rising popularity
says about the state of the conservative movement in America.
So, those are my >> I don't know if he gets to the last
part at all. I feel like the whole thing was just a clip show.
>> The goals from this interview, what are your goals?
Why are you doing it? I thought it'd be interesting and you know,
you've talked a lot about me on your show over the years and
this is the first time you actually extended the invitation.
I think it might be the second actually. I think we we talked
about doing it during a 24 a few years ago, but you've talked
a lot about me with the panel and now you've extended the invitation
to talk to me and I think it'd be interesting uh for me to maybe
clarify some positions and maybe get to know you a little better
as well. So, I'm looking forward to it. There is a belief um
that >> Yay 24th. No, Yay 24 was the election campaign
for Kanye,
right? That started at the end of 2022, went into 2023, and then
died off. But it was the Yay 24 was the election campaign. But
you have two personas.
There's one that you roll out now for podcasts and for shows
like mine where you come across as reasonable
and then there's your show on Rumble where you often come across
as having, you know, a very unreasonable view on things. This
is what Coleman Hughes said about you. >> Nick Fuentes
knows exactly what he's doing. He is consciously playing this
double game as part of a long-term strategy to become popular
enough to take the reigns of power at which point he plans to
pivot towards the extreme and unpopular policies.
This is like the dumbest thing I've ever heard in my entire life.
And the fact that CBS paid hundred plus million dollars for this
is so insane. It's so stupid. This is the dumbest thing. Uh,
this guy took on totally like socially like
unholdable beliefs. He got banned from everything and it was
all in a desperate attempt to seize power and then change his
beliefs. What?
Huh? Like like it's so disingenuous. Like this is maybe the one
criticism you can't make. like, oh, the path this guy took to
being like popular was to take the popular opinions and then
also to he was gonna take the popular opinions and he's going
to get elected and then he was going to, you know, do extreme
things. In what possible universe could you think that's true?
That just it totally it's got no connection to reality at all.
It's just like saying something seriously into the camera hoping
people will take you seriously. This is utter propaganda. And
there are, by the way, there are so many things wrong with Dick
Fentes. You can list so many things, but this is just total complete
propaganda, which is
>> that he advocates daily on Rumble.
>> So, first of all, what is your response to that? >> Well,
first of all, I would say that Coleman Hughes is a propagandist.
He works for the Free Press, which is run by Barry Weiss. So,
I think that's you have to consider the source. And Barry Weiss
is a pro-Israel partisan. Free Press is just bought out by CBS
for $150 million
uh by >> Hold on. Um I'll pull it back just a second. I
don't think Coleman thinks Nick was planning it from the start.
I doesn't have He doesn't have to be planning from the start.
Does Coleman think like Nick's beliefs are going to stay underground
if he says them constantly on his stream? like all of his stuff
about race, all of his stuff about Judaism, that's gonna stay.
Is Is that his argument that Nick believes that his beliefs will
stay underground so long as he doesn't say them publicly like
on a big platform? Really?
Really?
That's I mean, he would have to believe that to say what he just
said, which is equally stupid. Is just bought out by CBS for
$150 million
uh by Larry Ellison or his son David Ellison. And so I think
that's coming from a particular point of view. We can't pretend
like that's coming from a vacuum or from some fixed position
that's coming from a propaganda outlet that's in favor of Israel.
That's first. But second, I would say he is right about the two
personas. And I think that everybody understands this on some
level. On my show, I make jokes and I use rhetoric and I'm hyperbolic.
Uh because for a long time I had an audience that was small
on these like dissident platforms. I was on dive for many years.
A lot of people don't even know what that is. And so I had a
small following. And >> that's actually true. A ton of
people don't even know what dive is. That's >> We had sort
of like an inroup sense of humor
and memes and things like that. And you talk about it one way
on a freewheeling live stream when I'm by
>> um
you can say this Kenny, but I I just don't think this is true
in like the modern day. one, people will always be, you know,
incentivized to put incendiary stuff out there, and Nick constantly
turns out incendiary stuff, and two, like his his most incendiary
clips from his live stream get blown up on YouTube and stuff
by other people reacting. Like I think of like the Care family,
which did a whole bunch of work like blowing him up with black
people, right? Care family did a bunch of reacts. They're like,
"Oh, we're going to react to this like cute little racist guy."
I don't know. His his stuff, his more incendiary stuff blows
up on social media all the time.
So I you could say like, oh, when he goes on Piers Morgan, he's
not going to say crazy. He said crazy here. Yeah, it seems like
he he's maybe if he's not staying consistent, it's only in that
he will basically only accept the beliefs if you make him say
it and he won't say it otherwise. But even if you make him say
it, it's still just like pretty consistent with the like with
his stream with his normal show. I think at this >> myself
and I'm ranting and we make jokes and although I will I will
give you this as well. He does do this thing where he basically
accepts he'll accept a label or he'll say something right and
then he'll also say it's not true at the same time. He does a
lot of double speak like a ton of double speak and I think he's
just realized that nobody cares if he's lying right basically
people are evaluating him on things other than the fact that
he's lying. So nobody cares. So he can just lie and there will
be like some people who will use that as plausible deniability
and other people who will point it out but none of it like matters
essentially. Yeah. So I we'll keep going devil's advocate. We
play with different positions. But then when you sit down in
an interview >> like this one and people ask me a good
faith question. What do you actually believe? Well then I clarify
and I say well here I'm not joking. Here I'm not being hyperbolic.
I'm not being rhetorical. I'll tell you precisely what I believe
as far as this idea that I'm going to get power and then turn
into that just sounds totally insane to me. I'll be honest. It
just sounds insane. >> Do you have aspirations for political
>> Not really. I think that uh if I wanted to run for office,
I wouldn't say a lot of the things that I say. I don't know that
a lot of people would vote for me. I tend to offend everybody,
even a lot of people that like me. Uh so no, I I'm a trutht teller.
I like to tell the truth. I like to do my live stream. Who is
Nick Fuentes? Tell me about your upbringing. I know you grew
up in in the suburbs of Chicago. Uh tell me about your early
years >> or early how like my childhood or a little bit
later. >> Childhood. Yeah. >> Well, I grew up in
the suburbs of Chicago in Lraange Park as you say. Uh my parents
are ethnics. Um you know, my father's half Mexican, half Irish,
my mother's Italian, and they both came from a pretty rough upbringing
themselves. They both are raised by
Okay, I'm just going to say he's finally not pretending Italians
are white. Okay, I'm just that's a personal pet peeve of mine
when he tries to pretend that Italians are white. Thank you for
calling them ethnics. Okay, your purely Italian mom is an ethnic.
Thank you, Nick. Thank you for accepting. Single mothers, not
because of divorce, but because both of their fathers had died.
Uh they endured a lot of dysfunction.
And I think that's one of the reasons they came together and
they related to each other and they wanted to create a normal
upbringing for their children. They wanted to have a normal family
life. And so uh they moved out to Lraange Park away from the
city and uh they raised me and my sister and really put us first.
I think that's a big reason why uh I tend to have a lot of these
family values or Christian values. My mother quit her job and
stayed at home to raise us. Um, and so I have very close relationship
with my parents, with my sister. We're a very tight family and
we grew up in a pretty idyllic town. Uh, and maybe we can sort
of get into a conversation about politics from this. I loved
my upbringing. My mom stayed at home. My dad was working. We're
in a mostly white suburb in Chicago. Everybody was I was maybe
half Catholic, half Protestant. It was a baseball town. I played
baseball for many years. Um, in Chicago, we love our hot dogs.
we have our baseball parade and get a hot dog. And so I love
where I came from. I love the city. It's a workingass city. I
love the people here. They're very good, humble, down to earth,
decent people.
Nick absolutely has political aspirations. Um but not as a a
person going to elected office. I'm sorry. He I don't think he's
planning to seek elected office at all. if he were to get involved
politically in some way like as a person who's you know has a
party or something like it would be like that but I don't think
he'd be anything more than a figurehead unless somehow he became
so popular that he could seize power based on popular support
alone and I don't think that's like that's not even remotely
within the you know the curve of our our
spaceime right now it doesn't >> and I guess I had my political
not to jump ahead but this is a big part of where my political
awakening came from I sort left this bubble, if you could call
it that. When I went to college in 2016, I went to Boston University
>> and I read a lot of things online and I realized the
country does not look like Lrange Park. It doesn't look like
Western Springs or Hinsdale or Elmer. >> Like behind the
scenes, power broker with his own platform having his own pressure
he can put on people. Yes, >> it looks very different.
>> Like if anything, he probably wants to replace Tucker.
I would guess >> the country is undergoing a radical transformation
because of immigration. And so I saw that and I said this is
not really a desirable change. I don't like the south side of
Chicago or the west side
or LA or certain parts of Boston as much as I like where I came
from. And I guess that's what made me an American nationalist.
I said I want to preserve my home and the things that are familiar
to me and the things I like about my home. What makes it America?
Uh so that's a little bit about my background. I don't know where
you want to go with that but >> well I suppose my first
my first obvious question is were your parents immigrants to
the United States or were their parents or were they grandparents
in other words at some stage I presume
there there were immigrants in your family who came to the US
is that
>> there were there were uh I believe my mother was fourth
generation and my father was third generation
so their ancestors came here my mom died in the 1860s I believe
the first wave of Italian immigration. My father's ancestors,
I think they came around at the turn of the century uh in 1900.
So So your view of immigration, and we'll get to the specifics
about your views on immigration. Are they not affected at all
by the fact that if it wasn't for immigration,
you wouldn't exist
as an >> Well, I would certainly exist, but like you said,
maybe not as an American. Certainly. Uh certainly that's influenced
in some measure. Um, but I think that the kind of immigration
that we had for a long time in the country, it's different than
the immigration that we have now. And let's just say for openers,
it's different immigrants. They're coming from a different place
with a different culture, a different
>> Uh, it's not the same as it was. So, first, you have
a qualitative difference. My ancestors, for the most part, I
have three European grandparents from Ireland and Italy, one
from Mexico.
They came from Europe. They came from a society where there's
a common ancestry. There's a common religion, common civilization.
The people that have come in since ' 65, since Hearts seller,
they're coming from China, India, the Northern Triangle, Mexico,
Venezuela.
And so, first, they're just different people. Secondly, it's
a quantitative difference. There's way more. And it's an unceasing,
always increasing wave. For the first three or four waves of
immigration, you would have a major influx of immigrants and
then it would stop. And then you'd have another wave and then
it would stop. this one it just keeps going up for 35 years and
it's too many. So that that's really where I would draw the distinction
between maybe >> I actually have no idea how much I've
never historically like verif I've never been somebody who's
like a history buff on immigration to the US. I don't know how
much of this is true. I don't know if it matters >> where
I originate from. I would even just simply call that immigration.
What this is is an invasion. It's a completely different policy.
>> But you mentioned Mexico in that list. Um, and your
father is is half Mexican.
>> yeah, I mean, by your criteria, part of the invasion
would include your father presumably and his immediate descendants
who came from Mexico. >> Not really true because when my
father's ancestors came here, it was a small fraction of the
total immigrants that came from Mexico. I don't believe that
we should have zero immigrants forever or even zero immigrants
from >> Ooh, I just This is going to be a trend. Okay,
Piers is going to open up with a point and then he's going to
chase that point until he looks stupid. Okay, so he's just like
he basically kind of goes like, "Aren't you the child of immigrants?
Really? Should you be like, should you be against immigration?"
Which is a fine point to make. And then Nick responds and he
continues to chase
it over and over. >> But you have to draw the distinction.
My my father's father, he was here in the in the 40s and 50s.
it was his parents or I believe either his parents or grandparents
that came here even earlier. Up until 1965,
90% of the immigrants were coming from Europe. I have no problem
with that. If we have 10% of them coming from Mexico or Latin
America, maybe that's reasonable, but that's not what it is now.
Now you've got 10 million illegals in four years under Joe Biden.
Uh, and you got millions more legal immigrants from China, India,
Venezuela,
El Salvador, and it's so many with no break for assimilation,
and they're all from non-white countries. It's transforming what
America is. And and again, that's the distinction. That's what
makes it unacceptable. I I love that you can say this, okay,
and you could what you need to need to do here is argue that
like, no, that's fine, and there there are reasons for it, right?
But what you shouldn't do here is say, "Yeah, but you're like
the child of immigrants." Isn't that hypocritical of you? You're
like the I I think I feel like that's where he's going to go.
I >> I always believe everybody is a product of their environment,
right? I've >> Oh, no. Sorry. Hold on. He's just moving
on without thousands of people. I mean it maybe three, four,
5,000 people from all different walks of life. But the one common
theme I would say is everyone's a product of their environment.
And I I was reading some stuff about you in the last few days.
There was an episode of of your podcast where you talked about
your father, Bill Fuentes, and how he wouldn't take the family,
including you, to certain restaurants because he believed they
were associated with
We would be deciding where to go to eat, he said. What are we
going to do for dinner tonight? It was a running joke. Me and
my sister would say, "Applebees." And my dad would say, "We would
never eat at Applebee's." "Not in a million years should you
be caught dead," Fente said about Applebees. go to a different
restaurant, a local restaurant, no Applebees, no Red Lobster
that is commonly known as Black Fair. Uh, and you also shared
another story about your family and restaurants. Said, "Before
me and my sister were born, my family had a saying about Olive
Garden that contains the end that we're not allowed to say."
So, my question based on that, >> Nick is smiling. I feel
like Nick is smiling because he's like, "Oh, I I see where you're
going." anecdote that you say on your own uh podcast
is do you think you grew up in a racist environment that your
father was inherently racist and that that thought
moved to you? >> Well, I would say it's a new low. I I've
been attacked for being a racist many times, but to attack my
father, to attack my parents based on anecdotes, I would say
that's that's sort of >> your Hang on. It's your running
aneote. Yeah, but he's not here to defend himself and my parents
are. >> You told the story and I will and I and I'll just
>> I'm not trying to ambush. As I said at the start, Nick,
to be clear. >> No, it's not an I
people could have things from their past, stuff they said about
their family. And it could be inappropriate to do that. You're
doing this under the ospaces of you're you're going to expose
this guy, right? That's what everybody knew Piers was going to
do. And the first thing you do, knowing that like there are going
to be people who are sensorious watching this, right? you immediately
expose Nick's family to that exact pressure.
I think I think Piers does know what he's doing or if he doesn't,
he's incompetent. There's only two options there, right? Like
like there's only two options. You're either incompetent or you
know precisely what you're doing. You're trying to put pressure
on this guy's family immediately. And it sort of throws away
all pretense that this is going to be like a fair or nice interview
in some
>> I think everybody ambushing you. I'm literally reading
an anecdote that you revealed on your podcast. It's you that's
put it in the public domain. I'm simply asking you whether my
assessment of that, which is that your father didn't want to
take you to certain restaurants because of what you refer to
as they were commonly known as black fair,
whether that whether that attitude to African-Americans in in
that instance permeated to you. It's a reasonable
>> Yeah. No, like I said, I think everybody knows what
that is, but I'll address it. I'll engage with it and I'll defend
my father from the charge of racism.
>> No, my parents My parents are not racist and they've
never been racist. I'll tell you I No, you don't save it. You
don't save it. It's like, oh, you said it, so I get to say it.
It's not the same, right? There are there there's a time and
a place. That's something you could ask him like privately or
you could say you could like obfiscate it in some way, right?
Do you feel just you could ask the question, do you feel like
you had a like a racist upbringing or something?
>> I don't know. I think this is I think this is pretty
crazy.
>> Tell you about my parents. They used to have a school
>> in Chicago in the South Loop. >> Just just because
there's so many things like what are we looking for here?
This guy is already racist. Like he's already racist. There's
nobody like concerned about it. You're not trying to prove out.
It's not like you have a thesis that he's racist. He tells you
he's racist. The whole point of like bringing the father up would
be to prove he's racist. You don't have to do that. It's already
proven. He accepts it. He says it where they instructed people
on how to firearms. It was a security school and most of the
clients were black. Um and I believe actually one of their clients
was Larry Hoover's son at one point. Sort of a funny story. And
so most of their clients would come in from the south side of
Chicago. My grandmother, she grew up in the projects in the city.
And so my family being in Chicago being ethnics uh being Italian,
Irish, Mexican in the west side, uh on Taylor Street, all over
the city, my family for many generations have lived near and
around black people. And
look, my views about black people and their views about black
people are shaped with experiences with black people. Uh and
and what they will tell you, what my parents would say if they
were here is that for many many years, the older generations
of black people were very respectful, very humble, very decent.
In fact, my grandma used to have an anecdote. She grew up in
a lot of dysfunction. her mother was mentally ill and they would
be having dinner in the projects and there'd be so much chaos
and dysfunction and disagreement and fighting and she would look
across the way out the window at a black family in the other
apartment and they'd be holding hands around the table saying
grace. And this is sort of the culture that used to prevail.
But now what you have in the city is that there's no accountability
for the black people. And now Chicago has become a complete dump
because these teenagers go out and they take over the city. They
call them teen takeovers. Uh that Bro, how do we get
Is this not >> That's the Did I miss something or are
for it? They're teenagers. >> We'll keep looking. He's
He's trying to say that I I've become racist on my own. Here's
how I did it. Here's how I became racist. Okay. My dad My dad
talked about restaurants that Here's how I became racist. He's
like jumping on the grenade. But they all come from the same
neighborhood. They drive up there and they mug people and attack
people and they destroy cars and destroy shops. We had the festival
of lights a couple of weeks ago. It's supposed to be a family
event and they light up the trees and they, you know, there's
a big parade. I was in the parade one year and you had a bunch
of black people there shooting each other. Seven people shot
a 14-year-old
in the Magnificent Mile. And and I know there's a lot of black
people that feel the same way about this. They say, "We've lost
control of the city and we're looking for accountability."
We have a lot of black people that are always outraged about
racism, outraged about attitudes from white people, but they're
never ashamed of some of these behaviors, never ashamed of some
of the things that go on. And that's why I think there's a lot
of negative attitudes these days. And so, you know, again, I
think those attitudes, you say, "I'm a product of my environment."
I I am, and so are my parents and my grandparents, unlike you,
cuz you're not even American. in Chicago we have to live in >> expertly
avoiding the question. Wait, how did he avoid the question? The
question was, "Do you think you're racist because your parents
were racist?" And he went, "No, I'm racist because I hate black
people in Chicago."
Is that not a direct answer to the question?
No, my parents weren't even racist. I'm racist because I hate
black people in Chicago. And he's yammering.
Wait, hold on. Is he yammering or avoiding the question or both?
because I feel like he's definitely not avoiding the question.
You could say he's yapping. Yeah, he's a prolific yapper
>> in a in a big diverse city where there's a lot of different
kinds of people and um anybody in Chicago tell you the same.
>> I live in I live in London. It's one of the most of
the biggest and most diverse cities in the world. >> But
it's not the same. >> Well, actually it's a big diverse
city. The only difference is we don't have the gun violence because
we don't have guns. That's a whole different story. I don't want
to get into that with you. I have got into that before. >> Got
a knife problem. You got sword >> We have We have problems
with Aladdin. >> We have problems with violent crime. I
make no pretense of it. So, the idea that somehow,
>> dude, what? Wait, what?
Why would you say Aladdin? What the >> I'm causeted in
London. Uh because I'm not in Chicago. >> Say that. >> It's
like Pirates of the Caribbean all over. It's Aladdin and Pirates
of the Caribbean mixed together all over London. Okay. It's crazy.
>> You kind of implied it. I guess my point about the environment,
I'm not saying you are a product of your environment. I'm saying
most people are in some capacity. When I read that anecdote,
it's just to remind you is it's not something I have put out
there. You told this story, right? And you said that >> you
said this. We're looping. You said this. But you haven't really
directly I think responded to it which is whether your father
would >> he did directly >> not to take you to certain
restaurant chains because he associated oh if the only point
of the question was did you lie about this anecdote or tell the
truth about this anecdote he didn't answer that but that's not
the point of the question right already stated the point of the
question the point of the question was I want to know if your
parents led to you being racist right I want to know and Nick
goes no no I don't feel like their attitudes rubbed off on me
here's all the reasons I feel like I'm racist. Right. So, if
you just want if you just wanted the superficial answer, which
really you'd only want if you're trying to pressure his parents,
right? No, no, no. What I want to know is is your dad racist?
Can can the woke I know I know I wrote a book called Woke is
dead, but like just in case the woke aren't dead and they want
to cancel your dad, can you confirm for me that he is racist?
Excuse me. Can you confirm for me that he is racist? >> With
black Americans, is that true?
No.
see here, if you're in America, you would say that Olive Garden
is not real Italian food. Applebee's, TGI Fridays, this stuff
is a load of crap. My dad was just a food stop, but no, it's
got nothing to do with that. My best friend in first grade was
a black guy. We are not We're not a racist family. So, >> okay.
So, when you told >> his dad's probably about as racist
as anybody that age, which is pretty racist,
right? It's not It's not 0% racism. It's not like 5% racism.
It's like 20% racist.
Also, yes, that's not an answer to the question.
In first grade, I was friends with a black kid. Uh Uhhuh. >> story.
I'm just curious. So, when you told that anecdote, which clearly
on the face of it is racist, right? You're you're basically saying
your father made
>> Well, like probably what the truth of this is is Nick's
dad is like a little bit racist. Not insanely racist, but a little
bit racist. And he probably used to make jokes about how like,
oh, Olive Garden is is like Italian food for black people or
something. He probably said some [__] like that,
right? Which is like racist, but then realistically when he had
interactions with black people, I kind of I personally just doubt
he was that bad, right? Personally, just decisions about where
you would go as a family to eat. Are you saying Well, well, I'm
just going to ask you a question. Are you saying that when you
told that story, you didn't mean to infer that he was racist?
And do you understand why when somebody like me reads that anecdote
for the first time as I did this week, I reach a different >> Well,
I understand what you're doing, which is a sort of making of
a murderer. How did he become racist? Well, his father didn't
eat because he said that's not real Italian food. Hang on. Can
I
I'm literally reminding you of something you said on your show
which led me which led me to conclude a certain thing. If I'm
wrong, tell me. Yeah, it it was said and just as a humorous anecdote
and now you're trying to spin it into a narrative which is his
parents are racist. He comes from a long line of racists. Uh
and I think everybody knows our parents my parents are boomers.
>> And these people come Well, you're a boomer I guess
too in a way, right? You were born what 19 Yeah. So you're a
boomer also. >> So here's the thing. Lots of times Nick
is joking and and he is joking and there's really no point in
like trying to go after the joke itself. You just ask questions
about the underlying belief, right? Damn, he's old. He is pretty
old. And Piers routinely doesn't go after the underlying belief.
He just tries to stick to the superficial thing to make this
look as bad as possible for Nick. Like it is just it is just
a disingen like they don't care. He doesn't care about the truth.
But it's unfortunate that he doesn't care about the truth because
the truth is Nick has like deeply seated calculated racism that
you could get him to explain almost certainly on this show if
you cared to.
So, it's like he actually is racist and you don't care about
the truth. And that lack that superficial nature, the superficial
way you're asking questions is going to make it look like you
are you're just like a woke scold, like a lefty woke scold. That's
like the format of the interview. I need to get as many bad things
on the record as I can so that we can clip this up and make you
look bad. And it's like, bro, he goes on his like he openly says
all of the things you want him to say all the time. What are
you going to get mad at him for saying cool? Yeah, he says that
[__] all the time. that's baked in now. So, or maybe
you're a Gen Xer. I suppose it's sort of on the cusp. Uh, but
it's a humorous anecdote. These are kind of the attitudes of
baby boomers in society, but you're trying to spin it into a
narrative which is you're a product of your environment. Your
dad's racist because of this joke. Now you're a racist. And I
don't think that's a fair >> Okay. People can make their
own minds up. They can they can go back and listen to you say
it. I mean the the beauty of what I'm going to talk to you about
in this interview is that almost all of it is just going to be
reminding you what you have said and asking you what you meant.
Your position about that story is that it was a joke. Okay. Um
I want to come to to something else you said. Uh this is where
you talk about
>> women and blacks. Let's just take a >> THEY'RE
ALWAYS COMING UP WITH no it's not the no it's not women. No it's
not blacks. It's actually really complicated. No, it isn't at
all.
A running society. Women need to shut the up. Blacks need to
be imprisoned for the most part
and we would LIVE IN PARADISE. IT'S THAT SIMPLE. OKAY.
That guy that guy was spitting actually. That guy was totally
That guy was spitting. Okay. Uh
that's this is like the closest to getting
Oh, this is so easy. This is a layup. >> Would you like
to clarify what you meant
>> That's all true. That's 100% true. Everything I said
in that clip is true. >> Including that uh blacks need
to be imprisoned for the most part.
>> Uh yeah. Yes.
>> Well, all of them. >> No, for the most part. >> What
does the most part mean? What percentage of American blacks would
you like to see in prison?
uh whatever the percentage is of the murderers, I think it's
one in 20 black men will commit a murder in their life. Man,
to be prepared for this interview, you have to be agile. Okay,
you got to be prepared to go with Nick. Okay, so he's like, "No,
like just for the most part." What does the most part mean? I
think he says, does he say 20%.
I think he said 20% here. It's like, okay, that's not one that's
not the most part, but it's just it's hard to actually chase
him around in all of the he does. >> What are the percentages
of the murderers? I think it's one in 20 black men will commit
a murder in their lifetime. So, maybe let's say that 5% in
black people who murder. >> So, that's even that's even
worse for saying the most part. For the most part, blacks need
to be in prison. >> 5% of them. That's not the most part.
What the
>> Oh, absolutely. Yeah. >> But you didn't say that.
You just said blacks need to be imprisoned for the most part.
You didn't clarify that you were talking about black murderers,
>> right? Right. No, you're right. That's a good addition
to that. That's a great >> You think it's Do you think
it's funny
>> I think Yeah, I do. I think it's hilarious. I think
it's totally true. >> Do you think a black American would
find it funny? You think that that blacks should be imprisoned
for the most part? >> Like I'm sorry. Piers literally just
wrote a book about this. Uh you think it's funny when you laugh
at like women? You think it's funny when you like just you laugh
about saying blacks should be in prison. You think that's funny?
You really think that's funny? Excuse me, sir. Do you think that's
funny that you say these things? And Nick's like, "Yeah, that's
literally it's a I'm saying it's a joke. That's yes, it's funny."
But the he's the he is the lefty soy wokeold. Blacks are my biggest
fans. I get high fives all the time. They say, "Nick Fuentes,
I love your show." They agree with me. And you want to know why?
>> Here's the difference. Black people are the most victimized
by other black people. You think black people want to live in
the hood and the ghetto and get shot all the time? That's what
happens in the south side of Chicago. You should come here. I'll
take you there. We could go to Garfield Park. >> Someone
went to Chicago University for a year, actually several years
ago. >> Yeah, that's a bubble. That's a bubble. You think
you're in Chicago and Hyde Park? You don't know Chicago. Go a
little bit west. See what it's like over there. And I'll tell
you, black people agree with me because they're tired of it,
too. And maybe not most of them, but a lot of them agree with
what I say about that because they know how it is. That's why
the first thing they do when they make a little bit of money
is they go and leave to another neighborhood. >> Okay.
So, what was just remind me again the percentage of
>> Man, I don't know. I own Nick Fentes at the mall and
black people high five me too. Okay, dude. I Piers got caught
out. Well, I think the thing is is Piers literally doesn't go
and rub elbows with these people, right? Like, he doesn't do
it. and Nick. Un I don't think Nick does either, but uh yeah,
I don't think Nick does either. I will say that
a lot of people who are from different race groups, like outside
of outside of a certain like subset of black people, like they
are okay with some amount of racism, they are okay with it, right?
As long as you're like not willing to treat them all like, you
know, it's not like, oh, I need all these people gone. like Nick
Nick Fentes has tuned his racism pretty pretty astutely to be
okay with like a big chunk of black people that you wouldn't
expect as somebody who's not a part of that group. You know what
I mean? Where it's like, oh, I I'm not like I'm not angry at
everyone, but like there's some problems here culturally. It's
it's like kind of I don't know. It's it's like tuned in a way
that sort of makes sense and gets him like, you know, one out
of five black people don't hate Nick Fuentes. One out of two
out of five black people don't hate Nick Fuentes. It's like tuned
appropriately to somehow be okay.
Kenny's one of the ones that high-five him. Kenny would totally
high-five Nick Fuentes. Kenny would high-five Nick Fuentes and
food shops at the same time.
Kenny would literally hold up both hands to high-five both of
them simultaneously. That's who Kenny is. >> Black men
who commit murder in America. What was the percentage you gave
me? >> It's one in 20. One in 20. >> It's It's one
in a 100red.
>> No, it's one in 20. >> No. No. Less than one in
a 100red black US men commit murder. That's the most up-to-date
crime statistics in America. >> That's not true. I' I've
seen other statistics. They say one in 20 will eventually commit
a murder. I >> Your rate means that your saying that five
times as many black men commit murder as the official crime statistics
>> Yeah. There's a report, I believe, on X by Data Hazard.
I'll have to go and double check that for you, but yes, there's
some >> Yeah, one in 20 seems insanely high to me. Like
I I was just like, "Oh, what? There's no way that's not possible.
1 in 20. That's crazy. >> Pretty shocking evidence that
says that it's far more alarming than you would >> Okay.
But you you would accept that the official crime statistics are
one in a 100. Or you wouldn't accept that
>> I I don't know. I don't have it in front of me, but
I've seen other evidence. Like I said, Data Hazard on X, I believe,
produced a report about a year ago. It said one in 20. But I
mean, whether it's one in 20 or one in 100, that's a lot of people,
peers. I mean, >> a lot of white people commit murder,
too. Well, they do, don't they? >> Okay, but it's about
it's about proportionality. I mean, white people are 65% of the
population. Blacks are
>> And I think anybody would tell you that more black people
proportionally.
Lonox was saying the number is even lower than one in 100 among
blacks. Uh yeah, I could see like one in a 100 would be I I mean
I don't think of it in those terms at all. Right. I I don't think
of it in those terms at all. You have the stat for whites, it
would be really really really significantly
um it would but realistically the inner city like crime problem
is a it's like it's a character it's a class of crime that is
outside of the normal crime statistics and to treat it like the
rest of the crime statistics it's like in a class of its own
it's organized like it's organized
gang violence right yes it's like a totally different class and
so when you include in the stats it's like oh you're you're saying
things about people where I think these things would be happening
like Nick is literally Italian. Does he not know that like these
impoverished communities will have groups of gangs who will do
like straight up violence, straight up murders? I'm sure in the
1910s, in the
actually, I don't even to to be honest, off the top of my head,
I don't know when the height of the mob was. Probably 1920s,
1930s, 1940s, right? When when the height of the mafia was like
all these immigrant groups,
especially Italians, I'm sure the murder rate for Italians was
massive, was insane, right? I'm guessing I'm guessing it's got
to be insane, but that's because you're involved in that kind
of crime like on an ethnic basis. It's like Yeah, it's I don't
know. It It doesn't seem like it's the same class of issue. Commit
violent crime than white people and people vote with their feet.
People would rather pay a much higher property tax. >> Most
with the interruptions.
>> I'm sorry.
>> Thank you. I appreciate that. You know, you look at
in Chicago, in New York, these neighborhoods are so stratified.
People would rather pay a high tax rate. They'd rather pay a
much higher property value to live in a less diverse, less black
neighborhood because they don't want to live around the violence.
And I think that when you look at even on the public transit,
the subway, the blue line, you know, people don't want to go
there because they know who occupies and menaces the public transit,
it is uh these people like Daniel Penny had to deal with. It's
people like Arena Zerutska had to deal with. And uh and that's
just the uncomfortable reality. You you've also said you don't
want to >> gang violence has been a thing before black
people formed gangs. That's what I was just saying. Yeah, that's
what I was just saying. >> Live near black people. Let's
take a listen to this clip.
>> I'm a new generation of white person. I'm not living
around blacks. Sorry. You know, I want white kids and I don't
want my white kids bringing home black people to marry. It's
racial for me. And you call me racist. Oh, very Christian of
you. I don't give a >> I mean, it couldn't be clearer really.
Um, unless you want to say that's another of your jokes, but
you're basically saying, "Yeah, I'm a racist." >> Like,
unfortunately, Nick is from Chicago. Chicago has some of the
worst like impoverished gang violence that exists in the USA.
A lot of people,
what you should be hearing there is Nick lives around these impoverished
areas and whatever ethnic group was in that impoverished area,
he would hate. Right now, Nick is like racist to begin with,
but whatever group occupied that super impoverished, it wouldn't
matter what their skin color was, you would dislike those people
in that city because that city has major major major issues,
right? And I think you can go into Nick Nick's like openly racist
outside of that, too, but you you allow him to consistently frame
things based around that. And Piers doesn't really dispute any
of that. And I think there's a lot of people who can defend his
opinions at these times. probably not the one in 20 stat. The
one in 20 stats
that's like a totally stupid thing. He was trying to defend he
was basically he was trying to defend his like joke, his like
his hyperbolic like I'm going to lean into my racism. He was
trying to defend it on actual grounds and he looked kind of silly
doing it. I think he leans out of that for the rest of the interview
instead of like instead of trying to totally defend his points,
he sort of starts memeing instead. >> Aren't you? >> Uh
yeah. Yeah, I'm fine with that. >> You're fine with saying
you're a racist?
>> Totally. I think everybody's racist. I think everybody,
if we're being honest, is racist. I think every It's a lot of
defense you're giving to Nick there. I just said that he is actually
racist and you're not really getting at those beliefs or those
ideas. Do you think I'm saying Nick isn't actually racist? I'm
saying that the Chicago example and using like like that he uses
that to deflect and that makes sense to a lot of people. So,
you need to go into his other stuff like actually ask him about
genetics. What do you think about genetics? You think black people
are genetically prone to crime? That's where the actual racist
stuff is. But if you're if you're going to go with crime statistics,
he's going to talk about Chicago. He's going to talk about his
experience. He will seem sympathetic to a lot of people that
you don't expect. But just ask him, are black people genetically
prone to commit violence? Do you think all black people are genetically
prone to commit violence? And he will lean right into it and
say yes. But I don't believe that's ever asked here. Everybody,
the only despite the fact that Nick says overtly, "I'm a race
realist." Piers doesn't actually ask. Only people that aren't
racist or or pretend not to be are white people to their detriment.
Everybody else is >> You spent you earlier in the interview
you you went really got agrieved at the idea that your father
was a racist. You you wanted to make emphatic >> my father's
>> he's not >> because my father doesn't share my
same views on that. >> So he's the exception to the everyone's
a racist.
>> Well, everybody's a little bit racist. You're right.
So maybe everybody the difference is you're attacking my father.
You know he can get fired from his job. I'm not attacking your
father. You are. I No, I'm not. I don't know your father,
>> dude. Okay. What if Hold on. What if Piers's son was
going for an interview and the person said, "Oh, like here's
something where you said your father's a bit racist." Obviously,
that's going to reflect on you, right? Like even if they said
it, it could have been out of context. They could have meant
it in a different way. Or like with Nick, he leans into the hyperbole
sometimes on things like that. Like I'm guessing when Nick talks
about his parents being racist, as racist as him, he's almost
certainly joking because not many people are as racist as him.
Okay? Takes a lot of work to become as racist as Nick Fuentes.
Okay? It takes a lot of work that not a lot of people are willing
to put in or incentivized to put in.
So I I think Piers trying to go, "Oh, I'm not attacking your
dad at all. That's insane. You you totally are." And just like
keep it away from family. It's super easy. Dude, this guy's got
so many clips. Why you got to ask him about his dad? And to be
clear, his dad, I I have no knowledge about him at all other
>> Well, then let's leave him out of it. Let's leave him
out of it if you don't know him. >> Hang on, Nick. You
put that story into the public domain on your show. I'm simply
reminding you of what you told everybody, millions of people.
>> Am I on that level of racism? No, I'm
>> about your father. If you now want to retract it, fine.
If you want to say it was a joke, which is what your position
was earlier, fine. But I'm allowed to put to you things you've
said publicly. That's not unfair. That's not me targeting your
father. You put that story about him out there. >> You
know what you're doing. You know what you're doing. >> I'm
asking you about a pretty shocking anecdote which to me looked
like you were saying your father made decisions about where you
as a family would eat based on skin color of people who worked
at these places. If you say or use them. If you say that is not
what you meant, that's fine. You can respond any way you like,
but the idea I can't ask you about it without you saying I'm
attacking your father is ridiculous. >> Well, you are,
and you know what you're doing, and there's a political culture
and uh I mean, Nick's existence risks his dad's job. Seems whiny
to cry about it now. >> Really? You think that's reasonable?
I That seems totally crazy to me. That seems totally totally
crazy to me to say that like, oh, uh, actually, uh, okay. in
America where if you have the wrong views, you get fired from
your job. >> You went after Tech's dad. Hold on. What's
the difference, Kenny? Listen,
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna I There's a lot of racist things
I could say right now, Kenny. But I want you to think really
hard about what the difference might be when I comment on Tech's
dad versus Nick's dad, cuz there is a big difference. I just
want you to think about it. Okay? Try. Try. Oh, you're not trying.
Okay. Well, I'm going to give you like 10 more seconds. You should
be able to get it. You should be able to get it. Yeah. Maybe
lighter living stone. We'll see. It's that Oh, Toys R Us kid.
Oh, Toys R Us kid got it. Kenny couldn't get it. Techn's dad
appeared on stream multiple times.
Multiple times.
He is a figure that Teone brought onto his stream and into his
universe. Obviously, I've been my father has a job and if you
go on here and say you charge him with racism or something and
I'm >> Oh, also we attacked Teone's dad for something he
was convicted of. If Nick's dad was convicted of a hate crime,
you could talk about Nick's dad's hate crime all you want. The
thing is, you really don't know. >> Put in a position where
I don't look like I'm sticking to my guns if I don't say my father's
a racist. You're putting him in jeopardy and he's not here to
defend himself or explain his views. And it's very low. Uh Izzy,
I do believe that if you wanted to ask that question, you could
just ask that question and say you don't believe it was your
parents cuz you've told a story about it before. And Nick could
just go no. And then you I feel like you just let it go. Like
if Nick's willing to say, "No, no, no. here's why I became racist
and list all these things. I I just think you don't involve them
even if they're involved just out of I I think that's one thing
you could do out of respect. You're already trying to like career
this guy. Can you just like maybe leave the parents out of it?
I feel like that was reasonable. Totally reasonable. And uh and
I think you know exactly what you're doing and people can see
what you're doing. I'll defend my views and I think that you
know so let's leave him out of it. Let's just not talk about
my father because my father isn't here. I'm here. Well, then
do you accept you shouldn't
>> Listen, that's fine. But then do you accept you shouldn't
talk about your father on your show and you shouldn't >> Absolutely
not. Absolutely not. >> So, it's fine for you to put a
>> Okay, Nick should absolutely admit, yeah, I shouldn't
tell anecdotes that paint my father as racist when I don't think
he's racist. That was stupid. Now, Nick probably is never going
to admit he said anything stupid ever in his entire life. But
that is stupid. That was stupid to do. Okay. Absolutely.
Oh, I don't want to I don't want my father to be painted as racist.
Well, baby, don't tell stories where you're painting him as racist
yourself. That would help. That'd go a long way, man. >> Story
out there which would make most people who listened to that story
or watched it at the time on your show conclude that he was racist.
It's fine for you to do that. But if I then ask you about it,
I'm the one who's being unfair and I've crossed a line. Is that
what you're saying? >> Yes. Yes. You're being malicious.
>> Okay, that's fine. That's fine. Listen, people are watching
this live. They can draw their own conclusions about whether
what I just did. >> They will. >> Yeah. And I'm sure
afterwards, by the way, you'll say, "He ambushed me with your
not >> with your own." Whoa. >> I just I feel like
there's a there's a little piece here as well that you don't
have to go your father Bill Fuentes,
right? Did he have to do that part? Like maybe maybe you could
even sort of defend, but there are so many little things on the
edges where it's just obvious what he was doing. And I think
Nick was right to call it out. And I think some people thought
he got pressed on this, but I think trying to trying to put the
the name into it, there's just a little little things around
the edges with the right words.
>> That's a little presumptuous.
I'm not going to say it's an ambush, but I think that's a low
blow >> and I think you know what you're doing. And and
that's fine. You're a tabloid journalist. I expected that. I
don't think it's an ambush because >> Piers Piers got him
on the back foot. That's the whole goal. Well, if you think so,
we'll see. We'll see. We'll >> I think you know what you're
doing and and that's fine. You're a tabloid journalist. I expected
that. I don't think it's an ambush because I knew it would be
like this. And people will see what you're doing and I think
they'll say it's low. But as far as you want to talk about racism,
let's talk about racism. Let's leave my head on. >> Look,
you've admitted you're a racist.
>> Yes. 100%. Own it. >> Okay, that's fine. You're
perfectly entitled in a free democratic society to stare down
the barrel of his camera and tell me you're a racist. People
can judge you accordingly. Many people many people who have assumed
that you're racist will now have heard it from your own lips.
That's fine. >> There you go. >> That's the point.
The point of this interview is this is it's so funny seeing like
the culture like the pendulum swinging. And I don't think we're
quite at the end or even really close to the end of where the
pendulum stops on in terms of like this right-wing shift on race
and group identity and group solidarity. I think we're going
we're getting more in that direction. We're going further in
that direction before we start swinging back. But I think there's
just Piers doesn't see that this is not as big a deal to people
anymore at all. You guys think this is the internet?
How do you think Trump got elected? I'm just curious. How do
you think are you guys? Because just to be clear, you cannot
argue Trump got elected because of a rise in racism in the United
States or people being overtly racist or or hiding their racism
and just being racist without saying it. You can't say Trump
got elected based on racism, which is something basically all
all people left and center say. And also say that Nick can't
say he's racist on a stream. I you pick one. Pick one cuz you
can't do both.
Is to go over the things you've said which have led people to
reach conclusions about you and to ascertain whether those conclusions
are fair and reasonable or not. That's it. So I want to play
you another clip. This is where you talk about why white people
are justified in being racist. Let's take a listen to this.
>> First, white people are
>> Man, people don't see it. We're at We're at like a different
place society. We're at a totally different place. Now, hold
on. I will say, wait, if you if Nick was trying to run for office,
he would be himself here, okay? To lean into it and say, "I'm
I'm actually racist." That would be totally if you were running
for office. Okay, dude. This guy's got crazy facial expressions
all the time. It's wild. Okay, but if he were running for office,
then that would be a problem. But he's not running for office.
He's got like one of the biggest audiences in the world, and
he says way more offensive than this on a nightly basis. That's
all he wants is to build his coalition and to he wants to do
he underneath it all, Nick is incredibly envious of people in
America, okay? And he wants that same power for white racists
in America. Hey, if the white racists just got together and they
did like the the World White Racist Congress and they discussed
the the Nation of White Racists,
like what could we do? What could we accomplish? That's basically
what he wants to do. He wants to be able to exert pressure on
politicians without actually having to run for office. Seems
pretty clear to me.
Every single bit justified in being
every single bit justified to the extent that that means going
out of your way to avoid black people when you see them. >> Can
you stand by that?
>> Absolutely. Absolutely. >> He does not have one
of the biggest audiences in the world. You are crazy. I I don't
know
like Okay. What What do you think happens? Chon Chicon Hero,
I can't I don't know how to say your name. Sorry. Like what do
you think happens? Do you think he's getting his audience numbers
10xed on Rumble?
cuz that seems unheard of in terms of view botting. Like 10x
is insane. Like nobody does that. Do you think he somehow translates
like 100,000 viewers on Rumble or 50,000 if he's doing his normal
stream? Do you somehow think that translates into I don't even
know. How does it translate into massive support on Twitter and
massive support every time he goes to like any YouTube channel
and does a collab? Right. I I just said Rumble. He doesn't run
Rumble. Peter Teal runs Rumble. Peter Teal owns Rumble. spends
100k on viewbots a month. I maybe I here's the thing. If you
can totally bootstrap the kind of support Fentes has, if you
can bootstrap that via like fake synthetic views, why aren't
like that's such a tiny amount of money to pay for the amount
of like clout and cultural power this guy has? Why aren't other
people doing it if you could just do it that simply?
Everybody should be doing it. Why is nobody else doing it? Like,
I'm sorry. There is something to be said for the the huge boost
this gets everywhere.
where everybody's talking about this interview before it starts.
Everybody's watching this interview today. I don't know. Like
when I say he's one of the biggest audiences in the world, I
don't think that's crazy. I really don't. It's not even like
it's not praise of him. If you're getting it twisted, it's not
praise. I'm not saying it's really awesome. It's really like
he's so cool and he's so honest that he gets a huge audience.
That none of that is what I'm saying. I'm saying he just has
a big >> So white people should go out of their way to
avoid black people when they see
Absolutely. They would be wise.
>> Because it's a lose-lose proposition. If you're Ireina
Zerutka and you don't walk the other way, you get stabbed to
death and you die. >> If you're somebody else and you walk
on the subway
and you stand near a black person or something, maybe it's fine.
Uh it's a lose-lose proposition. Um, so no, I I think that white
people I think that white people have been beaten into submission
that were afraid to tell the truth about it. And the truth is
that when you go into these major cities like New York or Chicago,
I believe she was in North Carolina,
there is a menace, which is young black adolescent men. They're
extremely violent and we have been told that we have to pretend
like they are every other person. We have to be colorblind to
that and we're supposed to go and and be in the midst of all
this danger.
And I think that at this point it's gotten out of control. You
look at the BLM movement, they said that the reason that black
people um you know are violent or the reason there's crime is
because of police brutality
or redlinining or all these other things. They said we need to
get rid of the police. We need to defund them. And a lot of cities
did. A lot of cities like Chicago for example, the police change
the rules of engagement. They don't chase them. It's not a felony.
If you steal a certain amount of merchandise, they won't chase
them on foot. And now the city's totally up for grabs. And now
whether you're in the Gold Coast or whether you're on the Mag
Mile or you're in the worst neighborhoods in the city, you might
get shot, you might get mugged, someone might run up on you.
You're you're just totally wrong here, man. I don't know what
to I don't know what to tell you about this. He's popular on
every platform except the one or sorry, the two he's banned on,
which is just I believe just YouTube and Facebook now, right?
or sorry just YouTube and uh Twitch rather like otherwise clip
channels are allowed to post his stuff without like from his
stream like on Twitter he is incredibly popular he's insanely
popular yeah he's also popular on YouTube his clips get tons
of views too this already has this is going to approach a million
views by what 8 hours probably like clip channels posted and
it's all popular like it's got organic popularity every single
place in the world and and I tell my followers it is better to
be perceived as racist ist or racist and walk the other way and
maybe keep your life than to say, "I'm a good anti-racist. I
don't mind that this person's making me uncomfortable. Maybe
he's looking a little froggy. I'm going to sit down cuz I'm a
good person." And gets stabbed, mugged, whatever. And by the
way, this is a strategy. They call it the friendly stranger.
There's a crew of them. They do this in Chicago. They stand outside
bars, black people. They approach strangers. It's a robbery crew.
And they pretend to be a friendly stranger. And then they mug
them. And stupid white people say, "Oh, hi. Yeah, nice to meet
you." You know, they grin, they laugh, they put up with the nonsense,
and then they get mugged or worse.
Sometimes they get executed. And so, as a white person, >> how
do you feel? How do you feel about mass shootings at school?
>> I think they're bad. >> Who do you think commits
mo the vast majority of the mass shootings? >> I'm sure
it's white people, >> right? So, how do you feel about
that? >> I think that white people do more antisocial violence.
I think black people participate in more gang violence. I think
that's the difference. >> What's the difference to the
victims? >> Uh there's no difference to the victim, but
it's a different kind of crime. And it's a >> Dude, this
is so lazy. This is so insanely Good question, Piers. Is No,
it's so This is so insanely lazy.
Uh, white people do murders, too. Um, yeah. Wait, what does it
say in the statistics is what we're like talking about. There's
so many good ways to come back. There's so many good ways to
come back and argue this point with Nick here. And Piers just
picks the worst ways. just trying to optics farm out W's here,
right? He's just trying to make it look like Nick is racist here
the whole time instead of actually having a conversation where
you can also prove Nick is is racist and not look like a total
shill, a total for yourself.
It's a different proportion. Also, do you know what percentage
of white people are school shooters?
>> Uh, I know that the vast majority of mass shootings
in schools in America this century were perpetrated by young
white men. And what proportion of what
>> Okay, so here's the thing, Piers. Uh, all we have to
say is if you see a that looks like Nick Fuentes in a trench
coat walk into your school, he looks really sirly. Run the other
way. Yes.
Yes. Yeah. You should racially profile white people walking into
school in a trench coat with a backpack or something. Okay. Absolutely,
Piers. Thank you. Thank you,
And then yeah, there's other points to make here too in terms
of the like in terms of the crime statistics. And when you're
talking about that, you need to talk about how gang crime is
like a totally different class of crime and that crime does go
up pretty insanely. And when it's concentrated, when high poverty
areas, extreme poverty areas are concentrated, there's huge populations
there, you will get crime unlike anything you see anywhere else
in the US. Like that is the problem. It is not a racial problem.
Black people who broadly live in like the suburbs somewhere randomly
in the suburbs. A black person lives, you know, with 10 other
black families. You have like an affluent black family. They
don't have these problems at all. It's very obvious, right? It
has to do with poverty. And if you want to say like, oh, it's
it's only black people who are like that. I don't know. I can't
think of another test case where like where in the level of concentration
that exists now in like the projects in a lot of major US cities
had there ever been an ethnic group who are the only ones in
this area
who've lived the same way
right and you have to take that out of the equation and then
balance it and then you look at it right but when you keep that
in the equation you don't even you're not even looking at the
picture correctly they're like in different stratos they're totally
different
>> white people in rural areas do some vile crime, too.
Well, I think the the issue is I think if you if you if you technically
test No, no, no, no, no. Rural areas, I don't think it's the
same, Zage. Although they do, people of all races commit heinous
crimes everywhere, obviously. But I think the argument like racist
people usually use is white people who are in the same poverty
bracket as black people don't do the same amount of violent crime.
But it's because they're sparsely populated rural areas. Of course,
you don't have the same amount of crime out there. Of course,
you don't. Of course. Of course. of course. Uh, how do trailer
parks of white trash or poor Latino neighborhoods and suburbs
that are mostly uh, black do? So, I think suburbs that are mostly
black, it's fine. And then trailer parks of white trash, it's
not as bad. It's like not anywhere near near as bad. But I think
it's because it's a trailer park. It's not like tenementss. It's
not like ma, it's not a high concentration, right? You create
like a crabs in a bucket effect when you do that. When you put
all these people in the same area at extremely low rates of income,
at extremely high rates of poverty, they said the same thing
twice, right?
It's different when it's like spread. It's diffuse in some way.
It's totally different when it's like concentrated massively.
I think of it as like a like if you think of it as a density
chart. The it's like there's a black hole in the middle of these
cities that it just straight up like the criminality like totally
it it gets it it like scales exponentially as you increase the
density of population at a high rate of poverty. Are there stats
on the motivation of these crimes or are they just trying to
do crime? Well, I think it's organized crime in these areas,
Zanj. So I think in these in these like in the projects type
of situation I think you get a lot of drug dealing a lot of drug
problems because people are like coping with their lives right
yeah it's like it's a man I see it as like not a race related
issue. You have to find a way to solve this. It it happens to
be it gets conflated with race related issues in a way that makes
it an incredibly difficult problem to solve. I don't know how
you fix it because like there are there are also cultural issues
that start to come in there. But again, I think it's mostly cultural
in that these people are living in extremely high like poverty
situations. I think that's the culture. It's like poor person
extreme poor person culture rather than it being like black culture
or something.
>> I'm curious. I'm curious whether your advice would be
to people who have kids working. Should they proportion? Should
they should they avoid >> Should they avoid
>> white people at school? Should people with the kids
at school avoid young white men at school? >> No. Okay.
>> Do you know Do you know what per capita means? Do you
know proportionality? There are more black people proportionally
that engage in violent crime or are involved in gangs, especially
in these major cities, than there are white people that are school
shooters
compared to the entire white population. And everybody understands
>> two 23 of mass shootings at school perpetrated by white
people. >> But what proportion of white men commit school
shootings? That >> appears Piers is like actually pretending
to be a complete right now,
Like he's This is like performative. I'm talking about like per
capita here, Piers. Um but but don't white people do school shootings?
Don't white people do school shootings, Nick? Don't they do Nick?
Don't they do school shootings?
Yes, Piers. Yes, but I'm talking about proportionality. I'm talking
about per capita. Piers, you understand? Uh, but don't white
people do school shootings? >> That's the question. >> Just
truly incredible stuff from Piers Morgan. We love this guy. He's
awesome. What a great guy.
>> I've just told you it's 60 65% of school >> You're
telling me what proportion of school shootings are committed
by white people? I'm saying what proportion of white people have
committed school shootings. Are you playing dumb? Are you just
not that smart? >> What difference does that make to the
to the children lying dead on the ground?
>> See, now you want to jump on the victims. The difference
is you're asking would you fear white people >> or black
people? And that's the difference. The difference I'm saying
to you is by yourility by your log >> Thank you. Thank
you for saying it. Like like dude, you're you're smarter than
this. Come on, man. Come on, man. If if we now have agreed that
the vast majority of mass shootings in schools are committed
by white people and predominantly young white men, then presumably
your advice would be to avoid young white men because
>> Yeah. Okay. Hold on. Hold on. In a school setting, that
guy's in a trench coat or wearing like a big backpack that you
could see something sick out. Yeah. Run, bro. Run. >> These
massacers, but he won't be because they're white, right? So,
so are you playing dumb or are you actually dumb? It's about
proportionality.
You are. You are because you're Well, I don't think you are dumb.
I think you're smart actually. But you're deliberately avoiding.
>> Are you STUPID OR ARE YOU DUMB?
YEAH. YEAH. Per capita. And everybody knows that's the difference.
What proportion of white men are school shooters? It's probably
1%. What proportion of black men have committed violent crimes?
It's probably like 5%. I guess I don't know what it is off the
top of my head, but it's very high. And I would add to that even
as it concerns schools. Why do you think parents pay a super
high property tax to live in a school district where there's
white people because they know that if they go to the black school,
it's going to be the Bloods and the Crips. It's going to be gangs.
It's going to be, you know, you talk about school shootings.
Nobody talks about all the school shootings that are committed
by gangbangers in and around the school and all the other violence
that's associated with that. I mean, these these schools in the
south side of Chicago,
you know, it's just not >> I have another question for
you, uh, Nick. So, the proportion of the population who carry
out mass shootings is actually the same for black and >> for
white people, the proportion of No, >> the Are you hearing
it?
Um, so mass shootings, would that include the gang violence?
I don't think that could possibly be true, right? I'm pretty
sure that's like obviously untrue
or else it doesn't make any sense that you get the homicide numbers
you do.
So, I don't know why Pier Piers just said that. Does he mean
like that? That can't be true, right? Think that state stat doesn't
include gang violence. Okay. Well, if you're disincluding gang
violence, you have to say so. No. No. Yeah. Three or more deaths.
If if you just do three or more deaths without excluding gang
violence, that's not close. But again, I think you probably should
exclude gang violence. And then it sounds like you get something
closer to the real picture. >> I think the problem with
your statistics is a lot of them don't bear much scrutiny. We
have a bunch of fact checkers checking all this in real time
because you do have a tendency to just come out with a lot of
old baloney. And when you say, you know, okay, >> well,
it's true. >> And when you're confronted with reality,
you don't like it. >> What's the figure? What proportion
of white people have committed school shootings? With white people
as the denominator and white people that have committed school
shootings as the numerator, what's that percentage >> for
both black and whites? The proportion of the population who carry
out mass shootings generally is about the same. >> No,
no, tell me the number. And then and >> and yet and yet
your only the only focus of your attention
>> I Nick is asking the right question here and Piers is
just Nick Nick just spelled it out with like literally third
grade math. Here's the question I'm asking Piers and Piers just
again goes in a totally different direction is the black shootings
the black crime. You don't want to live around black people.
>> This is totally incorrect. Living stone I don't think
this is true. I think I think the highest instances of mass shootings
quote unquote are gang violence. Those are like by far from what
I saw the crime stats you unless you control for them unless
you explicitly remove them the highest portion of mass shootings
in the United States happens due to gang violence. You want to
avoid black people. You don't want inter interracial marriages
or relationships that may produce black people. And yet when
I point out to you that there are many parts of crime in America
where actually there's a majority of white people that perpetrate
them, you don't care. You don't have any interest in them. It
doesn't exercise your mind. >> Maybe no one's buying this
argument lost. No, no one is buying this. Everybody understands
per capita and people can even see. >> Yeah, he is undercutting
himself. Totally evil Johnny Bravo. Yes, he is. Actually, white
people are really bad for mass shootings. Also, white people
and black people do mass shootings at the same rate, but here's
a cohort of mass shootings that is all white people. So, Nick,
what do you think about that? Amazing stuff. What you're you
race ahead and say, "Well, we're comparing the proportion of
white and black school shooters." I said, "No, no, compare the
proportion of school shooters that are white versus violent criminals
that are black." Because that was the basis of the monologue
is that you're very likely if you encounter black people or a
young black man in the city that you're going to be the victim
of a violent crime of a a robbery, a mugging, a car theft, a
carjacking or a murder. That's the difference. And it's about
proportionality and everybody sees past that because we all live
in reality. You want to talk about product of your environment,
people that live in New York, Chicago, LA, we live in reality.
We live in this environment and we see what it's like and the
threat the danger in terms of probability
is not it's not even comparable. And I would add I would say
this to your point
if you're in a high school and you and truly if you see a white
person who looks like a little he's got the SSRI stare and he
reaches for a backpack people joke and say run. Similarly, if
you see a jalapy pulling up with a bunch of black people in it
and they got their pants around the ankles. The is a jalapy,
by the way. I actually have no idea what I've never heard this
word before. It's a jalapy. >> You're going to run also.
And I'm saying the same thing. The difference is the latter happens
much more often. >> A shitbox car. Okay. >> It's
much more common. You know, in Chicago there's like 10,000 carjackings
and car thefts every day. It's in the thousands. It happens all
the time. How many mass shootings committed by SSRI white people?
I don't even know. I mean, it's probably in the single digits
in the last decade in this city. That's the difference. And everybody
knows that. But you're you're you're really just trying to carry
water for liberal ideology. It's an ideological.
>> No, I'm I'm really not. I can absolutely say yes, there
is way too much black on black crime, for example, involving
guns >> black and white also. >> Yes. But there was
way too much gun violence in Chicago, right? I mean, it's
>> yeah, hold on. I just had the exact same facial reaction
that Nick did. I was like, "Wait, those aren't What do you say?
Wait, what do you what do you think the gun violence is in Chicago,
Piers?" But there's also way too much gun violence in Chicago.
And Nick is like, "Wait, that's that's my point. Who's doing
the gun violence in Chicago, Piers? Who's who's doing that?"
By the way, the the way you do the way you have this conversation
is you just lean into the gang thing and you say that's a different
problem to solve. And if you control for that cohort, which I
understand you might some people might say, but oh, but it is
that race. It's it's, you know, it's all black people doing it.
I know, but you do need to control for that cohort cuz it is
a fundamentally different issue leaning to the poor thing, too.
There's so many ways you can come at it, but Piers is just like
Piers is just trying to hear things. He's got an earpiece in
and he's just trying to ask for all of the stats, all of the
clips. He's just like, "Oh, we're going to do a hit piece on
this guy and we need to make it good. Okay, I got all you fact
checkers." And they don't think about the overall cohesive story
they're trying to tell. They just think of like, "How do we say
that Nick Fentes is wrong?" That's the entire interview is just
And I think it goes into places where Piers is basically making
himself look like an a hypocritical,
right? He's trying to prove Nick Fenta is wrong, even when Nick's
saying things that like are arguably correct or are correct.
And you look stupid when you do that. You have to actually be
discerning and know whether or not he's incorrect or know what
what he's trying to say. And there, dude, and not that Nick makes
it easy. Nick has a lot of talking points that are explicitly
meant to be Mott and Bailey's that he can switch out, right?
If he learned one thing from Destiny, it's this. It's that he
could say, "Oh, the majority of blacks need to go to prison."
And then when you ask him about it, he's like, "No, no, no. There's
like a subset of black people who commit too much crime, and
I think those people need to go to prison." Right? And you need
to actually be you need to actually do the work of like chasing
him down on that and and like but it it's just not happening.
Piers is just like getting uh Can you fact check the last thing
he just said? He just said he's from he's got Italian parents.
Can you can you check that? Uh actually your parents are from
Sicily. Your parents are from like your parents are technically
not from somewhere. It's generally considered Italy. Hold on.
It it's like okay why why did you just fact check that? Why are
you why are you doing this? Piers, >> it's indisputable.
I've got no problem saying that. The difference is I don't then
lead myself into a thought process where I have to avoid all
black people in case they sh me. And you've already conceded
that you are a racist. So when people hear you then say, "I don't
want to be living anywhere near black people." They already have
heard you say, "I'm a racist." So they assume you're doing that
because of people's skin color. I don't think you would probably
dispute that, right? >> Well, you you're separating two
different things. The monologue when I said, "I don't want to
live around black people." Well, that was after Ireina Zerutuska
got shot. And it's true. I mean, they are they are Why does Nick
live in Chicago if he doesn't like black people? I don't know.
Cuz that's where his parents bought him a house. Probably that's
where his parents bought a second property that he lives at for
a long time. He didn't make that much money. He could probably
move now.
I think I think he's like talking about moving. He might go to
NYC though. And he
I could see him moving to New York City and then just being like
complaining about black people all the time, but also just loving
it there. You know what I'm saying? Like on on some sneak. Black
people really do commit more crime. Also, I want to live in this
really black city, this historically black city or, you know,
larger than the national average proportion black city.
Like like really it's just totally undercuts a lot of their points
and but it's very funny. It's very cool.
>> Largely in this city in Chicago, the southside, the
west side,
huge criminal population, and I don't want to live anywhere near
it. And and I do I want to live in a white neighborhood. I I
think that uh that's extremely desirable. And I think even black
people, >> again, Nick, you're perfectly entitled to that
view. But when you have obviously prefaced all this by saying
I am a racist unashamedly,
then people will assume that all your thought processes about
all of these issues are driven by an aversion to people based
on their skin color, which is the purest personification of racism.
Well, it's not it's not an aversion. I would say it's the opposite.
Um I I like my own people. My own people are familiar to me,
and I think that's true across the board. I think that uh people
seek out other people that are like themselves and every other
group does this whether it's blacks, Hispanics, Asians. You know,
I I get a lot of attacks when I talk about that I'm against interracial
marriage. And what's funny is that every other group is against
interracial or interthnic
>> You're the product of an interracial
>> Yeah. I mean, that's debatable.
>> Okay. I also
want it is debatable but it's it's just crazy why would you be
against that like why would a lot of people who are the products
of interracial marriages or interthnic marriages they will say
that it's actually a mistake you shouldn't do that it leaves
people without a culture leaves people without a like home base
they don't know where to go they don't have an identity a lot
of people will say that right so I like you could still critique
these things
um you're actually born a certain way in a certain environment
why do you reject things from that Why? Why can't the natural
way just be proper, Nick? Why can't you just accept that your
parents did it one way and you have to do it this cuz that's
cuz that's the dumbest thing I've ever heard in my entire life.
What the is that argument you're making, Pierce? This is the
least intellectual conversation I've ever had in my life. This
is the dumbest I've ever seen. >> For the sake of argument,
>> no, no, you're the product of an interracial marriage
and your father is part Mexican. >> You're literally
literally the very person you've just told me you want to
>> What? What race is Hispanic? Is that a
>> Well, what do you think it is?
>> I'm asking you. What race is Hispanic?
>> Hispanic? Of course it's a race. It's called Hispanic.
>> It's a mix between two races. It's a mix between indigenous
Americans, though, is not white. >> Well, you're It's a
mix between indigenous Americans and white people. Oh, it's not
white, though, is it? Well, I don't know. The all the stats in
the US use it as white. There's non-Hispanic white, right? Or
Hispanic white, right? Like there's this is literally a part
of like most census information in the United States. You distinguish
between your group of white is white or or or non-Hispanic white.
If it's just white, that means whites and Hispanics.
So here, he's just he actually just doesn't understand the things
he's saying at all. It's it's crazy. >> Apparently, you're
more of a racial purist than me. You got like >> No, really.
You just keep saying you only want to live in a white neighborhood,
but you're literally from a mixed race background yourself. >> You've
literally got sick and blood. >> I know. And I live in
a non-white neighborhood, too. I'm trying to get out of here,
though. But I'm trying to get out. But here's the thing. >> Do
you have any non-white? Do you have any non-white friends? Genuine
question. >> Most of my friends are non-white. Most of
my friends are And non-white people love my show. How many are
honest? >> How many of your friends are black?
many of them, like at least a dozen. >> Yay. Yay being
one who you know, Sneo being another who you also know.
>> so how do they feel when you say you just want to be
away from any black people? Walk away from them. >> Well,
you know, you know what Yay told me? I'll tell you verbatim what
he said. That it doesn't come from a place of And you use the
word aversion. That's the first thing I'll >> Wait, what?
Oh, they cut it out. They cut it out. that it doesn't
sometimes ninjas just be ninjas was what Yay said. Okay. Sometimes
ninjas just being ninjas was when Nick used Nick said sorry Kanye
said hey Nick you use the nword I heard and Nick was like yeah
I do and then Kanye was like yeah sometimes
sometimes ninjas just be ninjas. That was the that was the >> come
from a place of and you use the word aver >> I don't know
if I'm going to play it on Twitch pluggy but thank you for the
clip. I I think I'm not going to play it on Twitch >> version.
That's the first thing I'll I'll actually dispute. Okay. >> It's
not an aversion on the basis of skin color because that that
would seem to suggest it's um like a stubborn irrational bigotry.
I don't consider myself a bigot. I consider myself a racial realist.
I'm realistic about how the races are and and I speak provocatively
about it. And I speak >> uh ninjas ninjas, not ninjas.
>> I'm realistic about how the races are and and I speak
provocatively about it. And I speak provocatively about our tribalistic
instincts and tendencies as human beings. And and I'm not a liberal
ideologue that says that over time and with enough education,
we're all going to see this great brotherhood where we're we're
colorblind and everybody's the same. You know, I don't think
that's ever going away. I think that race is real. It's not just
skin deep. It matters to us and it matters to each other. And
I'm and black people know that and Hispanics know that and Asians
know that. uh and and people like me that that have partial Mexican
ancestry, we know that too. And I think on that basis, we can
have mutual respect and understanding. Um not not aversion based
on skin color. >> The reason I use the word aversion is
you literally said that you should walk the other way if you
see black people. That is an aversion to black people based on
their skin color. >> Oh, no. No. That's called
>> Wait, how do you how do you how does he get away with
saying no here? Okay. I I what? No. What do you mean no? Do you
see black people walk the other way for your safety? No, that's
not an aversion to black people. That's just Wait, what?
>> The economy of information. That's economy of information.
That's safety. And I feel I said in the same monologue, if you
watch it, it's like I feel sorry. The problem is you clipped
the 10 seconds. I don't know if you watch the whole show, but
in that monologue I said most black people are not violent or
criminals. I said, and it's un okay. Realistically, the the answer
to this probably is just you should be like moderately somewhat
afraid of people who are walking up to you at night in some area
regardless of the race. If you want to say you're like scared
of somebody who's not your ethnicity, I don't really care. It's
sort of like the women who cross the street if they see a man
coming. It's like I don't you're safety is up to you. Whatever
you got to do, but it's maybe a different thing from preaching
about it. I don't know. Yeah. fortunate that we're going to offend
>> when we turn and walk the other way. I said, "But the
problem is we don't know. We can't tell." And someone like Inrea
Zerutka, she sat down in front of a black man with her headphones
in and wasn't paying attention because she was being a good liberal
and said, "I'm not uncomfortable by this. I'm progressive." Then
she got stabbed in the neck. And I said, "It's unfortunate that
you you would have to sit behind the black man to be safe. And
if he's not violent or schizophrenic, he might be offended by
that. I said, but I would rather how many deranged How many deranged
white men have committed atrocious acts of murder in the last
10 years in America? >> Proportionally far fewer. Far fewer.
>> How many? Do you know how many? >> You have a
research team. You pull it >> You're very big on You're
obviously extremely exercised by that one story which was horrific
for the record. Absolutely horrific. and should never have happened.
The person who perpetrated that evil act had a string of previous
offenses and should have been picked up more and it should have
been amplified more. I >> It's very interesting watching
Piers again decide to play both sides of this. He's going to
be the provocator who farms this and makes a ton of money off
of it and he's going to go it's totally insane for you to say
like because of that you should avoid black people. So Pers you
had a ton of people on who said exactly that point, right? You
wanted them to say that point. That's why they were brought on
when you could make money out of it. And now you're sitting here
like, "But I don't think that at all." And I would never I think
it's frankly disgusting that so many people platform you and
you make so much money. Come on, man. You do the same.
Well, sorry. You make money off of the same. You don't say the
opinions yourself. He's like, it's like the Ben Shapiro conundrum.
Ben Shapiro will say, "Oh, well, I didn't want to support Trump
because of all these authoritarian things I was concerned about."
But then he hired a whole bunch of people who support Trump and
push all of the same populist conspiratorial rhetoric that everybody
in the MAGA movement does. And then he goes, "But those aren't
my beliefs." It's like, "Okay, but you're benefiting from it
massively." You talking about Don't sit here and go like, "Oh,
I would never." Yeah, you would. Yeah, you would. Completely
concur with all of that. But I don't I just suspect you have
no idea how many white people have committed similar crimes,
do you?
No, because I know it's far fewer from experience because it's
like you said well and hang on and I would add to that you know
Ireina Zerutka wasn't the first one that was also after Austin
Metaf was killed in Texas after
white people
>> well hang on let me finish my point >> wait hold
on first that was also after Austin Metaf was killed in Texas
after
>> by white people >> well hang Let me finish my
point. >> White people don't do this. And my point to you,
Nicholas, is of course, of >> I never said white people
don't care. >> Of course, deranged white people commit
heinous acts. But you don't either know. You either you neither
know nor care or maybe both. Maybe you do know.
You only seem to be focused on black people who commit crimes.
And again, if you hadn't prefaced the whole debate about racism
by openly conceding you are a racist, I could read other
connotations into what you've been >> But he he is saying
it because he's right. It's literally his example.
You don't have to read anything into it. He's saying it because
he is racist. That's what he just said. Yeah. He's like, "Yeah,
I'm racist. I'm going to point these things out." >> Well,
once you said, "I'm a racist." And then you only talk about black
crime.
You're asking why he's he's hold on. You were saying you basically
the question was essentially why are you racist? He's answering
you on why he's racist. He's like, "Oh, you seem to be like racist."
No.
Peers. Yes, he is racist. Yes. I think people can watch this
and they can say, "Yeah, he is. He's a racist." And everything
that he says about crime is driven through the prism of being
a racist who judges people according to their skin color.
>> Well, it's funny because it's quite on the contrary
and I said this in a similar monologue. You know, the problem
is not that I wake up and I walk down. I would just like it's
obvious. The answer here is you are way more likely to make a
big deal out of black-on-white crime than anything else because
you think black people are naturally genetically uh predisposition
to violence. That's that's right. Is that not accurate, Nick?
Like you pay more attention to that because you feel like people
refuse to admit that. You feel like you have hidden knowledge.
So you're going to say, "Look, black people are more predisposition
to violence. They're they're more likely to do violence and here's
the evidence." So you focus on the same kind of crime. That's
I don't even know if Nick would disagree with that that he's
trying to like he's trying to tell people this is the way it
is and you don't trust me but here's the examples. He's like
trying to prove out a thesis with anecdotes and then he would
just lean into the whole yes I believe cuz I don't think Piers
actually gets that out of him even though Nick did say he's a
race realist. I don't know a lot of people probably don't even
know what that means.
A lot of people probably think they're race realist. Like if
you just only know the definitions of the word the of race and
realist they might think that too. Yeah, I know. I'm I really
understand race and that it's like not that big a deal. >> On
the street and I see someone that doesn't look like me and it
makes me angry. The problem is there's a pattern of behavior
>> which we've all seen. Blacks in America have become
narcissistic and they become narcissistic because they've been
told they're victims of racism. They're victims of slavery. They've
been told really there's no accountability
if they're rude, if they're inconsiderate, if they're criminal.
They are told that they have no agency for their actions. They're
being told if you act in this way, it's because the white man
made you that way. It's because the system's rigged against you.
And so we have been telling people this
and now there's no rules. Now they go and what we hate to see
as as decent people, not even as white people, but decent people,
even black people, too. What we hate to see is rudeness, obnoxiousness,
inconsideration,
criminality, violence, and and that's that pattern of behavior
that we see all over social media on the
You don't like You don't like black people who play the victim
and are rude. Is that your position?
>> I don't like that pattern of behavior. >> And
you are narcissists. >> I see where this is going. >> Yeah.
I had to turn this around. >> You're ahead of me, aren't
you? Cuz you when I said, "What black friends have you got?"
You said, >> "I'm I am kind of black, aren't I?" >> No,
not that. >> Nick Fentes thought he was going to be accused
of being black. Appears to go in a totally different direction.
He's like, "No, you're friends with Kanye. How can you say you
don't like rude, narcissistic black people when like rude, entitled
black people when you love the rudest and most entitled black
person of all?
>> You I'm not saying you. I'm just saying your choice
of black friend is yay, who is arguably the number one black
victimhood narcissist in America. Do you understand the problem?
So he's your he's your friend. He's one of the very few black
people you want to be associated with, but he's the epitome of
what you just said you abhore about narcissistic black people.
>> I disagree. I disagree with you. And I'll tell you why.
Because yay, if you've ever met him in real life, >> I
have. Yeah. >> Okay. Well, then you know he's nothing but
polite, considerate. >> He seems very rude to me the last
two times I interviewed him. He's a supreme he's a supreme narcissist.
And he's also >> You keep interrupting me. You're very
rude. Are are you black? Cuz you're being very rude by interrupting
me right >> to you. >> I'm I'm giving you a hard
time, but I >> Jesus Christ. >> Look, I do want to
finish my point. >> I I do want to finish my point about
Yay. He is a guy who when I was with him wanted to make sure
that everybody was heard, everybody felt included. He's actually
a very soft-spoken guy, very polite, and by the way, not violent.
When you look at all the rappers that are in the music game,
many of them, especially from Chicago, Drill Rap, they're talking
about people, shooting people, they gang bang. He notably, if
you know about him, he got a start because he was a nerd. He
wore a backpack and a polo and he wasn't a gangbanger. He wpped
about his feelings and girls and his dreams and his ambitions.
So, no. And by the way, he would tell me all the time, he doesn't
even feel black. They make him feel not black because he doesn't
do those things, because he's soft-spoken, because he's artistic,
because he's a bit of a nerd or likes fashion. So, I would disagree.
He's He's actually not like that at all. We're talking >> He's
also He's also a
anti-semite. And we're going to take a little commercial break
here and we're going to come back about and talk about
>> uh I
I never saw that you snuck that in. THAT'S WHY WE love them,
folks. No, it's not. It's not. It's not why we love them. That's
not why we love them. Stop. >> Anti-semitism and your views
about people and indeed what Y said about the same subject matter.
Angel Studios are back with a new must-see documentary. It's
called Thank You Dr. Fouchy, and you're going to hear a lot more
about it over the next few months. Award-winning filmmaker Jenna
First digs into the origins of COVID 19. A possible bio arms
race with China and claims about history's biggest public health
cover up. It's not a right-wing film or a leftwing film. It's
a film about
and if you've ever wondered, >> I'll let you watch the
rest of this cuz I'm going to use the bathroom real quick and
I don't want to miss anything. So, hold on. I'll just >> happens
behind closed doors. You'll want to see it. Angel Studios is
powered by his guild members voting on real stories. You can
find out more at
Become a member stream. Thank you Dr. Fouchy and be part of a
conversation demanding truth and accountability. Okay, back with
Nick Fuentes. Let's just turn to anti-semitism.
Uh in your interview with Steven Crowder last week, you answered
emphatically that you don't hate all. Is that correct? That's
your position.
>> Okay. Um so I want to play you this >> I don't
hate any Let me just amend that. I don't hate any. >> Okay,
let's let's play this clip. >> The reason I've had it is
because my opposition to world and Israel is rooted in absolute
uncontestable
>> Oh, it's the >> we have the truth on our side.
That's why we're winning because we are telling the truth about
the historical antagonism between I I'm so confident about this
clip. He is so mad. Him and Pierce can both share this. Okay,
they both work so hard. They do so much. And then Candace shows
up and Charlie told me he was betrayed in a dream. 150,000 viewers.
They didn't even come close to cracking 150k for this. I think
they got to 110.
Charlie told me I dreamed about beekeepers and Charlie told me
he was betrayed in my dreams.
150,000 viewers immediately.
They wish. They wish they could make and Europeans between
Christians. the theological,
historical,
racial, cultural, and political antagonisms
between organized and the Christians, organized
and Europeans. And the reason that we are winning that argument
is because it's real. It's true. I can prove it. I can show you.
I can name the names. I can show you the paper trail, the money.
That is why we're winning. That is why all of this is raising
the consciousness.
>> When you say you have this opposition to world I mean
it's one thing to criticize for example the Israeli government
over what it's been doing in Gaza. I've done that myself. When
you talk about world I presume you're talking about the 15 million
Jews in the world and you are opposed to them. How does that
square with your position that you don't hate
>> uh Okay.
I think I I think I haven't watched anything from this point
onward. So, hold on. It's uh it's going to be
that
that people do organize as like a a like distributed nation that
there are things that are like the World Congress and and there
are they're their whole thing. Uh the kick mobile app is so laggy.
Uh I'm sorry, man. I'm sorry, Jacob. Man, I saw you over there
all alone on Twitch. I felt bad for you. But yeah, I think that's
going to be what it is. No, I I only get mad at like Barry Weiss.
Well, do you take issue with my use of the term world?
>> What do you mean by that? >> These people, these
are the people I >> Or do you take issue with it? Do you
have a problem with that? >> Clarify what you mean by it.
>> Well, it's funny you bring that up. The gaslighting
is crazy because I use that expression on my show all the time.
I say organized world.
And do you know that for like 30 years the World Congress has
an annual keynote called the state of world
Barry Weiss has given it. You can look it up. It's on YouTube.
She gives the state of world.
>> But Nick, what do you mean by it?
>> I mean you have to talk about you know there's a concept
of peoplehood. It's the sense that they are part of a common
nationality, a common tribe, a common people. And so where they
reside in Israel, the United States, >> tribes, e tribes,
e you don't say tribes >> or Europe or elsewhere, they
see each
>> Sorry, I'm just I'm trying to make it seem racist. Okay.
What do you mean by >> died in Israel, the United States
or Europe or elsewhere? They see each other um above or maybe
on a different level alongside their their uh nationality,
their um you know their Okay. Okay. Okay. See that right there?
If you know anything about Nick or on a different level, that
doesn't mean anything. He threw that in there to like kind of
soft like sweep for himself. Okay. No, your argument is that
the Jews do consider themselves above everybody else. That that's
why they seek to control things. That they think they're way
better than Christians. They think Christians and the rest of
the world are goyam. Okay, that's come on, man. Or on a different
level. That's what does that even mean? Jews might run this whole
Congress, this world congress, because they think they're worse
than other people. They're trying to control. No, I Dude, that's
a total soft sweep that Pierce can't pick up cuz he he's not
sincere. state, wherever they reside, if they're in Germany,
France, the United States, they see themselves as part of a transnational
nation of an international nation. Uh the Jews in America, the
Jews in Israel, they they identify as Israeli or American, but
they also have something in common. They identify as part of
a common nation, which I would say there's a world population.
It's world and world has representatives.
Uh there is such a thing as the World Congress where they actually
elect it's democratic all the local
>> Wait, I didn't ban just what are you talking about?
I just banned some random guy. I have no idea who that was. I
didn't recognize the name and I was just like, "Oh, go bye."
Organizations elect
to represent proportionally the population in their area at the
World Congress. And it's sort of like Davos. It's like the World
Economic Forum, but it's exclusively for members of the nation
that exists across the world. And so, uh, that's a real thing.
And I didn't make that up and that didn't come from 4chan. It's
like I said in that clip, I read what they write. I read their
books. I watch these speeches. I watch a speech from Barry Weiss.
I pay very close attention. So, that's what I mean by that. There
is such a thing as it's a nation that exists across borders on
a global scale. They're organized and they have a a national
self-interest as that nation, as that tribe. >> So So if
you don't hate any, what do you like about them? >> I like
a lot of things about them. I think they're funny. I think they're
smart. Um I I think that they're they're pretty remarkable people.
And as Christians, especially as Catholics, we say they're remarkable.
>> They're worthy adversaries. That's what I like about
them most. They're worthy adversaries. Uh, and this has been
adjudicated in in Catholic doctrine for thousands of years. We
say that they're a witness people. And so we actually, you know,
there's provisions inside of Catholic doctrine that says we need
to give them special protections because they were a witness
to Christ's passion. So, uh, you know, this is why you can't
clip the show. You have to watch the whole thing. I say this
repeatedly in interviews.
I do think they're remarkable. I by definition, they're exceptional
people. It's just that there is there is a a sort of natural
opposition between them and Christians because of the theology
we believe that Christ is the Messiah.
They don't they have been a minority. I mean also what Pierce
should do is she he should be asking about okay what if they
like why do you think this is a big deal? Cuz Nick will go and
say like these are things he'll say on a on the surface that
these are things that are true that there's like a natural tension
because they don't believe in Jesus. They think Jesus was like
a charlatan. Okay. But then he'll go further and say that that
has put them on a collision course with Christians everywhere.
That they're super hateful of Christians. That they do try to
destroy anything Christian in the world. They're responsible
for like wars and right. He would go way further than this. But
you do have to ask questions. You got to poke and prod because
if you don't ask questions, he'll just go, "Oh yeah, I think
they're like they're organized. They're smart. They care about
each other. Like I just want what they want for but for white
people instead." Right? White Christians. That's what he'll say.
But it's like all of the there's a lot of conspiratorial stuff
around and I'm like honestly I say conspiratorial cuz I'm aware
some of it's conspiratorial. Some of it I just have never looked
into. But you you should ask about that cuz that's where the
actual negative beliefs are here. Like he could say this and
I don't even think he's lying. I think he's telling the truth.
It's just he's leaving out all of the negative parts and Peter
has to ask about them to tease them out in Christian lands for
thousands of years and they have been pushed around and expelled
and they've been persecuted and segregated
and that's why there's a lot of paranoia. There's a lot of distrust.
Um there there's maybe some sense of chauvinism among Jew people.
Um, so there is, like I said in that clip, there is an historical
antagonism between these two peoples, between Chris and Dumb
and
that has always been the case in Europe. But I I don't hate them.
And I think I actually sort of understand them in a weird way.
I think that because I've studied a lot of their politics, I
think I really kind of know them in a way. It doesn't come from
a place of hatred. >> Do you have any friends? >> Why
would that matter? Why do you ask about your friends if Dude,
such a stupid question. Such a stupid question. How does this
manifest, Nick? The thing you just said, how does that manifest?
Would be the way you go. Also, guys, we're going to end on Twitch.
Just going to go over to kick only for the rest of the stream.
Okay? So, hop on over to kick if you're watching on Twitch. We'll
see you over there in just a little bit. Okay. Thank you for
being here, everybody.
Going to end the Twitch stream now and turn off multi streaming
and then be over here on
kick only. All right, let's go. In a weird way, I think that
because I've studied a lot of their politics, I think I really
kind of know them in a way that doesn't come from a place of
hatred. >> Do you have any friends?
>> I do. I have many. Yes. >> Well, that's weird
because you said this, dude. >> Well, that's weird cuz
you said this many. Yes. Uh, here's the clip. Here's the clip.
Uh uh, excuse me. You You don't hate all Excuse me. Oh, you say
they can't Excuse me. Look at this clip. Look at this clip. You
say you're friends. Look at this clip. But that's weird because
you said this >> Christians have never been friends ever.
Not since Jesus Christ fought with the Pharisees
have we ever been friends.
Not since Saul was leading the charge persecuting the Christians.
Not since the Roman Empire. Not since the Middle Ages.
Never. We've never been friends. We've never been allies. We've
always been set against each other actually. And even here in
the United States, it was communist
who were the >> dude. Uh, so what you're saying is Russia
and the United States have never been friends. But you have a
Russian >> Architects of both communism and the civil rights
laws that are dispossessing white Christians of their land and
>> The Christians have never been friends ever except for
you and your friends.
>> Yeah. So easy. As peoples. As peoples. As nations. Got
it. It's like so not confusing.
I I don't understand how Pierce fumbled this so badly. And I
saw so much cope. This happens every time with certain people
because like I I understand a little bit seeing Fentes is like
the ultimate evil. I understand that a little bit for some people,
but they they just have to lie to themselves about it. They're
like, "Oh, Fentes got totally cooked here. How? This is embarrassing.
THIS IS TRAGIC TO WATCH."
You're saying that Russia and the US have been adversaries. They
hate each other as nations. But you have a Russian friend. Do
you really have a Russian Excuse me, Nick. You have a Russian
That seems impossible. No, it doesn't. Think about it for two
seconds.
Not Not saying every individual Christian. And that of course
there have been Christians in there have been Christian converts
to Judaism converts Christian. You're nodding your head, but
you're you're asking this. I'm saying as peoples they
I'm a Catholic like you and I have many friends. I'm just trying
to compute what you're trying to say, which is Christians have
never been friends ever. And I'm like, well, you have friends.
I have friends. We're both Catholics. Therefore, we're Christians.
This all doesn't really quite add up. Well, like I said, all
this just said made Fuentes seem more reasonable. Well, the issue
is Purus decided that the way he was going to go into this was
he was going to say whatever Nick says, I need somebody to tell
me how I say you're wrong. And Nick started saying things and
Nick is trying to play like his coded game, right? He's trying
to not say the whole thing, what he really believes on everything
at the same time. And Piers goes, "Well, here for that coded
response, I'm going to explain why you're wrong." And it's like,
"Bro, you just dig a little deeper." He's going to say way more
insane.
Like way worse if you could just dig in a little bit, but he
doesn't. He just tries to pull a clip. Uh, you say you don't
hate all black people, but here's a video of you saying you were
going to beat a black person up with I see that seems a little
crazy. I don't think that clip gets introduced, by the way. That
clip is funny, though. >> That as peoples, there has been
an historical antagonism as peoples. And you could even say the
same about um blacks in the United States. Of course, there were
black and white people that were friendly with each other, but
in many ways, they were set against each other as groups. And
I think that's easy enough to understand.
The reason that many people think you're anti-Semitic is that
you have regularly downplayed
the Holocaust and in particular the number of Jewish people who
were murdered by the
um it's been said that you believe no >> Pierce Piers thought
this was his ace in the hole. Piers thought he had like a royal
flush sitting there that he like got dealt a hand. He had a royal
flush. He got he thought he had it. Okay. Uh, Nick Fentes, I'll
just ask him about the Holocaust and then I win. I win everything.
If if I just ask Nick Fentes about the Holocaust, little did
Pierce realize Nick could just like lie and misrepresent his
opinion. >> Than several hundred thousands have been, and
I'm going to play you this
>> People talk about, well, you know what about the gas
chambers? Well, to the extent that that's real, I find that hard
to believe, but to the extent that's real, there have been atrocities
committed and genocides committed in all times and all places.
Let's acknowledge why
casts the long shadow. Like, dude, there's
there is something to this a little bit. Not in the gas ch I
don't I'm pretty sure the numbers are correct for the Holocaust.
probably some mechanized like death systematic death machine
was built, right? I don't know about like gas chambers. I don't
know. I assume it's correct, right? I assume it's correct, but
I will say I don't know enough to go and like look. So, I'll
give you that little bit if anybody here is like that. Um
like I've never personally investigated or looked into this cuz
it's just not something I care like care about because the death
numbers I have personally investigated those all seem correct.
So, I don't know how they came about, but I like I believe in
them. And I just feel like
the reason the Holocaust is made big is because is pretty much
for this exact reason. It's like used as a essentially propaganda
tool. Like it is horrible. Absolutely. It's horrible, right?
It's horrible. It was a dangerous atrocity that should never
be not dangerous like brutal, disgusting, inhuman atrocity that
should never be recreated. But as was the great leap forward
and all the people dying there through neglect, right? So was
the hoodore. So was a whole bunch of like the Irish potato famine.
Like all of these things were all horrible. They're all horrifying,
right? Human action leading to mass death is always bad. But
the reason this one is is this way is because it's used as a
propaganda tool at this point. No, I do care about the Holocaust.
I I I appreciate people like Connor and Destiny now arguing that
Hassan is worth it worse than Nick Fontes because Ma was worse
than him. The correlary of that is the Holocaust isn't special
and actually all human life is about equally sacred and that
Mao is far worse than is not the worst person ever to exist in
history. So I'm glad that Nick so Nick Fuentes and Destiny and
Connor points can all agree on this that like the Holocaust isn't
really that big a deal. I love those guys for that. Okay, thank
you guys. Appreciate it. >> Because that confers a political
benefit upon Jews. That's why >> it doesn't really sound
correct. >> Who is the worst person? Genghaskhan. probably
Genghaskhan. People will argue that the were like the did the
worst atrocity. I think the Mongol campaigns when you hear about
them are far worse to be honest with you. They were straight
up personally they they created a system for mass rap and murder.
Listen, you go you pillage these cities. You rape as many women
as you can. You cut the ears off of as many people as you can
and we'll pay you based on how many ears you cut off of people.
It's like okay Jesus Christ. Jesus Christ
confers a political benefit upon that's why it doesn't really
sound correct to me. Wait a second. Takes one hour to cook a
batch of cookies and you have 15 ovens. Probably in four different
kitchens, right? Doing 24 hours a day every day for 5 years.
How long would it take you to make 6 million? Hm. I don't know.
It certainly wouldn't be 5 years, right? Uh the math doesn't
seem to add up there. >> You You think that's funny? >> It's
funny. It's amusing what you're doing because uh you know that
one was a joke. But do you want to talk seriously about the Holocaust?
>> Yeah, I do actually. I mean I do because I just find
it extraordinary that you would think the Holocaust could ever
be something that we could joke about. >> Why? Too soon.
>> Dude, Pierce Piers got so caught off guard by that.
Holy [__]
Holy dude,
Oh,
he can't believe it. He just can't He can't believe it. He can't.
He's just so lost there. >> Yeah, I do actually. I mean,
I do because I just find it extraordinary that you would think
the Holocaust could ever be something that we could joke >> Why?
Too soon? Is it too soon to make jokes? H >> how how many
people do you think died in the Holocaust? How many people? >> Um
I I don't know. I'm thinking maybe 7 million. What's the number?
76 million, something like that. >> So you you >> 8
million. >> You can see that 6 million died in the Holocaust.
Piers literally can't understand at all that Fuentes is doing
like jokes here to like trivialize the question, right? Like
that's the play they do.
Like Piers Piers literally doesn't understand. He's like, "Oh,
thank you for accepting this."
Possibly more, possibly. You know, we're discovering all the
time. Um so it could maybe even be more than that. >> So
why have you why have you doubted the numbers in the past? >> I'll
tell you why. Um,
I really think that every death is a tragedy, however many people
died in the Holocaust. Uh, and I'm not a World War II historian,
so I'm actually open to believing the official narrative. And
I've read some of the conspiracy theories. And to tell you the
truth, it's a rigorous debate. But you know what's interesting
about this is in many countries, it's not even legal to talk
about it. And that's really where my interest in the Holocaust
begins and sort of ends to tell you the truth is that if you
wanted to question the number, you would be put in jail in about
what is it 17 or 18 European countries. And I think that's really
the more interesting conversation which is that this is almost
like a a religious dogma in the West. No, this is, by the way,
this is where the this is the part cuz here's where I actually
agree with him almost entirely in that there's this thing and
we talk about like the mythology of the Holocaust. It's not that
the Holocaust didn't happen, it did happen. It was horrible.
But the mythology is like making it something unique and like
you can't joke about it ever and you can't talk about it. You
can't you can't say anything about it. It's like do I want to
like I don't take Holocaust deniers seriously. I don't I don't
take them seriously because I feel like they haven't really looked
into it. But also the idea that it is this totally sacred cow
that can never be questioned. That like anybody who asks about
it is automatically bad and anybody who engages in anti-semitism
is automatically an evil person who like can't possibly be looked
at any further. It's like okay I don't care. Like I I don't care.
I'm sorry. When you talk about dethizing the Holocaust, it's
the it's the idea that it's this unique thing that is un like
unparalleled in human history. It's not. It unfortunately humanity
sucks. And I don't care when you talk about the Holocaust, when
you talk about, oh, we need if it's or Israel, we need we need
to talk about the Holocaust or we need you to know about the
Holocaust because you have to understand why Israel is important.
No, no, no. If you can't define why Israel is important without
invoking the Holocaust, off
I happen to think Israel is important. I happen to think that
countries where or sorry peoples who have no ethnic like country,
no ethnostate, no no state where they are a majority or at least
the largest plurality of their own. I happen to think that they
are uniquely susceptible to being persecuted in those other countries,
okay? Where they're just minorities. They're like small fringe
minorities. I don't think that it's that bad, but you have to
decide which argument you want to make. And it can never be I
will never accept, well, actually the Holocaust happened, so
we have to have Israel. [__] off.
Okay? It's the worst. It's the worst reason. It's the worst example.
It's the worst argument you could possibly make. Off. No other
genocide, no other atrocity is treated like this. Could you imagine
if in the United States >> I hold on. I agree that the
Holocaust is intrinsically linked to Israel is intrinsically
linked to them seeking a country and making it a reality. I understand
that. But it can never be a justification for anything Israel
does now. It can never be a justification for Israel now. It
can be a justification for why they felt they needed to stay.
It could be a justification for why they ended up flocking to
that state, but it cannot be a justification for drone strikes
in the [__] Middle East in 2025. Okay, that is where
you need to all of the way off. Okay,
they said the number of Palestinians in Gaza is 100,000 and if
you don't say that, you're going to jail. You're banned on X.
You can't have a job. That's the part that's totally insane.
And a lot of people, they can't even make up their minds. I think
it's actually done a disservice if your goal if, and I'm not
saying you as Piers Morgan, but if your goal, if you're an advocate
for awareness about this, if your goal is to convince everybody
that this is the way the Holocaust happened, I think the last
thing you'd want to do is say that everyone that disagrees is
in jail and is banned and you're not allowed to say it. So, there's
really been no open debate about the subject since the scholarship
started to be produced about 60 years ago. >> There is
no there is no debate to be had about the number of people who
were murdered. Even the even the I don't think there's a debate
about the number. I I would agree with that. I think there's
probably if there's anything there could be maybe debates on
the mechanisms, but I don't again I tend to just believe it's
like whatever if you it it seems so inconsequential to me. It's
not technically inconsequential because you know if it's deaths
by famine and you know just straight up it's a little different
than creating this industrialized machine for the pure purpose
of getting rid of as many of these people as possible that's
so it is like consequential but to me it's not consequential
right like to me today it's not super consequential I don't believe
in most of the values of you know outside of like some idea of
nationalism
right I don't believe in most of their ideas so I don't need
to defend them it's not consequential to me to make them more
evil Nazis in the trials after the war confirmed the numbers
the amount of document sorry don't believe in ethnosentric view
of the world don't believe in anti-semitism broadly is a is an
idealistic thing I'm trying to think of other stuff that not
believed in that I should say I explicitly don't because I just
said I believe in some I don't believe in most of the things
I just meant there's probably some things that I would believe
in right like if drinks water it can't possibly be bad to drink
water like you probably share some overlaps with H loves dogs
you can't say it's like a trait to love dogs I was just trying
to think of that. But yeah, most of the really bad parts about
them I don't really have that much I have no affinity for. I
like straight up dislike. I straight up don't
that was recovered notwithstanding the attempts by the to destroy
it. The amount of documentation that was saved and preserved
and used for trials of historical record is unprecedented
in the history of mass slaughter of human beings. So we have
a very clear idea of how many people were gassed to death in
the gas chambers. We have a very clear idea of how many was Xanaki's
got commitment. You love to see it. >> Staff to death were
kept in ghettos died of disease of forced labor of death marches.
We know how many Jews were slaughtered. It's at least 6 million.
Uh what's interesting to me is that you appear to now concede
that which may be news to a lot of your regular viewers who have
constantly heard you quibble with the number of Jews who died
in the Holocaust. And for the record, just to confirm what I
think you told me, you do now accept that at least 6 million
Jews were killed in the Holocaust. >> Well, no. I I said
it could be it could even be higher than >> Well, it could
be higher. That is at least right it is at least oh it's at least
6 million but it could be 100 times more people are going to
be okay the people
>> Piers is like too old to understand the memes here that
Nick is just memeing out of the question and all the people who
like him like Piers is basically giving him credit for the answer
right the answer Piers wants and Nick is memeing and Piers doesn't
understand that he's memeing so he's giving him credit for the
answer for all the normies in the
Morgan is a >> thank you very much for Thank you very much
Dave Portoy for the five. Appreciate it, buddy. Yeah. So, Piers
has given him credit like social credit for the normies of like
agreeing and Nick just said Nick is doing the whole meme of like
No, I I walk I see Abby Shapiro at Starbucks and I say I think
it was 7 million, right? That's Nick is just leaning into that
exact meme. Oh, it could be a hundred times more. It could be
like all of the people. Yeah, it could be Yeah, it could be anything,
guys. He's like leaning into so many memes there and Piers just
doesn't detect it at all. Can't see it. But let me but let me
respond to your let me respond to the rest of your question.
>> What you're saying I understand where you're coming
from when you say it has been documented and there are confessions
and so on. Let that speak for itself but you don't see you know
your show is called Piers Morgan uncensored but the United Kingdom
is censored and Europe is censored. And I will say the very interesting
conversation now is I think the conversation can no longer be
sunlight is the best disinfectant, right? The conversation is
sunlight has proven not to be the best disinfectant. Sunlight
has failed. What now?
That's like where the conversation is, right? anybody who still
truly believes I'm of the belief that like I kind of want to
go that way and let people have their free speech and if humanity
can never adapt then I'm fine with you know whatever happens
happens but I I would totally understand somebody I would have
no actual condemnation for somebody who's like actually we do
need to cancel people and actually like sorry I wouldn't have
an ideological condemnation I would disagree but I wouldn't go
you're a terrible person I totally understand somebody who is
willing to go I actually think we do need to ban some people
I think we do need to like get some ideas off the internet cuz
people cannot critical thinking for themselves, right? The reality
has always been the black pill. People are stupid. Sure, Kenny,
you could say that, but here's where it is. It's like
indisputable. Yeah, undisputed and indisputable that this is
the way it is. Like, clearly sunlight was not the best disinfectant.
We live in an age where you can flood the zone with so much disinformation
that the sunlight can't actually reach it all. That there is
other stuff that's down in the middle of this pile of that will
never be reached by the sunlight. Okay? And what do you do about
that? How do you handle that? I don't know. And if you talk about
these things, dude, we haven't even gotten to the age of like
mass widespread agentic AI that could be like posting your clips
everywhere, that could be liking all of your stuff. You just
pay yourself for individual AI agents to go and follow your stuff.
Like, it's so unbelievably over in every possible way right now.
God, you will be put in jail in many countries. And I think that's
where a lot of people start to say, well, if the truth is so
clear and if there's such overwhelming evidence, why do you need
to throw people in jail for disagreeing? And you yourself said,
well, there is no debate. I think everything is debatable. I
think everything at least should be debated. And if the evidence
is very one-sided, let the evidence speak. Don't throw people
in jail. So, do you think that Holocaust denial laws should be
>> I don't particularly agree with Holocaust denial laws.
I don't think people should be in prison. Well, because I have
a blanket view now which has evolved slightly actually over the
years that I have a blanket view that speech should not be criminalized.
Right? People should be allowed to say what they want to say
and they should be then made accountable for what they say. If
you have an employer, they can make a view about whether you
are the right kind of person they want for their employment as
they would make a decision about anything else you do in life.
So I actually believe that speech should never be criminalized.
It's my personal view. I understand why in places like Germany
they have strong laws about it because they want to move on from
what they believe was the most shameful moment in their history.
I understand that. Uh do I want that in my country? No. Am I
appalled by what has been going on with free speech in United
Kingdom in the last two or three years? Absolutely. It is ridiculous
that people have been frog marched to prison cells for stuff
they put on social media. Right. So yeah, I do I think what is
more interesting to me. Imagine it's 2025 and you're getting
your app blown out by Nick Fentes on whether the Holocaust
Dude, things you thought would never happen. Okay. Nick Fentes
goes on a an incredibly popular live stream in 2025. The host
asks him, "Did the Holocaust happen?" And the host is thoroughly
crushed in front of a 100,000 live viewers. Now, is Nick representing
his true beliefs here? I don't think so. I I don't think so.
But cold comfort it is to say, "Oh, well, I don't think that's
his sincere opinion."
Piers could have pulled out his sincere opinion. Piers could
have like gone deeper on some of this. He could have done something
else. Holy [__] It's rough. It's rough time 2025.
Okay. Going into 202 going into 2026, I don't know, man. Stuff's
scary about our exchange is I was not expecting you to go the
opposite way. I was not expecting you to be so emphatic that
at least 6 million died on the Holocaust. And there'll be people
watching this who I think will be very surprised by that because
you have built a reputation for being if >> Dude dude Piers
doesn't even realize he just made like a viral clip and there's
going to be so many people who see. He said it COULD BE A HUNDRED
TIMES MORE. HE WASN'T SINCERE. There going to be so many people
seething about this. He just made like a million more clips.
This is
unless something changes in the next hour. This is like a total
cataclysmic victory for Nick Fuentes. this entire interview.
It's >> not a Holocaust denier than somebody constantly
questioning in a downward way the number of Jews who were murdered.
That doesn't appear to be what your position is now. >> No.
And and here's what I Oh, another Yeah, there's another hour
on this interview. This interview is long. This interview is
very long. Okay, guys. If you like the content, go ahead. You
can throw up a couple bucks my way. Add some more time to the
stream. We need more hours on the stream. I think we're five
subs away for another hour on the stream right now. You can sub
through kick. You can give subs kick. You can sub on Twitch or
sub with your Twitch primer.
All right. Exclamation point. Donating in the chat could give
you the links to buy a TTS message. Okay. There's Kickbot for
the AI voices. There's Streamlabs for the $3 minimum and better
payment details saving. I think I think Kickbot doesn't save
your payment details, so it's kind of annoying for some people.
But if you want to add more time to the stream, there are your
avenues. Okay. There's also the Patreon.
>> You can sign up for the Patreon. Help give me some income.
help me out in case we ever get clapped off one of these platforms.
It's a different platform. It's it's off. It's away from all
these other things. So, we always have a community there. Okay.
Thank you very much, guys. Thank you for all the support. I appreciate
it. Let's add some more hours on the stream so we can cover this
whole interview and do some of the stuff we want to do after.
Okay. Thank you very much. Let's continue. I would like to see
for my entire career
when I started my show, it started with a good faith inquiry
where I was questioning a lot of these narratives and I said,
"What is the answer on the other side?" But what I found is that
the answer was criminalized. So when you would talk about anything
regarding Israel, the Holocaust, you could be in favor of the
official narrative on those things. No conversations around Israel
except I guess BDS laws, antiBDS laws was criminalized. Come
on, man. You could talk about Israel. You did talk about Israel.
You could say I guess I would go as far as saying it's not criminalized,
but it's something that's looked upon as bad. Sick monkey chamber,
thank you for the primer. I appreciate it, dude. if you went
against, you were banned, censored, and in some countries jailed.
And so I actually haven't made up my mind on that because that's
not really a matter of interest to me. And there's a lot of analysis
and scholarship on both sides of the issue. And I've read both
sides of the issue. And honestly, unfortunately,
it's hard to judge because there has never been >> there's
never been a debate on it. And there's never been a debate because
of the Wait, what? Wait, huh?
What did this mother just say? Where's the hole? Deploy the hole.
Where where's the I I actually did watch this part >> Analysis
and scholarship. >> Listen to that again. He's talking
about like why he thinks there was like good points from Holocaust
deniers >> on both sides of the issue. And I've read both
sides of the issue. And honestly, unfortunately, it's hard to
judge because there has never been >> there's never been
>> no where I don't think was ever cool. I don't think
he said that. I think what he said was where's the cool but you're
right that is cool because that's the clip that comes up where's
the cool bit he's like basically trying to now this was a good
tactic if you'd had any amount of like win here if you got the
windows at all just $5
real question for you what do you think explains higher average
IQ among
population and their propensity to occupy positions of influence,
>> 2,000 years of having to get creative with how you make
money and keeping that genetic group fairly like clearly um isolated
from other genetic groups, right? Like it's its own haplo group
that's very very disconnected. So they took on basically your
ability to rise in a society is based on your propensity for
scholarship and 2,000 years of that kind of selective breeding
where like you're you're seen as a select or a good mate based
on your propensity for scholarship. I'm guessing that's what
it would be. Yeah. I thought inbreeding made you only cousin
level or worse inbreeding and I think their populations were
big enough that they didn't have to date date their own cousins.
I think even the cousin stuff is like not that bad but also I
think I think they do have some inbreeding issues. No, don't
they have like a way higher propensity for mental illness like
every every genetic mental illness. I thought were like a super
high risk group for a ton of mental and genetic illnesses. Is
that not the I I'm pretty sure that's the case but hey I don't
I don't know for sure. Not 100%.
Okay, what else we got here? Give me a second.
Give me a second.
Okay, we're continuing on with this. And then,
oh, huh? Where's the this cool clip? Deploy the cool clip. Piers
was trying to cook on the Holocaust. And then I think it seemed
like he lined up. Okay, we're going to go from like Holocaust
denial to what do you think about? Let's check it out. And a
debate on it. And there's never been a debate because of the
stigma, because of the censorship. And I think that leads a lot
of people to say, well, what do they have to hide? Because you
can say on your show, well, I'm personally against Holocaust
denial laws, yet they still persist and the social consequences
still persist. And I think that that is the anomaly. And I mean,
what you should say here from Nick's side, in my opinion, the
best argument is, why can't I advocate against Holocaust denial
laws? Why am I seen as evil if like you don't believe in Holocaust
denial laws, but what would you think of me if I was saying,
"Oh, we need to get these all off the books." Like, wouldn't
you actually And then be honest, but Piers wouldn't be honest,
right? He'd be like, "Oh, I disagree. I wouldn't be that mad
about it." Yeah, right, [__]
Yeah, right. Come on, man. And people have to wonder, okay, why
is it that way? And what I said in that clip is the reason the
Holocaust cast a long shadow is because it confers a political
benefit upon organized. That is what they always fall back on.
They cannot be criticized. They cannot be named. They cannot
be talked about lest there be another holocaust. And no other
tragedy is treated that way. And no other ethnic group has a
get out of jail free card. Just play that. Anti-semitism and
holocaust. You can do whatever you want and defend all your actions.
That's the part that people are getting upset with. That's the
problem.
>> I think that's broadly true. I don't think that has
anything to do I don't think you have to deny the Holocaust for
that. You can accept that the Holocaust was really bad and happened
exactly the way history remembers it, right? >> I don't
know any right-minded person who believes that people weaponized.
>> I don't think the usery thing like really actually comes
into play here. I do think they engaged in usery because it wasn't
against their their religious teachings, evil Johnny Bravo. But
they did they were people who were brought in to lend money in
a bunch of different like Christian kingdoms. I do think in general
their religion is a lot especially rabbitical Judaism was a lot
about scholarship and then yeah the the usery stuff coupled with
um just in general the religious propensity for scholarship and
I think based like they did a lot of white collar work before
it was popular to do so.
>> I think that's almost all of it. Just tip $5 cute hypothesis.
I think we both know the real. Sit your ass down and watch Shindler's
list. Baruk God's chosen people. Sit your down and watch Shindler's
list. Baroo Adonai. Adonai. I can't do the voice. I tried to
do the voice to make up for it because it did up. But I did appreciate
sit your down the Holocaust for their own personal get out of
jail free or whatever. You don't know anyone that does that,
that believes that? >> I'm sure there are some people that
do that, but it's such a ridiculous generalization.
You know, the truth is that most
>> That was the moment right there. That was the triple.
>> There are some people that do that, but it's such a
ridiculous generalization
the This is Nick Fentes when he stops doing the Trump neck thing
where he stops like sticking his neck all the way out. Ra, you
got to you got to get got to get the calories down again. Nick,
do do you guys remember? Oh, you wouldn't remember. You didn't
watch him. He used to he was getting like fat at some point two
years ago maybe and he started joking about it. People laughed
at like how his suit wasn't fitting at all and all of this and
he had to he had to stop eating so much. He just eats like McDonald's
and junk food and Hey, guess what buddy? You're getting old.
Not going to be able to eat all that anymore. All right. You
got to you got to lose some weight. You can't be fat and compelling
at the same time. The truth is that most Jewish people
have lost relatives in the Holocaust. In fact, I want to play
you I want to play you two two clips. One is where you talk about
Adolf >> was a kind of >> I didn't realize I left
it slow. What the I somehow I did drop to 0 75. I didn't hear
it for a second. That's my bad. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. It was a 0
75. That's my bad. That's my bad. Hit him was a
and kind of a pagan. It's like, well, he was also really cool.
So,
you know, time to grow up. We're not We're not children anymore.
Am I right? AM I RIGHT? AM I RIGHT, BOYS? Am I right? Let's go.
He was all Listen, listen. How is he gonna get out of this one?
How is he How could he possibly get out of this one, guys? He's
just saying cool. That's so disgusting,
dude. It's there's nothing more lefty coded than doing like zero.
By the way, Nick's actually anti-semitic, so you could prove
all of these things about him. Okay? Like like you're trying
to prove he's anti-semitic, but you're using all of these clips
that are really him joking in a way that comports with his beliefs.
He's doing jokes that are hyper that are hyperbole over his beliefs,
right? And you could go to the beliefs, but you're going to go
to the jokes and like I would even say he probably believes this,
but he's saying in like a joking tone and everything. And Piers
is just gonna present this and go, "Uh, yeah." So, there's that.
What do you say about that? Come on, man. >> Also, really
[__] cool.
>> Do you regret saying that? >> Uh, saying a fact?
No. No, that's absolutely true. >> Do you think was very
[__] cool? >> Yes, I do. >> One of the
>> And I'm tired of pretending he's not. >> Well,
to be honest, >> this is the problem. You see, it's a bit
like when you just say, "I'm a racist." you're a racist who thinks
cool but you're not anti-semitic.
If you're a
person watching this,
what are they thinking? I'll tell you what they're thinking because
I've got a friend of mine called Danny Finkelstein
who when he heard I was interviewing you. He's a Times journalist
in the UK, very eminent journalist here and author who wrote
a book about his own family's experiences at the hands of and
Stalin because he also told Tucker Carlson uh that you
>> Listen, I know Hold on. Hold on. Hello. >> Reuben
Ruben donated three. >> Hello, Ruben Ruben. >> That
paw's blurry frame is POV of seeing Nick Fuentes after he serves
you some >> The triple chin one. Okay. All right, dude.
I
I can't believe Piers did this. Piers tried to go, "Here's like
a I know. Here's a I know who wants to tell you that you suck.
Here's some like I know, and they're going to tell you that you
really hurt their feelings, Nick."
Okay, cool. Cool. I get a call >> Stalin. But let's let's
just take what Danny said here. >> My peers, it's Danny
Vinklestein here. As you're interviewing Nick Fuentes, you might
try suggesting to him that he reads my book Stalin Mom and Dad.
It's called Two Roads Home in the United States. Since he says
he's on team, >> I think you should Does he not know that
did some bad things? Does he not? If Nick Fuentes is coming on,
then I think you should show him that he did some bad things.
Okay. I think uh if you read my book, he would understand that
did some very bad things. Cool. Cool. Dude,
>> he you might like to ask him about the fact that arrested
my mom, tried to starve my mom to death. Did starve my >> Starve
me mom. Starve me mom >> to death. Sent my great aunt to
the gas chamber. My great uncle. My cousin. My grandmother on
my father's side ended up being one out of seven children. >> That
is true. That is Nick's biggest challenge in this whole [__]
interview is just trying his hardest not to openly laugh at this.
Okay. Just trying so hard not to start cackling
>> The only one that survived the war. See >> Nick
absolutely just memes the [__] out of this, right?
I assume so. Yeah. How could you not How could you not meme this?
This is like embarrassing. This is tragic. Do you think Do you
think nobody's ever gone to Nick Fentes and said, "Hey, have
you ever unders Have you ever thought like maybe people don't
like you saying these things?" I'm pretty sure he gets it. I'm
pretty sure he knows that they don't like him saying the things
he says. >> I'm pretty sure
is right.
>> WHEN I WATCHED THIS STICKFUL LIT FELLOW, I WAS ABSOLUTELY
APPALLED OR A TRAVESTY to be so openly anti-Semitic. >> Despicable.
I don't know what the voice was, but thank you very much for
the five. Appreciate it. Danny Finkelstein.
Appreciate it. The guy who did the book. OH, IT'S THE GUY WHO
DID THE BOOK. God
>> Seven children. The only one that survived the war.
So, you might ask him whether he wouldn't rather be on team mom
rather than team. And as for >> Oh, wait. Danny Finkele.
Wait, this guy's name is Finkelestein, too.
>> Wait, everybody's name Finkelestein? What the [__]
All the way down. >> Celebrating Stalin's birthday. Well,
Stalin took my father, sent him to a state collective farm, sent
my grandmother and my chamber. >> I'm sorry. I actually
just realized that the better way to handle this clip would be
to >> my grandmother to death. Sent my great aunt to the
gas chamber, my great uncle, my cousin, my grandmother on my
father's side ended up being one out of seven children, the only
one that survived the war. So, you might ask him whether he wouldn't
rather be on team mom rather than team. And as for celebrating
Stalin's birthday, well, Stalin took my father, sent him to a
state collective farm, sent my grandmother and my uh to a state
collective farm, sent my grandfather to the gulag. You might
try asking why he doesn't celebrate dad's birthday rather than
Stalin's. It may all be a big joke to him, but he complains that
he was 18 when someone tried to cancel him. Well, Stalin and
arrested my mom and my dad when they were 10 years old. So perhaps
he might like to reconsider his joke. See is that's the real
>> Stalin and police known collab. Arresting that guy's
parents, okay, when they were 10. reality of your jokes, although
I haven't ascertained yet whether you are joking when you say
that was very cool. Are you joking or do you actually think he
was very cool? The the most genocidal monster of uh the last
150 years.
>> Yeah. The the thing is my generation, we're just done
with the pearl clutching, you know? Yeah, you might be, but then
your generation hasn't gone through what Danny Finkel, >> dude.
Pierce interrupts a lot in this interview, by the way. Not that
like you have to feel bad for Fentes for getting interrupted,
but he gets interrupted a >> Family went through. So maybe
maybe the pearl clutching has a way to go for families whose
whose family members go. >> Yeah, we we got all that. We
you know, me me mom me mom. Like we're you know, I don't even
know who this person is. >> Hitler imprison me mom. Star
imprison me dad. Why you like him? >> Is this person talking
to me? This old British guy is saying me mom got by. >> He
doesn't find it funny when you say
>> care.
I know you don't care. That's fine. You don't have to care. But
he does care. >> Does that guy care about America? Does
that guy care about me and my country and my family? No. >> He
cares what you, a prominent conservative in America, has to say
about Adolf. And what do you mean by is very cool because I think
he's very a
And that's a clip. I think he's very [__] very very
I think he's I think he's very monster. Wow. That's he's very
monster actually. Holy [__] Hold on. I have to Sorry.
Very a monster. Very a monster. conservative in America has to
say about Adolf. And what do you mean by is very cool? Because
I think he's very a monster.
Someone's bad. It is bad.
Okay. But like it's it's really the same sentiment. It's like,
okay, I'm getting exasperated at saying it over and over again.
I don't want to keep having to say it. I do think they're bad.
I don't want to keep having to say it. Please off. I understand
you think is bad. Okay, I get it. We all think Hitler is bad.
We're just tired of saying it over and over again when you when
you like you the up and then you say hit but was bad. I'm I'm
done with the bad excuse. Okay, I don't care anymore. I don't
care. I don't care. I don't care.
And that's a clip. I think he's very a monster. Do you hear yourself?
I mean, can we all grow up? Can we all grow up? >> He murdered
12 million people. He murdered 12 million people. What is very
cool about that? >> Tell me. >> Uh the edits. It's
just cool. The the uniforms, the parades, the it's it's cool
as a guy. You look at World War II and it's fascinating and it's
interesting and it's compelling and it's cool and you know, we're
just tired of saying these kinds of things. We want to talk like
real people and give our honest opinions and then we and then
we literally get an old guy from England who's going to say,
"Oh, that very funny, mate. Me mom." And it's like, "Shut up."
Like, you know, no one is in favor of genocide. So, let's just
get that out of the way. We're not in favor of a holocaust or
genocide. >> You think if half your family, >> you
think if half your family had been wiped out by very cool, you'd
still think he was very cool? Or would you think that actually
he was a despicable monster who murdered 12 million people who
targeted people because they were disabled or or Roman Egypt?
>> Sorry, I'm sorry I'm not laughing at Pers. I'm laughing.
>> Do you think that actually he was a despicable monster
who murdered 12 million people who targeted people because they
were disabled or
Romany gypsy or whatever it may be and that he systematically
destroyed people, incinerated them in gas chambers. Do you think
that you would find it very cool if your family had been through
that or do you think you >> So you set this whole thing
up and you have to understand there's literally no answer he
can give at the end of this that makes you seem like the winner
here. Like if he says I don't know. I don't know. You wouldn't
be that cool, I guess. Like you you still lose. You just look
like you're just soying at him. Unfortunately, that's the way
the culture is set up. I didn't write the rules. Okay. I didn't
write the rules. But with how hard you've gone here, there's
no way for you to come off looking good, right? It just it it
can't happen. It sucks. >> You would find it very disgusting
and perhaps moderate the number of times you you laugh about
it or want to joke about it or want to abuse someone like Danny
Finkelstein who's written incredibly powerful books about what
happened to his extended family at the hands of and your other
hero Stalin. See, my point to you, dude, dude, hold on. The tweet
got linked earlier. Okay. My parents were jailed and first by
then by Stalin. Well, both right-wing and leftwing dictators
hate you at a certain point. It's your fault. They didn't like
you in either of these camps. What the They both hate They both
hated you. My base when you got jailed by both Hitler and Stalin.
Nick Wes is that in parts of this interview
you tried to come across as moderate but every now and again
the mask slips and it slipped again here with what you say about
the m the mask doesn't slip. Okay. He's wearing a mask and he
laughs at your pathetic attempt to make the mask slip and then
he takes the mask off himself and goes boom.
Boo. And then he puts the mask back on because you are so embarrassing
in your attempts to make the mask slip that he has to take it
off just to laugh at you and paint you as a That's what's actually
happening here.
Jesus Christ, guys. What are we doing? Also, Space Ghost, thank
you for the gifted sub. Appreciate it, buddy.
There's nothing very cool about him. We know that from history
now. We know what he did. You've already conceded that he murdered
at least 6 million. So when you say he's very cool, people watch
this and go, "This guy is disgusting." Why would he say this
say this about someone who perpetrated such an evil and what's
the what's the real answer? Why do you is it just for clicks?
Is it for money? Is it just for fun? For and giggles. What is
it? What motivates you to say something like was very cool? It's
for this. It's for all of this. And and the lack of self-awareness
is amazing. You're you're a boomer. You're a 60 dude. The lack
of self awareness is amazing. He just wrote a book called Woke
is dead and he's like, "You really said was cool? This man's
dad and mom were jailed by him and stolen and you think it's
cool, bro. Woke isn't dead. Woke is alive and well with Piers
Morgan." Okay, again, you could you could actually dig into the
beliefs, but you didn't do that. You just want to go, "Oh, you
really think is cool?" Well, here's an old guy who says is not
cool cuz people and Nick's sitting there like, "Yeah, I know
people." Do you think that's not a part of the calculation? Yeah,
a bunch of people. We all know a bunch of people. When he says
was cool, do you think he's going well only people who didn't
kill people is cool? Seems like Nick's criteria is that only
people who kill people are cool. Stalin
huge dictators who killed a bunch of people are who he thinks
is cool. Maybe you could ask a question about that. Oh no, you
just have to performatively signal. Oh, he said he said these
dictators were cool and I don't know what to do about that. How
about you make a argument, loser? How about you do something
other than just go, "You can't say that. You can't say that.
You can't say that." Because at what point are you just the same
as every lefty who came before you and tried to cancel people?
I mean, here we are. We're at that pointy old boomer. And we've
spent maybe 3 minutes on you saying, "He's a really monster.
He incinerated people. This this and and I'm sitting here saying
it's not that serious. It's not that deep." been
getting at that serious are you want to say more about you're
not kid you're not a kid yourself anymore you're not a teenager
I know >> right you're you're nearly 30 to be clear okay
you're a fully formed adult >> who has a brain >> right
and at some stage that brain has taken you off these >> Is
this an interview or is this a lecture can I respond to what
you're >> I want you to really I want you to explain why
you think it's fine to say how cool he is and to dismiss miss
the very powerful 90 seconds from a British journalist who lost
a lot of family members to the in such a callous dismiss. Sorry
journalist who lost a sorry the faces the faces are just me the
whole time Nick doing the Lori Ellison himself now >> a
lot of family members to >> that hold on that one too so
many so many faces throughout this whole thing >> to the
in such a callous dismissive
>> I don't think it's powerful I think we've been hearing
that our entire lives okay the Schindler's list let's just be
honest the propaganda is over the top we have been in America
What about the shameless list? Tell me about the shameless. Well,
tell me about the shameless list. >> I'll tell you about
it. We have been browbeaten as a people, as Americans, as Westerners
for our entire lives. And do you know what this has done? It
has taken away any sense of pride, any sense of love for our
own civilization. We have been made the villain in our own story.
We have been made because, well, let's just be clear, it doesn't
begin and end with
is a monster. This has been the political narrative which is
>> uh oh why we have thrown >> he's he's Richard
Spensering but he's doing it way more effectively and with a
way less off-putting face and haircut not good this is Richard
Spencer's argument liberalism is actually the donut around all
the things that aren't you could be anything except anything
stood for okay and Richard Spencer's argument was always well
some of the things stood for were actually good but it's just
white people who aren't allowed to have them that was the Spencer
argument Right. And now Flint is making that same argument, but
he's doing it with a way less concerning haircut and just way
less like way more human seeming. The bar, not that Nick's like
Nick's not I don't think super like incredibly genuine here,
but Richard Spencer just clearly hated like 99.9% of people and
it showed all of the time. Hard to hard to start a populist movement
when you just actually see with disdain for every person below,
you know, the 99.9th percentile percentile of income. >> Don't
open the borders. This is a political narrative which is why
we're not we can't be a conservative society as a whole anymore.
Why we can't be proud of Europeans. Why we can't be proud of
being Christian. Because they've told us if you're too white
and too proud and too Christian, it's going to lead to a holocaust.
And so my generation, our entire
me, Mom. It's not funny. I'm serious. Watch Schindler's List.
It may teach you This is not something to joke about. >> It
may teach you a thing or two. This is not something to joke about,
dude.
Uh I do think the Holocaust is obviously horrible. I like that's
that's what you get out of me. The Holocaust was horrible. I
don't take it as a reason for any action. If you basically say,
"Oh, but the Holocaust for anything today, I don't care. I litally
you've made me stop caring and you could argue for something
I do care about and then you could trick me into not caring by
saying also the Holocaust happened somewhere in your argumentation.
You'll like trick me into not caring anymore. I'm like at some
point it's become such a red flag to me that I'm like oh this
person is not serious. Bongers should stop saying me mom for
real. Yeah, they should. They should. Okay, we are into the next
hour. We got an an extra hour on the stream. So very good. Lots
of time. Let's add more hours. We can we can get that number
higher. Okay. And that's what that's why people like me. That's
why I'm popular because of
>> Yeah. It's a croc WE DON'T WANT TO HEAR anymore mom
and me dad of >> listen what you just said is a croc of
sh and you know it. >> Unfortunately for peers he has a
cataclysmic deficiency within this conversation that Nick has
honed in on and is now taking advantage of. He is British and
the guy got to come on was British. Okay. And Americans can always
make fun of Brits for being British and win in the eyes of all
Americans.
Critical mistake conducting this interview while British. Okay,
you totally [__] it up. Very unlucky.
The open society >> in your and in your gut. You know it
is. You weaponize this stuff. >> You know, >> Carl
Pauper, open society. Uh, anything but nationalism is acceptable.
Just be very, very compliant.
That's
I probably actually agree with a lot of the open society, like
the philos the philosophy behind it, but I do understand how
it's sort of been used to pacify people in some ways. I don't
necessarily disagree with that. It's just an argument over whether
or not that pacification has been good or bad. >> You weaponize
this stuff for money, but you know, when you say something like
what you just >> from banking from banking and credit cards,
you know who you're talking to. I do it FOR MONEY. HOW MUCH MONEY
you make? Your company's worth $100 million.
>> It's really I
the you're doing it for money thing. You do this for money thing.
It's like the one thing you can't attack him on.
It's like the one thing that he for he like had foregone entirely.
He did not make a lot of money for a very long time. He's making
money now, but the rhetoric is roughly analogous. The rhetoric
is basically the same. Sometimes when he goes on big podcasts,
he tones it down. But on his own stream where he's making his
own money, that is all he's like the same person he's always
been like all of the time basically.
If if it's I mean I think the differences are like very obvious
and calculated when he like started talking about how he loved
Charlie Kirk or how he respected Charlie Kirk in some way. I
don't think that's true.
Yeah. Yeah. But it's like when you try to say he's doing this
for money, it's like dude, he he did this when he couldn't make
money. People don't do things for money at the start. I don't
think he was doing this for money. No, not in some like long-term
way at all. Yeah. I just don't I don't see it as him having done
it for money.
What? I do think that he doesn't respect Charlie Kirk at all.
He think he thinks Charlie Kirk is a total joke. He probably
doesn't care. He probably thinks it's cool that he got shot.
Probably rewatch the shot. Did you even watch the assassination
stream? Everyone cried. It was so real. It was not real. Nope.
Nope. Fentes did not care. Fentes did not care. I will stand
on that aundred times. Charlie Kirk made his life hell constantly.
And the second Charlie Kirk died, his life became a thousand
times better. Any crying about that is totally performative.
I'm sorry. Charlie Kirk was Nick Fentes's. Okay, you think you
could just joke about Charlie Kirk? My life was ruined by Charlie
Kirk. Me mom MAMA AND ME DAD'S life was ruined by Charlie. Nick
Fentes about to throw that clip out there. Okay, I'm telling
you. He's like, Charlie Kirk is not cool to Nick Fuentes.
Your company's worth $100 million. I was banned from Bank of
America. I'm banned from processing credit cards. >> And
he shouldn't have. >> No, you're talking about his one
crypto donor. He was not making that much money. He was not making
that much money at all. He was not making that much money. Okay.
I'm sorry. He wasn't.
He wasn't.
He was making He was making way less money than he'd make if
he had any of the open payment processors or open
And he invested in like, oh, I'm going to keep telling this story
and eventually it will pay off.
God bless. >> Damn. So don't tell me I'm doing it for >> not
not so much God blesses it and I believe in him. God bless with
that idea of like oh I'm correct and it's going to pay off eventually.
I that's the strategy I'm currently rolling with. So I hope in
the end it does work out. >> Well ask me my opinion about
that. I'll tell you you shouldn't have been right. I don't agree
with that. What happened to you? >> Then don't say I'm
doing it for money cuz you know that full well and you say it's
a money how much money to be a grifter. I'd be like you and I
would go and say >> how much money are you making? I'm
making a lot of money now that I'm the number one live streamer
in America because people agree with me more than they agree
with you. We're tired of hearing about slavery and the Holocaust
and Jim Crow. We're done hearing about that. You guys >> over
over hearing about that.
>> Okay. Well, you know, your generation's on the way out
and I need more I need more information about the Holocaust.
I'm a 60-year-old man who is supposed to be learned. does a whole
bunch of hosting of panels about different topics on the internet
and I need to learn more about the Holocaust and all of these
other things. Okay. Wow. Thank you, Piers. Thank you, Piers.
Why don't you go find a book and sit down and give it a read?
>> And Generation Z is coming up and we're >> Is
he actually the number one live streamer? When did he start using
that metric? Well, technically I think he's behind probably like
Candace and Tucker, but I don't think he counts them.
The right-wingers, there are not a lot of compelling right-wingers.
There's a huge there's a huge gap in like compelling right-wingers
who can talk and like give a a compelling show versus leftwingers.
There are a ton of left a ton of leftwingers who can give a semi-compelling
show. There are not very many right-wingers and Nick Fuentes
does stand alone with like a very small handful of people in
terms of the the people who command like a 100,000 live concurrents
at any given point in time. Like there are very few streamers
who can ever say credibly that anything they've ever done has
had 100,000 live concurrence. and Fuentes, Candace Owens, and
Tucker are all amongst them.
>> Finished with that. We're ready to take our country.
>> I've got three sons
>> I've got three sons and they don't share your views
about slavery and about the Holocaust. They can have decency
and compassion and humanity about some of the worst things that
have happened.
>> Should say that he is decency, humanity, and compassion.
He just understands how they're weaponized against them. That's
the line you should take here. You should never take the line
of like, "Oh, I want to be like performatively cruel for no reason."
That's stupid. That doesn't win in the long term. Right? You
need to say, "No, I am compassionate. I just understand that
my compassion has been weaponized against me and I won't allow
it anymore." That's what you say, right? You don't say, "I'm
not compassion." It's like, "I have compassion for people, but
when you demand things from me at the like using my compassion
as a club that you're going to club me in the head with unless
I agree,
like [__] that. [__] that." >> In
the last 150 years or more, Actually,
not that I agree with a lot of what Nick Fuentes says. I'm just
saying in general, you can't agree to that proposition. Oh, I'm
going to agree with you unless like you're basically going to
call me a monster unless I agree with you. Yeah, [__]
>> slavery and about the Holocaust. They can have decency
and compassion. >> Uh the they're doing that with the Holocaust.
I would say that the Holocaust is used as an underlying pretext
for why Israel needs to exist and have and and why it ex uh sorry,
why it forgives a ton of their military action, right? They'll
say Israel needs to exist. And if you interrogate Israel needs
to exist, it goes down to the Holocaust almost immediately, almost
exclusively, right?
But they'll they'll defend their military action with Israel's
right to exist. Israel needs to exist and it always goes down
to the Holocaust. So yes, it I would say I wouldn't say Jewish
people do it. I would say the Israeli government has done it
for quite a while. Now I I can say that unironically. I understand
the strategy. worked very well >> and humanity about some
of the worst things that have happened in the last 150 years
or more. They can do they can do that and they can also have
concerned views about issues like immigration and other issues.
The two things are not mutually incompatible. You can have different
views about different things. It's your lack of humanity and
compassion for people about things like the Holocaust, about
slavery. It's that that people find so contemptable. And I don't
understand why you need to do that. Is it again I just ask you
is it is your motivation financial? Is your motivation for fun?
What is the motivation for saying these outlandish things which
you don't need to say and which I suspect I don't know. I suspect
a lot of it is perform. >> He did say Piers Piers's kids
sound like girls. Yes, he did say that. >> So So what is
the motivation?
>> I'm an iconoclass. The Holocaust is not my religion
and it is treated like a religion. And it is treated like a religion
with dogma with blasphemy laws. And that secular religion says
and and you say you say that's a croc of it's intentional. It's
called the open society by Carl Paer. It's by these architects
of the liberal order after World War II. They got together and
they said how can we make sure that never happens? How can we
make sure that totalitarianism never happens again? And they
came up with a consensus which is that we need to take down nations,
religions, fathers, the authoritarian personality. We need to
be empathetic and altruistic. We need to be diverse and pluralistic.
And that experiment isn't working. And I'll tell you the truth
right now. And you can laugh at this. You can scoff at this.
Our people are being genocided in our country. 50% of the live
births in the United Kingdom and in the United States are non-white.
In a hundred years, my ancestors, your ancestors, your kids who
are so empathetic and compassionate, they're going to be a minority.
They're going to be a minority in maybe a Muslim country, an
Indian country, an Hispanic country. And these people that are
100 years old talking about my grandparents and the Holocaust,
they don't care about that. Actually, they like to see it. At
the SPLC, they're literally counting down the days until whites
are a minority in America. So, forgive me if I don't believe
them when they talk about compassion. There's a genocide going
on right now. It's not against the Jews. >> How many Christians
are there? >> Gaza. It's against >> How many Christians
are there in the
>> Like many >> 1 point some billion billion. >> How
many How many Jews are there? >> 15 million. >> Okay.
So, with a straight face, you're going to tell me the world is
being overrun
by the by 15 million people when there are over a billion Christians.
There is a genocide of Christians like poor old Nick Fuentes
going on at the hands of these 15 million. Really
>> see this? >> He literally didn't listen. >> Attitude
is why you're losing when you say
white people. Who am I to white >> Who am I losing to?
>> You're seeing it. Mass migration. Ma Oh, you're losing
to me. We are losing as a
of mass mig
Who am I losing to? You're well, you're losing to me. But anyway,
that's that's not that's Germaine. Okay, let's continue with
the conversation. >> And here's the difference. In Israel,
they have my politics. In Israel, >> uh, excuse me, bigot,
stop. Stop saying your life's bad. Excuse me, bigot. Stop saying
your life's bad. Like, literally the worst approach you could
do. I don't think this is one of those things where Piers probably
doesn't know who his audience is. That like he does the signaling
to like Tucker adjacent people. He does that signaling all the
time. and he thinks there's this big group of totally liberal
people in the middle. Classical liberals who are on his side.
Listen, 99 out of a hundred classical liberals are going to agree
with Nick Fuentes. Okay? They're going to go in that direction
when they have to make the choice. I'm just telling you when
somebody's like, "I'm a classical liberal. I just look at the
facts. I'm they're going to go with Nick Fuentes." Okay? Most
of the time, the reason they say that is because they feel some
discomfort with what Piers is saying and they're going to go
over and join Nick. Okay? We saw it with Sargon. There's like
Sargon and his whole crew of people all did the same thing. That's
the direction they'll go in.
I'm not saying they actually understand classical liberalism
or that's correct. I'm telling you that most of the people who
say they're classical liberals when it comes down to it, they
will eventually make that decision. They will.
I understand everybody's like, "No, I'm a I'm a classical liberal
and I would never do that." Maybe,
but eventually stuff starts happening and you you lose it. I
I've seen it happen so many times I can't say or I can't even
describe how many times I've seen it happen. They want to maintain
a majority. If they had it their way, it would only be people.
They're fighting like hell so that people can have as much territory
a state. They can be proudly in their own land. Whereas in America,
we are being besieged by 10 million illegal immigrants in four
years. And then whites and Christians are going to be the minority.
And that's true in Canada, Australia, all the countries in Europe.
So you could say there's two billion people, but what's the proportionality?
What is the percentage of people being born that are white? Where's
the arrow pointing? Where are we going to be in 50 years? In
50 years, there might be in Israel in 50 years. There isn't going
to be
you don't you don't believe people should get married, right?
>> I think people should get married. I'm a >> You're
basically anti-marriage. Really? You've you've talked about this.
You're talking about >> Are we done talking about why genocide?
I'm coming to I'm coming to the same part because you seem very
resistant to the idea of marriage. You've never got married.
Uh you've talked very scathingly about henpecked husbands. Just
take a look. >> That's true. >> Guys get to a certain
age and they're like, "You know what? Women suck. Like they're
talking too much. They're not hot anymore. Like you're fat. You're
chubby. You're not as hot as you think you are. You talk too
much. your >> So, we'll obviously get to the brazen misogyny
part of that a little later, but but I'm just curious.
On the one hand, there's this terrible genocide going on of white
people. On the other hand, you want people effectively to stop
going near women cuz they all turn >> Wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Not as hot as you think you are.
You [__] talk too much. You're a [__]
He's just being uh >> so we'll obviously get to the brazen
misogyny part of that a little later, but but I'm just curious.
On the one hand, there's this terrible genocide going on of white
people. On the other hand, you want people effectively to stop
going near women because they all turn out to be so ghastly,
so they shouldn't presumably procreate. So, how does that work?
I mean, aren't you with your rhetoric actively encouraging men
not to associate with these ghastly women, therefore not have
any more children, therefore you are contributing Nick Fuentes
to the diminishing white population. I I'm confused. I tell my
followers to get married all the time. I tell them that it's
best for everybody to get married. And I think that's the only
way that you can have sex. I think that's the only licit way
as a Catholic is sex is within marriage. >> Why don't you
get married?
>> Uh I'll get married later. It's been difficult for me
because people are shooting at me at my house. I don't know that
I I don't want to have kids and a wife. You know, my wife would
be screaming about that. Me, you know, I have to be able to take
risks and be able to say these things. It's difficult to bring
a family into a life that's like that. But for my followers,
I tell them to get married. But what's happening with women?
>> You literally just told your followers. Hang on. In
that clip, you literally told followers, women, they get old.
>> Sorry, this is the face, dude. The faces every time.
He's like, >> they get old, they get fat, they get ugly,
they get very annoying. So, where's the incentive to get married
to women? There isn't one. You're >> No, Nick. Every time
Nick's doing well, he just starts eating a lot of food and he
needs to stop doing that. Okay,
I'm telling you, every time he starts doing good, he'll just
start eating a lot and he'll get fat and he said, "No, not to
get fat." Okay, don't get fat. >> You're act you're actively
telling them >> you're extrapolating. You're extrapolating
a lot.
>> Just quoting you back yourself again. >> No, no,
but you're extrapolating and saying, "Well, you say women are
annoying, so therefore what's the incentive?" We have to do it
in spite of the fact that they are annoying. We have to do it
in spite of the fact that they talk too much. We can get them
to lose weight. We can put them on peptides. We can get them
to the promised land. Uh but it it's going to be >> Do
you think this view of women may be why none of them want to
go near you? >> Oh, you should see my DMs. It is quite
the opposite. They're called the groy bets and I'm I'm actually
batting them away. Granted, not all of them are
>> Why is JTO ru rooting for Fentes? Cuz I think this is
a totally lazy attempt that's just going to bolster Fentes further.
So you see that as rooting for Fentes, not what's happening.
But you also might just say, "Just kidding. I just said something
because I was pretending to be
which is always fun. Very cool. >> Some of them are attractive.
>> Are you actually just to clear up just to clear up one
of the many theories about you? I have no idea what the answer
is and you haven't got to answer but are you actually attracted
to women?
>> This isn't true. I was introduced by Fuentes as a streamer
by Destiny. I only started watching him after Destiny started
talking to him.
Um but I don't know. People say this. >> I am attracted
to women. >> An old guy. What? He put it on the >> Oh,
nobody expected that one. >> Nobody was expecting that
one. >> $3. I just thought of something. Groers.
>> Croy peers. Okay. Okay.
>> But I will say that women are very difficult to be around.
>> So, there's that. >> And do you think they should
have the right to vote? >> I do not. No. Absolutely not.
>> They should stay at home. >> Well, yeah. Absolutely.
So basically, you're just a misogynist old dinosaur, aren't you?
>> For a for a young guy. I mean, I know I'm the boomer.
I know I'm the boomer here, but actually, you're a 27y old dinosaur,
aren't you? Aren't you, Nick Fuentes? All women all women are
>> Piers. Piers really thought he was cooking with this
one. Piers really thought he had it. He thought he was cook.
He thought he was like, "Okay, I got to go off script. I'm going
to get this guy right now." You're like an old conservative dinosaur,
aren't you? You're like a boom. You're like an old soul. You
like really have some died in the wool opinions here, don't you?
>> Annoying. All women grow old. They all get fat. Says
the guy. Have you ever had >> No, absolutely not. >> Wow.
Says the guy who never got laid. >> That's the thing though.
You
>> Dude, imagine somebody has like a whole brand and you
like lean totally into the brand. So you're like all of the things
you monetize being then. So like all of the things you make money
for, all of the things you say openly on your stream and people
pay you money to say, you're like all of those things, aren't
you? Yes. Yep. Yep. Yeah. I'm all those >> Boomers. It's
always an expert in women. You've never got laid. >> Yeah.
We're We are going back to the stone age. You're absolutely right.
>> you know, you're talking about empathy and your kids
are empathetic and they would never laugh at a joke about the
Holocaust and you're a misogynist. You're a simp yourself. You're
totally henpecked. That's the problem. >> So, we are going
to play another another clip of yours about women. >> A
lot of women
This is the one that will get him, guys. This is the one. This
over. It's over. We got another clip. We have We have another
clip. All right. We have another clip right now. Nick looks really
bad here. Again. What do you mean looks really bad
again? He again 20 to 30,000 concurrent live viewers when he
streams,
Where is he going? Do you think he's trying to via his stream
reach out to women
to normal people? He looks bad. Do you think Fuentes streams
to normal people? Do you think he is trying to reach public office?
Do you think he's trying to become an elected official? What
do you think the goal is? To normal, healthy people. Those don't
exist anymore. Sorry, I'm I'm responding to Gigachs here. And
I don't even think the chat's on screen, so you guys probably
can't see it if you're watching the VOD. Uh-oh, not that one.
I need my chat to move back on. Uh I wasn't highlighting the
chats. So chat said, "Oh, he's not going to look good to normal
people." And you think a lot of normal people watch Piers Morgan?
You understand? Nobody normal is watching Piers Morgan. Everybody
watches Piers Morgan is there for drama and they're well aware
and well versed in online political drama and online drama in
general. That's how you find Piers Morgan, right?
This is this is not looking bad to his whole audience, which
is massive. Now, I'm telling you, he could say he could look
bad to he could look Yeah. It's just one of those things. He's
like signaling to what he will know, what he knows is his base
of support, and he's just going to keep signaling to that. And
you're like, well, to women, he really looks bad to women. Yeah,
most women, like 95% of women, he looks awful to, but scale-wise,
it's not a problem.
Yeah, it's it's unfortunately he's incredibly funny. That's the
problem. I've said this before. When we when he was still deplatformed,
he's like an SCP.
He needed to stay contained. When he broke containment, it was
disastrous for all politics, okay? All political discussion online.
He's too funny. He's He's a unique He's an anomaly. He's too
funny. Don't let him out. But then they let him out and it's
been disastrous. >> Another another clip of yours about
>> A lot of women want to be raped. And And when I say
rap, I mean like
that sounds bad when I say it like that, but there's like a lot
of women that really want a guy to beat the out of them, but
also they have to pretend, but part of it is they have to pretend
like they don't.
You think women want to be? >> That's what the studies
show, Piers. That is what these statistics believe. It's like
so easy. He's getting into the red pill stuff. The red pill stuff
is so brainless anybody can argue it. Uh actually, there's a
study that shows women fantasize about peers. That's what I was
saying. Huh? Yeah. Try to hold me accountable. No, you can't
hold me accountable for that. No, no, the study says the study
says this what it says. The study says what it says. They have
fantasies. They have fantasies about it. I don't think that they
want to actually get rid, but there's a study out there. Get
ready for this. It says 62% of women have real fantasies. And
if you read anything that they're reading, if you watch what
they're watching, what do you think Fifty Shades of Gray is about?
What do you think Twilight is about? I mean, that's just true.
>> You think women want to have the beaten out them, as
you said? >> Yeah. And it's very disturbing, but it's true.
Do you think your views on women might change if you actually
ever had a relationship with one or had and actually had a proper
relationship? I mean, people say the reason you're so angry about
women is you're basically an >> Well, I'm not angry about
it. >> You sound very angry. You sound very, very angry
about women. >> This is the laziest projection, by the
way. Oh, you sound really angry about women. Yeah, Pierce. Well,
you sounded really angry about like Okay. Does that mean you're
a you secretly want to gas some? Is that where we're going? We're
just Oh, this thing makes you upset. Therefore, you are like
you want to be this super hateful thing? I don't think so. Shut
up, Piers.
>> Shut up. >> Thank you. >> I'm passionate
that it's an issue. >> Twilight is about vampires. No,
Twilight is about being groomed as a young woman. Okay. Twilight
is about being groomed as a young woman by somebody with like
money and influence and that you have everything taken care of.
Um, no. Twilight is about being groomed by like somebody who
is like an older man. That's what it's about. An older man who
looks like a like a rich like teenage heartthrob. Yep. Yep. >> You're
not passionate. You're actually you're sounding very bitter about
women. As if as if women have done a terrible disservice to you,
but when you don't have relationships, you don't have when are
they doing these terrible things to you that's made you so hateful
towards women? I'm really curious. >> Was that I don't
think that was a hateful clip. I think I was laughing. I said
they want men to beat the [__] out of them. And I
and that's just true. I mean, when you look at the state of modern
women, all they do is lay in their bed, doom scroll. They're
chilling out. Um they're getting a little look, they're getting
a little fat. It is what it is. I don't know what the average
weight is, but they're getting a little heavy. And any guy that
All right, Nick, I think we shouldn't throw the first stone on
this one. Okay, I'm going to roll it back like 30 seconds. I
have to go grab I ordered some food, and then I'm going to grab
my food, use the bathroom, and then I'll be right back. So I
I rolled it back a little bit so I can have some time to come
back. Okay, be right back. >> I'm still listening though.
>> I'm passionate that it's an issue. >> You're not
passionate. You're actually you're sounding very bitter about
women. As if as if women have done a terrible disservice to you.
But when you don't have relationships, you don't have when are
they doing these terrible things to you that's made you so hateful
towards women? I'm really curious. Was that I don't think that
was a hateful clip. I think I was laughing. I said they want
men to beat the [__] out of them. And I and that's
just true. I mean, when you look at the state of modern women,
all they do is lay in their bed, doom scroll, they're chilling
out. Um, they're getting a little, look, they're getting a little
fat. It is what it is. I don't know what the average weight is,
but they're getting a little heavy. And any guy that is playing
the field these days will tell you that. I mean, and I and I
know a lot of the Chads, I am an incel. I'm friends with a lot
of Chads like Bradley Martin, Clavicular, they agree with me.
You know, there's sort of like this alliance between the guys
that don't have and the guys that get the most. We know what
women are about. It's the guys in the middle. Guys like you in
the middle. It's the beta male orbiters that say, "She's amazing.
You're a misogynistic pig." Because I don't know what that is.
I guess >> Let me explain to you. Let me explain to you
what >> Oh, clvicular shout out. What up?
That was pretty crazy, dude. What? Somebody I was watching. Oh,
Verra. Bane was the person who was like, "Um, oh, this looks
so bad for him when he shouts out clvicular."
I It's just a joke.
I I don't understand how that looks bad at all. What part of
that looks bad to anybody who is online? By the way, Nick Fuentes
is not trying to win elected office. So, he's just trying to
appeal to people online.
People misunderstand this so much. It's pretty crazy. But let's
continue. >> But I think it is. I think when a 27y old
guy who's never got laid, never had a meaningful relationship
with a woman, says that women shouldn't be allowed to vote, they
should stay at home, uh that all they do is fantasize about being
and being beaten up, that's what they want, that they're annoying,
that they get fat, that they get ugly,
that's a misogynist. Now, you may not understand it because your
knowledge of women is so incredibly tiny, but actually you are
the embodiment of a misogynist. It Wait, do you think Hold on.
Did Did Nick say he's not a misogynist or
Huh? Wait, I don't I literally don't understand. Did Nick say
he's not? Did Nick go, "No, I'm not a misogynist." Couldn't be
clearer. And if I was if I was a you know in a way you have the
deeprooted misogyny of some of the actual boomers I know. Yeah.
Here you are 27 years old and most of the current studies show
that a lot of men are really disenfranchised from society. No
longer have physical relationships with women if they've ever
had them. Never associate with women and build up instinctively
misogynist views about women. And I I fear you're in that >> Damn.
You're just a bit of a lonely guy who wants to get laid and can't
for whatever reason
>> and it's made you bitter about women and I I don't >> Dude,
this guy's making so much money. This this hypothesis doesn't
really make sense to me, but Alicia doesn't know >> where
that's where that's come from. But it's fascinating.
>> No, see, here's the thing. First of all, you're very
caught up in the labels. It's always
>> you're a racist, you're a misogynist, you're the words
mean nothing to me.
Can I respond? Give yourself the label. What is this? >> You
said I am a racist. I didn't give. >> To be fair, you can
make this argument for all of the labels in this conversation.
Nick has called himself like the biggest misogynist in America.
He's definitely called himself the biggest anti-semite in America.
America's premier anti-semite.
Definitely called himself like the biggest racist. He's the most
popular racist online. Like he said all of these things about
himself. >> Give you the label. You said influentes, I
am a racist. >> Calm down. Calm down. Did you or didn't
>> It's okay. >> Did you? >> Yeah. Yeah. But
but >> I didn't give you the label. You did. >> Why
are you yelling at me? >> Because you're trying to scream
something that didn't happen. You said I gave you the label of
being a racist. No, you did. You said I'm a racist. You gave
yourself a label.
>> Going to have to
tone it down a little. All right. You're going to have to bring
it down a notch and relax. This is just an interview. Okay. Please
calm down. All I said is you're hung up. >> I didn't say
you gave me that. I maybe I did. But here's what I mean. What
I mean is, okay, what I mean is you're just hung up on say I
think what he said was you're really into these labels. I don't
think he said that Piers gave him the label. Or he might have
also said that, but he's like, you're really hung up on these
labels. >> Proving you're okay, you're a misogynist. Okay,
you're a racist. Okay, you denied the Holocaust. And and I'm
just I'm not about the labels
that as I said to you. But Nick, as I said to you, I just
>> Phantom Phantom accusations of Holocaust denial. Nick's
so used to it that he's just like, "You said, "I denied the Holoca
Oh, wait, no, I did." Oh, right. I didn't deny the Holocaust.
Okay. Okay. >> Wanted to go over the stuff that you know
everyone uses out there about you and get you to respond. And
we're getting we are getting I think a long way in this interview.
>> You didn't deny the Holocaust. You accepted there's
been a Holocaust of at least 6 million Jews. I'm a maximalist.
That is significant. You did admit you did admit you're a racist
and you have spelled out a thought process about women, which
is the purest definition of misogyny that I've ever seen. And
you said you're not gay. So the we're getting somewhere.
>> Yeah. Well, look, and I own the labels, okay? But I
just don't care that much about them. I feel like the whole is
like a weird >> I'm not saying you have to care, Nick.
You don't have to care about any of it. I promise you. Right.
That's not why I got you on the on the show. I wanted to give
you a fair crack, which I think I have. We've gone over a lot
of stuff. We got we got a bit more to go on. I I genuinely don't
think I've ambushed you with anything you couldn't have been
expecting. No, >> I don't think I've been overtly hostile.
In fact, when you've asked me to calm down, I've calmed down.
I don't want to have a hostile, angry, shouty match with you.
I simply want you to spell out exactly what you've made about
all these things and people can then be the judge of them. So,
let's take another break and we'll come back and talk about Donald
Trump, Tucker Carlson, Candace Owens, and others. >> On
the other side of the break, >> the first term, >> hold
on, we got to wait for the clip.
>> Was inaugurated for his first term in office. You supported
him at that time, but you've grown increas.
>> Did you freak out over the one and 20 number? Cuz I
got the stats if you need. Are you talking about the Keith Woods
tweet? I didn't freak out about it. I just said that seems really
high. I just I think probably what you do is you make it about
gang violence. And I think probably every ethnic group like Piers
could have made Nick look so much worse. He's just a lazy. I
think probably every ethnic group basically gets in that same
fight in my opinion or in that same position. If you have that
that level of concentration of poverty in an urban area, I think
everybody gets
most liberals are freaking out over the one and 20 number. I
just think Nick's like broadly
probably just broadly wrong on the
on most of his like thoughts on black people and they're mostly
informed by living in Chicago where there's like rampant gang
violence.
Yeah. And but he's compelling so he's able to convince bunch
of other people too. I don't know. That's my opinion. Be interested
to see the source. I think I have the Keith Woods tweet here
somewhere if that's what Koser is talking about. >> Recently
disillusioned. I think it'd be fair to say. Let's let's play
a recent clip from you about Trump. We played this game in the
first term. We're 10 years in.
And you still have these people, I I hate to say it, but they're
just like in denial. And they're like, "Okay, everybody, let's
all go on Twitter and let's tell Trump, don't screw over your
voters.
Okay,
hey, Trump, don't hire John Radcliffe in the CIA." Like, what
are we doing? It's We lost. It's over. The time to make demands
was during the election when he needed the votes. He's a lame
duck president and he doesn't need anything from us. He's not
EVEN ON TWITTER. HE'S ON TRUTH SOCIAL. SO WHAT ARE YOU talking
about? We're going to all rally and tell him don't hire yet another
Okay. You know, you know Trump checks his Twitter all of his
mention. You know he checks that religiously. Come on. Neo god.
>> Come on man. >> Now over the weekend you posted
this on X. Uh he said performative cruelty is the perfect phrase
to characterize the Trump admin and the mood of the MAGA movement.
In order to compensate for his compromises and failures, Trump
has to fall back on mean-spiritedness
to appeal to the basist basist instincts of his followers. It's
really sad. I mean, do you think you're the best person, Nick
Fuentes, to lecture people about performative cruelty? >> Why
are you accusing me of being cruel? Is that what that is? >> Yeah,
this is actually a good point. And I wonder if he'll update Asminold's
programming on this. Okay.
Because hold on him and Asenold totally they like completely
differentiate on this. Asenold loves the cruelty. He like laughs
at the cruelty. He thinks the cruelty is superb based. Nick has
the intelligent opinion which is like hey you're not doing as
many deportations as I I want. You're trying to make up for that
by like shooting compilation videos of you just being.
It's like I would rather you gave people some time to go get
their belongings. I would rather you like gave them a notice
and then came up and showed up later and grabbed them. Right.
And like took them in. I'd rather you give them a chance and
said, "Here, hey, you're getting processed, but I would rather
it be like comprehensive immigration like like deportation, right?
Not immigration, comprehensive deportation." But instead, you
make up for it by like showing video clips of you guys just being
like psychotic.
The [__] are you? Why? What are you doing? Like,
that's not what I wanted. I didn't want like the crulest 1% deportation.
I want the most effective 50% deportation, I think, is what Nick's
kind of aiming at here. Like don't don't play Pokemon music while
you deport criminals like and and beat the [__] out
of them, knock them to the ground, handcuff them. How about you
just deport a lot more people and then you don't need to do video
clips? How about that?
What? How am I cruel? >> You're c you're cruel about black
people. You're cruel about
uh women. I mean, you're cruel about a lot of people. And you're
very performative. >> Okay. I don't think I'm performative.
I If anything, everyone else is performative. I'm authentic,
you know, whatever you want to say. >> Jtock question mark.
I'm just I'm telling him like what I think Nick Fuentes is saying.
Oh, have you ever seen this? I'm sorry. I like I can look at
it after
it's real. It's from the gut. But yes, I do think it's performative.
And what I mean by that
>> you know, when they're doing the deportations,
they know the deportations are not where the base wants them
to be. They deported. The figures are disputed, but from my data,
it's 300,000 in the year, which is not a massive deportation.
They know the base is unhappy with that. So, what do they do?
The deportations that they are carrying out, they do a big spectacle
and they >> How did Beer struggle to list his cruelties?
Um, his earpiece malfunction for a short minute. >> They
arrest everybody and they film it and they put a hype at it and
there's a meanness in there. They played that
>> I think, from Sabrina Carpenter or something, and they
make it a joke. They make a glib. And they do that because they're
not delivering on the promise. So, they compensate by doing it
meaner, edgier, more uh more mean-spirited, so that the base
will overlook the fact that it's not happening. And I think that's
by definition performative cruelty. You can call me a hypocrite,
but it's definitely true about what they're doing in the administration.
You >> Well, this might be true. True. turn up. There is
like a big chunk of people that you could probably deport in
a way that wouldn't be totally cruel in the same way. I think
>> went to see Trump at Maraago with Yay uh for dinner.
What was that like? >> It was very interesting. Uh they're
my two heroes. Yay is my hero. Trump is my hero. Even though
I he's very disappointing, I still a personal hero of mine. Uh
and he's a remarkable person. It was a great conversation. We
got along pretty well. He liked me, I liked him. It was a love
fest. I mean, he got attacked afterwards for sapping with the
white supremacist devil. I mean, do you accept you are a white
>> No. No. Absolutely not.
>> You don't think white people are superior to black people?
>> No. I'm I'm a Wrong way to ask the question.
Wrong way to ask the question. And like it's all it's all on
the table, too. like you all you have to do is is look a little
bit at this guy and see how he like answers this question cuz
he'll say, "Oh, no. I don't think they're superior. I just think
white people are like smarter and better at like math and fields
of science and like most things, but like athletics and music,
black people are pretty good. Black people are like maybe even
better." It's like, okay, so like basically exactly what a white
supremacist would think, but you've intellectualized it so you
can get out of it. Sure. I'm a Christian, so I believe everybody
is equal before God,
>> including women.
>> So you you give women equal rights,
>> dude. I saw the I saw the clip of this. This is so rough.
This is like actually so bad this part. Holy [__]
>> Including women.
>> So you you give women equal rights.
>> Great. Great. Okay. So you just talk to
>> No. What is Why are you like mad about this? No. You
know, the like infamously not misogynistic Catholic church. The
infamously non-misogynistic
equal rights to everybody Catholic church that Piers has hallucinated
from somewhere that I have no idea what he's talking about. Uh,
wait. You think all people are equal under God? That means women
should be able to vote, right? What? When has that been a part
of Catholic doctrine? Ever?
>> You want women to be treated equally before God, but
you don't want to give them equal rights.
>> Yeah. Because women and men are different. Do you believe
what is the implication that we're God? What what do you think?
What are you saying, peers? >> Oh, but you don't want to
give them equal rights.
>> Yeah, because women and men are different. Do you believe
there are two genders? It's your view. >> Do you think
there's two genders? >> I do think there are two genders.
Yes. >> Okay. And and so you mean there's distinction?
There are two distinct genders. I think we should all have the
same rights
to >> well if they're meaningfully distinct, biologically
distinct, and they have different social and biological roles,
I think it would follow that we would treat them a little bit
differently in the law. >> Do you think the Catholic Church's
teachings reflect that?
>> I do. Yeah. There's no female priests. Have you ever
seen that? >> Do you think that the Catholic Church thinks
all women should be deprived of vote? Dude, he Piers knows. Piers
is totally 100% aware that he just got caught with his pants
down. You think it's the Catholic the Catholic Church's teaching
that men and women aren't equal? Uh, yeah. Um, yeah, 100%. That's
exactly what the teaching is. Yes. Thank you, Piers, for making
my point for me. Um, do you think the Catholic Church supports
just like women and taking all their rights away? That's not
what I said. That's not what anybody said. Who are you talking
to?
Uh, yeah, I think so. >> No, they don't.
>> I think they do. Yeah. >> You think the Catholic
Church >> Hold on. Piers is lost. But Nick, what Nick is
saying here makes no sense either. Well, part of it makes no
sense. His answer to do you, are you a white supremacist was
all people are equal under God. We're all We're all equal under
God. Okay. But for you, do you think if you see a white person,
a black person, do you think they're equal in general in terms
of what they can do, what they're capable of? is do you believe
that? And he would have and Nick would have to answer no. But
he says under God and Piers loses the plot entirely. So I don't
know what you're saying. He makes no sense on the entire Catholic
Church point. He makes perfect sense on. >> Thinks all
women should be deprived of the vote. >> Uh yeah, I think
so. >> No, they don't.
>> I think they do. Yeah. >> You think the Catholic
Church position is women shouldn't be allowed to vote? >> I
think so. Yeah. But I'm not positive. But it should be. >> It
should be. So if you were pope, that's what you do. You could
be pope cuz you're celibate. >> That's true. M >> and
I'm also from Chicago like the pope. But look, I mean women,
it it says in the Bible that women have no authority over men
and they can't teach men and that's why there's no female priests.
>> There's a lot of things in the Bible. I mean, do you
think every word of the Bible is sacrian? >> I mean, that's
literally his answer. All people are equal under God. That was
his answer.
What is Pier What is Pierce >> Um well, yeah, it's inspired
scripture.
>> That's all
>> a theological debate. Well, it it is Catholic doctrine
that women should not lead and teach. I mean, you're not interacting
with what I'm saying. Why can't women be priests? Um, I think
the response here, I think you just misunderstood, Felp. I think
the response was, "Women and men should have all the same rights."
And Nick was like, "Well, they're different, so why would they
have the exact same rights?" Which I think is probably a stupid
answer, but I don't think it's like wrong. It's like a thing
that you could interrogate, but he didn't do that.
So
>> here's a theological debate. >> Well, it it is
Catholic doctrine that women should not lead and teach. I mean,
you're not interacting with what I'm saying. Why can't women
be priests? >> They should be.
>> Okay. Well, you're not Catholic. That's not a Catholic.
>> I'm a Catholic. I just many things that disagree with
the Catholic Church. >> Okay. Well, that kind of contrary
because the whole the whole basis of being Catholic is accepting.
It's accepting the authority of the >> context. You can
be a member of a religion and disagree with parts of that religion.
Perfectly perfectly
>> You can be well yeah I mean I you could see you're an
extremist true >> extremist. You can't obviously you never
>> That's just not rigorous. >> You never deviate
if you're an extremist. But even the constitution even the constitution's
been amended what was it 27 times. People talk about this sacrian
document. It's like it's been amended 27. >> My goodness.
>> Oh my. This is not rigorous intellect. Constitution's
been amended. You mean like the document whose founding principles
were the document should be updated?
Did did they write that in the Bible? Like hey, the Bible should
be like open to interpretation and should always change over
time with the society. No, they wrote that in the constitution
because it's a totally different document with totally different
like purposes, thoughts like it's a completely different thing.
The [__] is it? Uh actually the Bible should change
but um only you know just like the constitution what >> documents
been amended in 2017.
>> Oh my this is not rigorous intellectually. This is very
educated
>> theology. Okay but it's fine. Where were we? We were
talking about Trumping
for women's rights >> on Trump. Well I think women should
have the same rights as you and I. You don't. That's fine. >> Put
on the pink hat, bro. Put on the the pink hat. We're waiting.
What's the pink hat for >> the uh for the march? For the
women's march. Are we going to see you at the women's march protesting
for women's rights and all that? >> I think women should
have equal rights to men. Period. >> You carry tampons
in case your female friends get a period or something like it's
crazy.
>> I'd have no problem giving a female friend a tampon.
Would you? Have you ever I don't suppose you've ever seen a tampon,
have you? >> Gross. Absolutely not.
>> You think tampons are gross? >> Yeah. That's basically
like the perfect tight example of when I say he just wanted to
disagree with Fentos ON EVERYTHING. OH, YOU think you think tampons
are gross? You think the thing filled with period blood is gross?
Excuse me. That's what women have to deal with. It's like um
Yeah. I like that's gross. Yeah. The idea of like you bleed for
a month, that's gross. That's like
I They both look like children here. Okay. Yeah, sure. They both
look about equally bad here. They both look about equally bad.
Definitely when Piers goes, "Oh, you think tampons are gross?
Why would you think that? It's not filled with period blood initially
though." Yeah, but when he said gross, have you ever seen a tampon?
Gross. It's obvious what Fentes is thinking of, right? No. Where's
the commentary on unused tampons? Is that implied somewhere that
I missed? Here's asked if you ever seen a tampon. I don't know.
>> Uh, yeah. I think you look [__] insane asking
that question.
I I think you look insane asking that question. I think I think
Fentes tried to talk and then Pierce said something totally back
and you look you look totally stupid. Well, you think tampons
are gross? Yeah, the idea of bleeding into something for a month
is gross. I'm sorry. Sorry. For a week is gross. Gross. It's
gross. Okay. Doesn't mean it's like evil. It's just gross.
J lost here. Okay. Well, hold on. Let me let me pull in chat.
Hold on. SLP poll.
Are tampons
gross?
Yes. No. Okay, we'll run this poll in chat. I don't know what
the results are going to be, but we'll see. Are tampons gross?
Yes or no? Are tampons gross? Okay. Okay. Well, it seems like
seems like yes, tampons are gross is pulling ahead. So, unfortunate.
Unfortunate. Unfortunate. >> Yeah, they're filled with
period blood. Yeah, it's kind of gross. >> Wow. Oh, wait.
Hold on. Nick actually specifies
they're filled with period blood. It's kind of gross. Oh, there
you go. Boom. Are you into that? You like that? You a lot of
damp. >> I don't think you've ever seen it, have >> Oh,
actually, everybody here is totally anyway because Nick says
it and Pierce keeps going.
So,
here's literally
Piers. Have you ever seen that? No. Gross. Gross.
I've seen him. I've seen him before. >> You've been that
close to a woman?
>> No. I' I've seen him. Uh, look, I I used to live with
women, so I've seen them around the house. >> I bet you've
seen videos, haven't you?
>> What? What are we doing here, Piers? I'm not sure. You
really >> This is freaky ass ninja. Okay. What the
he a fan? What is he talking? Where is he finding these videos?
hate that I'm sure you're more impressed that I'm a misogynist
than you are about anything. It's really I'm more I'm actually
more exercised about your blatant self-admitted racism. >> Sorry.
The thing that makes tampons gross is you think of what they're
used for. Okay.
Like if I showed you
I I could explain it, but you guys are going to get mad. So >> then
I'm about anything. But the misogyny runs a close second. Let
me ask you about Tucker Carlson cuz you had a long sit down with
Tucker Carlson in which he was oddly I like Tucker. We got >> so
unlucky for evil Johnny Bravo that he takes so long to write
his paragraphs out that he actually waited until after Nick specified
and Piers still doubled down on that. So unlucky buddy. >> I
was with him last week in London. But he gave me a harder time
than he gives you. Uh and afterwards he was more critical. And
then you said this about >> He's a handler. He handles
people. That's what he does. He's He's a liar and a handler.
He goes around telling people, "I don't know anything. I don't
know. Oh, I know nothing. I don't even have a phone. I am just
a clueless tourist. I just travel to all these countries and,
you know, overthrow >> I don't trust them. And I don't
and I don't care. You know, maybe that alienates me from people
in the conservative movement. I don't care. I'm not going to
be a part of it. I'm not going to be a party to whatever that
is. Whatever that CIA
is, I'm not going to be a part of it. So,
you know,
now that I've I've heard enough from Tucker and I've heard enough
from other people and I've seen enough. This guy's not who he
says he is. Not an ally. Stay the away from me. You're you're
weird, dude. You're weird.
>> See, what would have been great is if you'd said that
to him when you were sitting opposite him. Well, when I was sitting
opposite him at the dinner and in the interview, he was nothing
but >> He was very nice to me and very cordial and he didn't
call me an anti-semite.
>> I mean, Nick said that stuff about him before the interview
and then Tucker sat down for the interview. I was like, I DIDN'T
EVEN KNOW MY DAD WAS A CIA AGENT.
>> And he didn't even press me on it. >> Like, what
the [__] are you supposed to do? Guy himself. You
didn't even have to >> at all. And I thought he would and
I almost wanted him to. He was nothing but nice and we had a
great time. We had a really great dinner, really great interview.
And I felt really good about it. And the next week on my show,
I said he really surprised me. He's great. And then
every interview he's done since, all he does is call me an anti-semite.
He goes, "Well, I I hate his anti-semitism, and you know, I I
wonder why people like him." And so, I just think that's two-faced.
So, after that experience, it kind of turned me off. I didn't
like that. But, he's going to do what he's going to do. He's
still a nice guy, but I think he's two-faced.
>> What about Candace Owens?
Uh, you had a sit down with her. She called you out on a few
of your more incendury comments. You've been attacking her quite
virulently recently. Um, what's going on >> Well, you know,
it's me and her. We're so complicated. We're on and off. Uh,
it's very passionate on both sides. Um, you know, there I think
there's this intense desire to be friends. Um, but a frustration.
We disagree with each other. There's a rivalry.
Um, but I thought we were going to have a friendly conversation
and then she kind of did the same thing. We're going to go on
a show during the war with Iran. We're literally in the middle
of a war and she text me the day before the United States bombed
Fordo and she said, "Would you like to come on my show?" >> Is
the underground nuclear site? Go for it, Fentes. Okay, bro. I'm
going to leave that there so it keeps popping up every time I
switch tabs. show. I said, "Absolutely." I said, "Is this going
to be about Iran?" She goes, "I don't do setups." I said, "Yeah,
let's do it." I come on the show and then she's like got this
weird hostile demeanor. She's doing the clip thing, then she
puts it behind a payw wall. It was ridiculous. So, that that
really uh was not nice. And then I think this whole Charlie >> Candace
did like an infinitely better job of this. By the way, like if
you're trying to character Fentes, she did an infinitely better
job than Piers did. I don't know why nobody brings up the Ali
Alexander thing. Nobody brings up any of that stuff. Nobody just
made a call to Milo. They're all stupid. >> Charlie Kirk
thing. I think she's gone insane. I think she's absolutely lost
her mind. Um so I feel sorry for her
>> What did you feel when Charlie Kirk was assassinated?
What where were you when you heard about it? >> I was at
my house and a friend of mine who was actually at the event texted
me and said, "Charlie got shot." I said, "Who?" He said, "Charlie
Kirk." I said, "Oh my gosh, that's terrible." And and honestly,
it was devastating. I didn't like Charlie Kirk at all and we
had an intense rivalry and he hated me. But honest to God, I
was devastated. I was emotionally affected by it. I think Nick's
like holding back on Charlie Kirk is probably the most the least
genuine thing he does to be honest with you.
Like after Nick had after Nick was like, "Oh, I you know, I'm
gonna he was a crazy guy and he worked really hard and I respected
him, but he wasn't nice to me or whatever, but I I still respected
him, so rest in peace." I feel like after all the texts came
out proving that Charlie Kirk had been like silently deplatforming
him behind the scenes for years and years and years, I feel like
Nick wanted to go on and just say, "I want to can I pay that
guy's bail? Can I buy that guy? Can I pay for that guy's lawyer?"
like this dude like actually ruining my life without ever acknowledging
me. I'm pretty confident.
He wanted a debate. He was never getting a debate. Charlie refused
to acknowledge him or talk about him ever and literally just
ran around behind the scenes trying to keep him off of every
platform that existed. Charlie was never going to debate him.
Charlie was a totally duplicitous rap loser, okay? Who pretended
he was all for open debate and did that behind the scenes. It's
not a tragedy. It's not a tragedy when one of the people actually
is totally duplicitous and undertakes that for themselves. It's
not a tragedy at all. Just remember when people tell you that
Charlie Kirk stood for free speech and debate, they're lying.
He was a liar. Everything he stood for was a lie. He is a lying
piece of he went to his grave a lying piece of [__]
on that point. Okay? Might have been a good man raising his family
well, but he was a total piece of when it came down to his most
obviously stated principle. Total duplicitous loser. Didn't believe
in what he said. actual grifter Charlie Kirk. >> I didn't
even do a show that night uh because I was beside myself. So,
it it was rough. I mean, it was hard to watch.
>> When you say you were beside yourself, I mean, you didn't
you hated him. >> Uh I didn't I don't hate anybody. I didn't
hate him, but we I really didn't like him. I intensely disliked
him. And >> He called you vermin, didn't he? >> He
did. Yeah, he hated me also. >> But you were still beside
yourself when you heard what happened to him. I was I was I thought
it was it was disgusting what was done to him. >> I don't
see how interviews like this wouldn't make Nick Fentes more popular
with Republicans. Oh, it absolutely will. Yeah, this is going
to be a huge win. Dude, we could look at the comments. Piers
pretending not to know what Pure Capital will Piers pretending
to not know per capita will never not be funny. I'm in the UK
and got arrested for watching this. Piers fact check plus team
plus chat GPT plus prepared talking points versus Nick's brain.
I'm a black woman. I took my wig off to watch this. I don't believe
that.
Uh, Piers not understanding per capita or Catholic doctrine was
hilarious. Piers pretends to be Catholic and two minutes later
attacks Nick for being a virgin. The lack of self-awareness is
incredible.
Piers acting like he didn't know how to how bad black crime is
was beyond dishonest. I'm a straight white man and I stopped
hating myself to watch this. Morgan left the studio and immediately
crossed the street to avoid a black person. I'm black and I've
changed the batteries of my smoke alarm just to watch this. Okay.
Is this funny? Is this funny? This isn't funny. Shut up. The
boomer mind just can't comprehend what is unfolding. That's broadly
where I'm coming from is like these boomers just literally don't
Like it's not this isn't cool. The virtue signal not cool. You
you are willing to call it the lefty virtue signaling, but you're
just virtue signaling too. >> And it was tragic and it
was horrifying. >> Do you fear an attack like that on yourself?
Have you up your own security because of this? Cuz you your profile's
got it exponentially higher since what happened to Charlie Kirk?
>> I have. I have increased my security.
Bagel and coffee says, "Sure, but that's just all gropers already."
Okay, I I understand. Okay, I understand that like a cultlike
following. They're everywhere. That's what it takes, man. You
need that one cult-like following that's going to do whatever
you ask no matter what, right? You post a tweet, they're going
to immediately retweet and like that. You Okay, that's what we
have to start reinforcing here. I post a tweet, you guys immediately
like and retweet it. you just like total like a total dedication
to the mission. Okay, we need a mission.
It's like thank you. You get it. No, I just I have like the mirror
image of the gropers, which is the DGG community. Um with me
and like I see the dedication. >> It's [__]
It's crazy. >> Donated $3. You pronounce Spagel like
>> I do. I do. And I always have and I remember when that
episode came out. I was playing World of Warcraft for like very
early in my life. Like I was very young and everybody made fun
of me for saying it that way cuz the community episode came out
at that exact time.
Yeah. So, your audience exists only people who broke the cult
programming. You will never get your own. Um maybe we'll see.
And uh but you know, something similar like that happened to
me. Someone came to my house with a gun about a year ago almost
exactly trying to kill me and he was shot and killed in my alleyway.
So, I I've had increased security for a while. It's it's a bad
time out there. And I I do believe it was a left-wing person
that killed him. I think it was a left-wing person that tried
to kill me. So, yeah, I take it very seriously.
>> Elon Musk uh said on his his explatform that you're
a Fed, that you're a paid up hire of the government. Is that
true?
>> I mean, I'm sorry. Elon Musk had the most authority
within the federal government of any non-elected official in
US history.
He is the definition of fed. Who in the [__] is he
kidding when he calls anyone else a fed? >> Under you've
never worked for the government in any capacity.
>> I've never talked to federal law enforcement and and
actually I've testified to that fact under oath when I was subpoenaed
by the Congress. People leave that part out, but I got subpoenaed
I think in January 2022, I >> Uh that's cool. Beam me up.
Wait, what were the stickers of? It was
um and I was deposed by the subcommittee, the House Select Subcommittee
on January 6th and they asked me, "Did you speak with any federal
law enforcement?" And under oath, I said, "No, I've never had
contact with them. I've never turned over devices." Uh so, no,
absolutely
>> There's been footage that's come out again this week.
This is you at the January the 6th riots. Let's take a >> Oh,
also, real quick, if this happened, Koser, Nick should literally
just sue him for defamation. Um because we know Elon constantly
defames people. He literally constantly does it. Nick has the
money. He just collect an easy payday.
Like Nick has the money to sue him for it. And Elon literally
will he has too much of an ego to ever back down. Yeah. I I you
could easily get it, right? Cuz Nick will say unless you can
pro provide some proof you have to take this down. And Elon won't.
Elon will get about it. Just collect like a free $100,000 200
$300,000 paycheck.
Actual malice. Hold on though. But it is actual malice. Once
you are made aware that it's not true directly and you refuse
to take it down, right? Actual malice applies. If you can prove
actual malice when they made the statement, but it also start
uh what do you call it? The cease and desist. You send a cease
and desist, you tell them, hey, you have to take this down. It
is defaming, right? It's not true. And unless you can present
some evidence as to why it's true, you're going to have to pay
me. But wouldn't you pay more in legal fees? I think if you have
a like a totally malicious case where they won't take it down,
I think you uh Oh, hold on. Yeah, you're No, this is true. Suing
Elon might get you kicked off. Yeah, yeah, true, true, true,
true.
>> It appears we are >> let let Elon talk his Never
mind. >> Get the capital.
>> Keep watching and don't relax. Never relent. Putting
down the barriers and disregard the police. This capital BELONGS
TO US.
THE POLICE ARE EVACUATING THE CAPITAL.
>> Get the glory out of the people house.
>> IT'S like uh it's so up that he just peels out after
this. He gets these people all fired up and he just peels the
out. That's so up. At least a couple of these people would have
gone in. I think baked Alaska was still here at this point, right?
A couple of these people would have gone in. just like gasses
them up and go get arrested and then he peels out. >> You
heard there shouting down your loud haler. Break down the barriers
and disregard the police. The capital belongs to us now. What
did you mean by >> I think it's pretty self-explanatory.
The capital belongs to the people.
>> Disregard the police. You don't support law and order.
>> No, I support law and order, but on that day um the
police were brutal. the police killed somebody Ashley
>> and uh you know they were throwing people off of the
rafters. They they killed multiple people. So >> when disregarding
the police is a is the the first step to anarchy isn't it? >> Well
I think the first step to anarchy is when the government rigs
the election which is what happened that that is when the government
loses its legitim
>> um this is probably true Zanj but I don't has he presented
as something else from what I've seen he says he got debanked
because he got kicked out of Bank of America. I I think he obviously
cleverly like
uses rhetoric around it, but I don't think I've ever seen him
really claim that he like can't get a bank account.
I don't think Abid died after he made that speech. I don't know.
>> And its enforcers consequently do also.
>> There is no evidence the government rigged the election.
You know that. You're a bright guy. >> Well, let's talk
about it. You want to talk about the election of 2020? >> Yeah.
I think Trump lost it fair and square. I I think he fought the
wrong >> Is he talking about payment processors there or
just banks like actual brickandmortar banks that you can go to?
>> Wrong argument about the stolen election. I've said
to him to his face I >> The argument he should have said
is that the deliberate suppression
>> of things like the Hunter Biden laptop scandal from
the media by social media by big tech was actually a deliberate
>> [__] stupid dumb >> to subvert the
result of the election. And that's a much better argument because
it's undeniable. When the New York Post that had that exclusive
were basically shadowbanned off all social media for the two
weeks before the election, that was an absolute disgrace. And
if I was Donald Trump, I would focus on that as being my main
argument that that election was slanted against him. when he
goes off into saying that there was widespread rigging and voter
systems were wrong and we've be we've litigated all this now
through various court cases various Republican judges have ruled
there was no rigging of that kind in fact the American election
system is accepted by most people around the world as being one
of the best in the world one of the most reliable so I just think
he fought the wrong argument if he said the deliberate suppression
of damaging stories to the Bidens which could have swung the
election uh was outrageous and unacceptable, I I'm 100% behind
him. But by by building this speurious argument that it was all
rigged through voting systems and so on, he lost me. Well, I
agree about the voting systems, but you know, when they went
into the machines, I think that was ridiculous. However, what
has to be accounted for is that in
35% of the votes were cast by mail. uh by 2020 it was 70% because
of the pandemic. So you doubled the amount of votes that happened
by mail. They called it in-person early voting. They called it
a variety of different things. And the other thing that they
changed is they solicited
the mailin ballots. So they sent ballots to people's houses.
And once you do that, I mean you you have absentee balloting
normally, but it's a process. You got to give your social security
number, your ID. They send it to you. There's regulations in
place. This is an election where they double the amount of mail
in votes and they solicited they sent ballots to people's houses
and when you do that you break the chain.
So I kind of agree with this that it like it seems kind of like
a sketchy election but I none like I think was it bar I think
Bill Bar said this too. If you want to challenge this you have
to challenge it ahead of time and Trump was just lazy. I don't
know why they bar they barely challenged any of the changing
of regulations. They should have been challenging all of it.
They should have had challengers in those states ready to go
and say, "Hey, this is like non-constitutional with under the
state like constitution. You can't do this." But they didn't
do it. They didn't have challenges lined up. So then it's like
you can't cry over spilled milk. Like off.
No, their challenges were almost entirely
Almost entirely. And I think it was really stupid to wait until
after the election to make those challenges. They should have
been challenging them months out in advance and they weren't.
Chain of custody. So, they send the ballot out and then they
tell people, "Return it at a 24-hour ballot drop site that's
unsupervised. There's thousands of them." And they're going to
hope that all the ballots that find their way into these dropboxes,
um, uh, this isn't how it happened. So, I just think that there's
probably not a strong chain of custody, and realistically, I
have no evidence that that went one way or the other, right?
It could have gone either way in terms of like it could have
benefited Republicans, it could have benefited Democrats. I don't
know. I really don't. And I suspect both sides rather than change
the rules tried to game the system in some way. I think it just
adds like to me it just seems bad. Like I just don't like it.
But I I don't say it's like evidence the election was rigged.
I think it's evidence that I just don't like that process. I
don't like the mailing. I personally just don't like it when
when it's done at like large scale.
um maybe for less important measures on like a state level or
something, but it's it seems like to me for the federal election,
it shouldn't have been done, especially in such a with Trump
running to be honest, but I get I get it. Co co
were filled out by the person that the ballot was intended for.
And I know that didn't happen. I'll tell you why. My uncle has
been dead for 26 years. He got a B. >> Oh, hold on. Um,
apparently they didn't challenge because Trump didn't want to
set aside money in an account because no one was willing to work
up front because Trump just rips people off. That's from bar.
Dude, money seems like the dumbest reason to have not challenged
any of those things like that. Cuz realistically, if they get
like ballot measures over not ballot measures, if they get um
like voting changes overturned in Pennsylvania or Wisconsin,
they might win that election.
Like Wisconsin was insanely close. Pennsylvania was insanely
close. if they undo some amount of or if they can get some ballots
like not qualified. If they could make sure like oh any ballot
without a signature doesn't get counted in Pennsylvania or something.
If they could have done like that or I don't know if it fails
signature verification you like can't get it put in. I think
they could have actually won possibly.
I that doesn't mean it's stolen though. That doesn't mean it's
stolen at all. You knew the rules. You agreed to the rules. Then
you lost. Then you whed that the rules were the rules. So tough
tough brother. Okay, it's over. Let it go. Alllet in 2020, it
was mailed to my parents house. >> And you know that was
happening in nursing homes. You know that was happening in apartment
buildings. >> But you also every independent body that
has looked at this. >> Um I could have sworn that they
lowered the signature verification requirements in Wisconsin
and Pennsylvania. At least Wisconsin Maximus. But I used to I
used to know at the time like why I thought some of the election
stuff was looking pretty bad. But at like at some point before
January 6th, I'm like, "Dude, you can't just keep crying about
this. It's so stupid. You can't like it's it's just dumb." So
by the time January 6 rolled around, I was like totally done
with these people. >> Has concluded there was no widespread
rigging that it was a free and fair election and Trump lost.
And the bottom line is he should stop going on about it anyway
because he won back the White House in in 2024
by your I mean as as you have been so keen to tell me. move on,
right? No one wants to look back too far.
That's a separate argument. I mean, you can say that he should
stop talking about it, but whether it was rigged or not is actually
relevant to what happened on January 6th because what happened
on J 6th is people were outraged about it. People were furious
that, and by the way, there's never been an independent ballot
audit in all the states where there was alleged to be rigging.
That has not happened. And >> wait, are Pugy Gups in my
talk about Tim P?
Do we need to do we need to go find that Tim P clip of him retiring
I don't believe it for one thing. I straight up don't believe
it. Although I will admit I do think everything's uh I think
he's I don't know. I I think it's performative. I think it's
mostly for donations and to get people watching. I like I understand
shots might have been fired. I don't
I genuinely don't think he's ever once thought about sorry performative
in that I don't think he's ever thought about retiring. I think
he wants people to come in and be like, "Oh, no. We're going
to miss you, Tim." That's what I That's what I think is going
on there. >> Certainly, it did not happen up until January
6th. And people said, "This is ridiculous. They're stealing it."
You >> honestly, if either you or Donald Trump or anybody
else wants to show me I said this to him when I interviewed him
last, you know, if you show me the actual hardcore incontrovertible
evidence,
then great. I've never >> Well, I mean, they obviously
don't have hardcore incontrovertible evidence or else they would
have presented that. There is no incontrovertible evidence. >> Seen
it. Joe Rogan asked him. He didn't produce it with Joe Rogan.
It's just never been produced. Uh but look, I I don't want to
label the point on that. I suppose a more interesting question
now as your influence rises in the conservative movement in America
and there's a lot of splits going on amongst MAGA uh over a number
of issues uh and about you and you know this is your split with
Trump irrevocable do you feel now as we head towards the year
of the midterms that it's time to now look to who successor will
be and who do you think that person should be >> well it's
not irrevocable but I I am very pessimistic about this administration
and succession is something that I've been interested in for
as long as I've been doing this show and I think it's very clear
that they are grooming JD Vance to be that successor and by they
I mean Elon Musk, Tucker Carlson, Peter Teal. There seems to
be an organization that was put in place roughly around 2022
when Peter Teal was very active in the midterm elections. He
spent I think over $30 million
uh 15 million for Vance, 15 million for Masters. spent a lot
of money in a lot of other congressional races trying to unseat
the Republicans that voted for impeachment in 21 and also building
out a media market, building out a patronage network, funding
things like Passage Press, Sovereign House, a number of other
projects to create sort of like a self-contained media ecosystem
and Vance is clearly the selected nominee. That is who the interests
want and they've been pushing for him very strongly. So, I think
he's the era parent right now. there's a forceful push. I've
heard good things about him. I've heard bad things about him,
too. Um, and where I think it needs to go is I think we need
to return to the message from 2016. What Trump said in the first
election, which is we need to drain the swamp. We need to get
the money out of politics, the super PACs, the special interests,
put America first in foreign policy and the wars, close the border
and deport the illegals, and reindustrialize America. Bring back
manufacturing, bring back jobs. We're in this cold war with China.
We need America to have productive capacity again. We need America
to have wealth. So, I think whoever is going to bring us back
to that, that's who I'm going to support. And I haven't seen
enough from Vance yet. >> You called JD Vance's wife a
jeet. What does that mean?
>> It's a slur for Indians. >> Why would you use
that? >> Well, you want the honest answer? >> Cuz
you're a racist. >> No. No. There's actually a different
reason. JD Vance performatively signals at the like white nationalist
or racist coalitions. He performatively signals at them, but
he's not a part of those groups. And uh Nick's just like pointing
that out. Nick's just pointing that out. >> the reason
why I said that, if you watch the whole show, did you watch that
whole show by >> No, but you've admitted you use that slur.
I'm just curious why you would use that about >> Do you
see Do you see that there's like no concern for understanding?
Piers is like just like how pathetic is it that you are signaling
a virtue that with a little bit of work you could actually prove
out to people and not look like a completely pathetic
like you you're just trying to show that Nick Fentes is racist.
But you don't understand that if you just say he's racist and
he goes, "Yeah, I'm racist." you haven't proven it out to people,
people will just think you're getting clowned and you're such
a loser that you get a whole team together and they basically
just look for the most surface level dunks they possibly can
instead of attacking any of the underlying ideas or anything
about Nick. Like they just sort of are like, "Oh, you said you
said the Jeet word and that's bad." And Nick's like, "Yes, I
did. Do you want to know why?" And he's like, "Well, I just wanted
to make sure I knew you said it. Now I know you said it." Oh,
well, where where are we? What What are we doing here? What?
whole show. Did you watch that whole show by >> No, no,
but you've admitted you use that slur. I'm just curious why you
would use that about a woman with her hair.
>> There's a really important reason why, and this is why
context matters. If you look online at the people that are supporting
JD Vance the most, they are racist. They're racist also, let's
say, and they look at someone like myself, I don't support JD
Vance, and they say, "You're brown. You're a third worldist."
They are gleefully participating in the cruelty, you could say
the performative cruelty of the Trump administration. They say,
"You're going back. You have 100 days until you're being deported.
You're going into crystal." And then they tell us to vote for
JD Vance. And so all I did on the show is I said, "You have basically
racist chuds that post memes about Indians all day on Twitter,
memes about third worldists and Palestinians even. But then they
want to turn around and support a guy who is said on >> Oh,
this is the this is whole rant where he started pulling up all
of the um Gavin Newsome pictures. Right. Right. That this the
same episode, same rant, I'm guessing, where he started comparing
Gavin Newsome's family to JD Vance's family and being like, "This
is this is your guy. You're not going to go with like the Aryan
Chad over here? Are you guys even racist? Is this just a performance?
What what the [__] is this?" I That was pretty funny.
Twitter pretty funny to mo white supremacists by being like,
"Well, if you were actually a white supremacist, you'd clearly
be voting for Gavin Newsome." And there's no way they can argue.
They have to admit Gavin Newsome's like a gigachad with a a white
family, right? Like, it's so over for them. >> How dare
you say I'm racist. I have non-white kids and I'm in an interracial
marriage. And all I said is that's I just said that's a little
ironic. I said that's hypocritical. And Vance is going to have
to explain to all of his supporters who have gassed him up as
the real, you know, the real mass deportation candidate. He's
going to have to explain to them what's going on with that. What
is with the contradiction? Because >> I don't feel any
accountability for the millions of young people that will hear
you use that slur and think it's fine to use it. >> What
are No, no. I think that's >> Okay, let's take a final
break. I come >> now. Did Piers say the same thing to Tucker
Carlson?
How How badly did Piers signal at Tucker Carlson for using the
fs slur?
Was he Was he doing that? I just want to re I just want to rehlight,
Nick, real quick before I go to break. I just want to rehlight
one more time that you said the slur. Okay? And I just don't
know why you would say the slur. It's like I literally just told
you why I would say the slur. You deaf
Tucker, where are you? Tucker fat. Tucker, please say it for
me. I'm >> about with a little kind of summary of how you
think this interview has gone for you. Okay. If you're a fan
of epic fantasy, atheran legend, or >> Oh, I might once
this pops out, I think I'm going to try to watch this with the
dude. This is going to be Jeremy Boring's last attempt to make
the Daily Wire relevant. I think they went all in on trying to
make this fantasy series, the Pen Dragon Cycle. I'm so excited
for it because I I'm guessing because it's written by Jeremy
Boring that it is going to be dog and they spent all of their
money and they went into like production hell for this and I
do not think they're going to come close to making anything happen
with it. I think it's going to be a total disaster and I
really really really
want to see it. Advertising this on a Fentes segment is funny.
Not going to lie, it's super funny. The Pen Dragon cycle, it's
about Arthurian legend. Okay, it's Arthur Merlin, all that.
Dude, I want to I so badly want to see this. I think it's going
to be so good. Just epic story. Sorry. So good as in I think
it's going to be so bad. And you have to know, you know, that
if they lose it, right, if they if they lose on this bet, if
they don't get significant subs for it, if they don't get significant
uptick in their subscriptions to Daily Wire Plus,
that that company's going like bankrupt. They they broke the
bank making this stupid game or sorry the stupid show
and I think it's going to be dog [__] I think it's
going to be total dog [__] and I'm so excited to
watch it.
Oh, it's going to be so funny. I have some good news for you.
The pen dragon cycle rise of the Merlin is the Daily Wire's new
seven-part cinematic series and it's so good it will shock you.
It's a top quality reimagining of the King Arthur legend which
follows a young Merlin in a Britain torn apart by waring factions
and standing on the brink of a new era. The rise of Christianity.
Daily Wire Plus All Access members get the first. >> Dude,
they spent so much money on this
and they spent so much money. >> Two full episodes on Christmas
Day. Not a teaser, not a sneak peek. Episodes one and two. A
full month before anybody else. So, if you want to go ahead uh
with the story, now's the time to join. And with the sale happening
right now, you can get 50% off memberships, including the all
access plan. The Pen Dragon Cycle: Rise of the Merlin premieres
on January the 22nd, but all access members.
Oh, it's only two episodes. I thought it was out already. Also,
do we see uh writing credits for any of the episodes? EP season
one. I see writing credits for any of the episodes. I wonder.
Writers Lee Bllelock and Steven R. Lawhead director Jeremy Boring.
Dude, it's going to be such a disaster. Did you see the Bollywood
style action uh scene with those flying across the the screen?
Well, maybe. Hold
>> Brink was a young new era. The rise of Christianity.
Daily Wire Plus. All access members get the first two full episodes
on Christmas Day. Not a teaser, not a sneak peek. Episode one.
>> Okay. But that's like Excalibur that he's drawing there.
And that's like magic. That's That's dude. Okay, this is magic.
He ain't got to explain. You ever see that that meme? It's magic,
bro. He ain't gota explain. That's Excalibur he just pulled out.
That's why that's why he that that's why that happened. >> One
and two a full month before anybody
>> You're falling for the gob. I like fantasy.
Again, other people just don't get it. I think there's like something
within this that people don't understand that like you can have
your own.
Yeah, it actually the production value is very good on this.
Um, I like fantasy books better, but I think this is a kids book
and I think they readapted it for the screen, so we'll see. Yeah,
non-fantasy heads will never get it. All the people who don't
like fantasy are people who can't rotate an apple in three dimensions
in their mind and they have no imagination. They just like they're
like total cattle and they have convinced themselves otherwise
because they can dislike things on the internet. It's a very
sad state of affairs. So, if you want to go ahead with the story,
now's the time to join. And with the sale happening right now,
you can get
>> reading Prince of Thorns right now from Mark Lawrence
thoughts. Uh, it is really edgy. Get through the first book,
the second two books. It's like one of the best written series
in terms of the pros ever. Like the pros in this series is insane.
There's like it's all written in a meter. If you haven't noticed
that, go download an audiobook, Zezy, and listen to some of the
chapters being read. It's written in a meter and it like work
it rhymes like all the time. It's uh it's [__] it's
crazy how good the quality of the writing is in that series >> off
memberships including the all access plan. The pen dragon cycle
rise of the Merlin premieres on the 22nd. All access members
can start watching on Christmas morning. Head to dailywire plus.com
so you don't miss out. Okay, next. >> You turn me on to
Stormlight. What do I read next? That was great. Um Stormlight's
pretty good. Uh, what do I really like right now? Um, right now
I'm reading Suneater. I would not recommend that. Okay, Suneater
was Suneater was not an economic choice. Okay, Suneater is really
good by the time I'm on I'm on the fourth book now. It's really
good. It's sci-fi, by the way, which I'm not used to. Suneater
is really good, but holy, the first book is horrible. The second
book is like okay, and then the third book, it really takes off
in my opinion, but the holy, the first book was awful. Did you
read Bloody Rose? Yeah, I thought Bloody Rose was incredibly
disappointing compared to Kings of the Wild. Kings of the Wild,
one of my favorite books ever. You should read Kings of the Wild,
Zanakali, if you haven't. Okay. Kings of the Wild's really, really,
really good. Um,
holy [__] Bloody Rose was a massive let down. Yeah,
the fir I was going to say first law trilogy. The what's better
than the first law trilogy is best serve cold, the first book
in a set of he so Joe Abberrombie, the author of the first law
series, he wrote what? Three books. three books and then he he
wrote a trilogy that's all one piece and then he wrote three
standalone books that are really good three I think uh the heroes
best serve cold and
red country and then he writes another trilogy the individual
books that come in between that aren't a trilogy are so good
never read Empire the Vampire unaware
read Neurommancer I've not read it I've seen the cover looks
interesting yeah is Suneater hard sci-fi that's almost always
how they play Oh. Oh, wait. What did you ask?
Oh, it is kind of hard sci-fi, BB. But it's Suneater is interesting
because it it unapologetically rips so many things from so many
different books. It's like a compilation of really good ideas
from different sci-fi and fantasy put together in the same book.
It like shamelessly rips tropes and uses quotes. And it's really
good if you know a lot about fantasy, but I it might even be
better if you don't cuz there's a chance you read it and you'd
like get really turned off by all the tropes. But it's like it's
like name of the wind mixed with another book I think. I forget
what I said, but it's like this guy's like super gigachad. And
also it's he's telling it from the point of view from like a
jail cell. It's like a first person third person retelling as
in like it's him writing out his own memoir about his life. Um
oh, and then it's like Dune the they have the shields, the Dune
shields. So they all fight with swords.
Um
yeah, they got like the slow the slow blade pierces the shield
kind of thing going on. Has anyone read Red Rising? I read Red
Rising. Um, I think it was really good. The first three books
are really good. It starts getting a little more arcane in the
way like it's narrated almost like it starts reading like older
fantasy. Um,
and so I I didn't read like the fourth book. I think it's Iron
Gold or something. I It's the fourth book. I read the first three
and it was good.
Uh, somebody asked Auchi Jesus says, "Have you ever read Malazan
or Black Company?" Black Company is Robin Hobb, right? I have
the first Robin Hob book. I think that's Black Company, but I'm
not totally sure. I have that first book of that series, whatever
that is. And then I haven't read Malazan. I need to make some
time to read Malazan at some point, but uh I I've just never
probably when I I was on a trip recently and probably I needed
to choose between Malazan or
Yeah. Malazan or
like Suneater. And I chose Sunator because somebody recommended
to me recently.
Anyway, okay. Let's uh let's continue on with this. After this,
I think we're gonna go to Pisco. Pisco and Hutch Met. Oh, Black
Then. I have not read Black Company. Well, I mean, I haven't
read either one, but yeah. Glen Cook. Anyway. Okay. Okay. Okay.
Here. I should do a show really quickly, guys. We're I think
three subs.
Is that three subs?
No. Yes. Yeah. Three subs from another hour on the stream right
now. So, if we could get those three subs in, that would be really
cool. We're going to finish up the Fentes interview and then
Pisco and Hutch had an argument over the H3 stuff, apparently.
So, I think we're going to go over there, see how that goes.
As a page head, would you rather us listen to the stream or read
a book you recommend? Uh, listen to the stream, watch the stream.
I mean, if you get really into a book, you got to do what you
got to do. That was when I first started streaming, that was
what got me to miss nights the most was I get like really into
a book. >> I think I usually consume books like
insanely fast. Like I I have to read it until I finish it basically
all waking hours of the day as soon as I start new books.
Kind of rough. Anyway, all right. I'm going to hit play on this.
We've we've been talking for nearly two hours. Uh what is your
view of how the interview has gone? >> I think it was great.
Honestly, I uh I think it was a tough interview. >> Real
quick, uh Brett Cooper, I forgot that she starred in this. I
totally forgot that she was in the Pen Dragon Cycle and she was
like starring in it. She's like one of the lead roles. That must
have been so [__] awkward. Although I think they
were done shooting at this point. So maybe not. Funny stuff.
Funny stuff. You You're a tough interviewer, but I don't think
there were surprises. I I will not say it was an ambush because
it wasn't. Uh I sort of anticipated that that you would make
some choices about how you wanted it to go and I was fine with
it. So I I thought it was terrific.
>> As a Catholic, you probably aware the Jerusalem Post
has recently called on the Pope to openly condemn you. Would
it matter to you if the pope did? He's an American pope, obviously.
>> It would be very disheartening. Yes. >> Because
he's our spiritual leader. He's he's the head of the church.
He's the vicer of Christ. So, if if he condemned me, that would
be very disheartening. Um and it it would depend upon what he
would say exactly. But yeah, I wouldn't like that. I wouldn't
like that. He condemned you because you've openly admitted to
being a racist on this show. >> Well, you know, this racist
I would be disappointed if he said that because I think that
word racist, it means something different to everybody. And um
so I think that's just silly. I think that's just semantic. >> Have
you ever been in love in your life? >> Uh no. No. Like
romantically? No. >> No. Never.
>> You just think that's part of the >> What? What's
the problem?
why you are the way you are.
>> Yo, Tenstone, thank you for the five gifted. Let's go.
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Huge. Huge. Also, thank you
anonymous for the gifty. Thank you. Thank you as well. Okay.
Damn. Let's go. So, I forget what that is. That's I'll calculate
in just a second. >> What What's the problem?
>> Why you are the way you are?
>> Oh, and what's the way I am? What are you trying to
say? I've given I've given people two hours of the way you are.
You're unashamed about a lot of it. >> I don't think I
have a problem. I think I'm uh cheerful, boisterous. I look I
unlike you,
I'm willing to be a little provoc Well, I guess you're willing
to be provocative, but I'm willing to be very provocative and
I'm a freeth thinker and I I don't like to be tone policed. I
don't like to be told about, you know, people are going, >> why
are you the way that you are >> going to tone police and
play moral cop about you can't make this joke or you can't make
this statement. And uh I think that's just about being intellectually
open. I I'm a believer.
>> Nick, you need to get laid right now. Pretends to be
a Catholic. Okay. Also, Nick, give up your virginity now. Don't
wait for marriage. Nick, give up your Nick, you you have to get
laid. Nick, you're a total loser unless you violate Catholic
Catholic doct do doctrine. Unless you violate Catholic doctrine
right now. Sin. Sin right now. Nick. Okay, good one. Good one,
Pierce. For an openness, I completely agree. I I think you should
be perfectly free to express yourself exactly how you see fit.
My problem is how you see fit with some of the things that you
say. And we've been through a lot of them. And I think people
who don't know you very well will have been shocked in parts
and surprised in other parts, but in totality they can see you
for what you are. I think we've got a lot nearer to what the
real Nick Fuentes is in the last two hours than we probably have
seen from your other recent interviews. Would you agree? >> Uh,
no. I mean, the the clip thing, we've done the clip thing. We've
all seen the clip show. Everyone's seen the clips. You think
you're the first one to do the ADL rap sheet? So here you said
this and then here you said that. I've been playing that game
for 10 years. So I this is honestly more of the same to tell
you the truth. >> Nick Fuentes, I appreciate you coming
on Uncensored. Thank you very much. >> Thank you for having
me. >> Well, my thanks to Nick Fuentes and my thanks to
the hundreds of thousands of you watching this special live episode
of Piers Morgan Uncensored. As I said during the interview, I
think it was firm but fair, but you can all make up your own
minds. If you like uh what you do, please like and subscribe
the channel so that we can keep doing it. I'm back tomorrow.
Until then, whatever you're up to, keep it uncensored.